It's fucked up.
Do it.
Kevin Smith.
We did it again.
Is it happening?
Yes sir.
We're there.
We're here with live.
Um,
this took a while to bring together.
So nice to see you.
They see you before we go any farther or
far at all or do anything.
Let me just throw out there.
I was telling somebody like,
what are you doing today?
I was like,
I'm going to go talk to Joe Rogan.
Then I launched into my leg 10 minute
Joe Rogan pitch and at the end of it the
person I was talking to goes,
oh,
like you,
you've known him a long time as I've
talked to him like twice.
She was like,
you just went on a passionate tirade
about them and I said,
I got it.
I don't know how to explain it,
but I love the way he lives.
Like every I've,
I've loved the man since news radio and
then I like meeting the man and,
and speaking with them on a previous
podcast,
both his mind but not just that.
And I love your philosophy.
I love the way you do life.
You handle it like the way I would if I
was you,
like this is the best compliment I could
give,
but I'm not using them gutless and I
lived through your instagram like I was
like,
this is how a man lives.
If only I could be this man.
So coming here is.
It's an absolute fucking pleasure.
I thought we're going to your house.
But that happened years ago apparently
moved out of the house so people got
creepy.
This is too many.
Too many creepy people like when you
don't want them coming to your house,
but you do want them on the podcast and
shit.
When I went like this,
it must have been awhile ago because
Megan was still working for me and she
drove me and she like had to take a
leak.
Pissed outside.
Our podcast was so long and then I felt
bad.
I was like,
maybe that's why he's not having to be
back at the house.
He's like bringing him to a satellite
office because he let's his assistant
void in the yard.
I'm feeling fucking dope,
sir.
Let me tell you why I made this movie
called Yoga hosers that just finally
came onto Netflix and I took it to
sundance in January and they bent me
over and just critically speaking and
we're just hate fucking it.
They hated this movie.
A lot of people were viewed it from the
moment we announced it,
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm going to make a movie with my
daughter and giant depths in his
daughter's going to be a two and right
away I saw like fucking long sharp
knives now and so as expected it goes to
sundance and you know,
so I'm not saying this movie is for
everybody.
It's for like 10 people in the world,
but the 10 people that love it,
love it.
Like religion.
And so have you always done that though?
You just kind of do what you like to do
in my life.
I could turn it around.
Turn on you.
What I like about what you do is you
are,
you're very much an accepted inside guy
who lives like some guy from Jersey who
is trying to break into the business
like this is useful because you never
really understand how people
professional,
see you know,
how the world sees you because they'll
tell you in any given moment,
Joe,
normal or sally,
normal people live in the real world and
shit,
but your peers and people like we work
in entertainment and shit.
How you tell your very unaffected.
You're a uniquely unaffected Casa.
Like ineffective.
Same time.
I know you're very effective.
You're effective at doing what you enjoy
and that's why you have such a unique
and loyal fan base is because they know
that.
It's like in this world,
there's not a whole lot of unique
visions.
There's a lot of ideas.
They get brought to producers and
executives and a bunch of people pile in
and it becomes more of a an idea where
it's trying to appeal to a broader
audience and it switches up and then
someone wants to bring a love interest
or there's all sorts of influences that
happen that homogenize as you drink some
milk.
I know that was a different time.
Is Milk.
Oh my Lord.
That was perfect.
Perfect timing of a standup comic.
Loving my.
It does really.
That's the best word for it because even
though if it's good like you,
you,
you don't feel like that guy like
Tarantino is one of the unique guys
were,
even though it's movies,
have these gigantic mega blockbusters,
it feels like he's doing his own thing
yet.
Feels like this crazy fucker just got
the money and the wheels and they're
listening to him because he's Tarantino.
Your movies at the same kind of feel
connects with more people.
There's more of a like,
oh yeah,
that's cool.
It's cinema of cool because you could
just look out even if you don't have an
experiential connection to it,
like,
oh,
I once went to a fifties cafe as per
your,
just like that looks bad at St John
Travolta,
dancing on the Thurman.
That's bad as all the way.
Everything about it is just like cinema
of cool and fed by a lifetime of movie
loving and a movie diet.
Yeah,
so if you love movies,
here's a guy that distills everything.
That's the essence of Cool of cinema and
I don't want to keep hitting the cool
belks people like,
come on.
It's a hipster term,
but it.
It does distill it down to those
moments.
Not so much like massive arcs,
but whew,
this feels awesome.
That's dope.
Oh,
that's metal.
Well,
yeah,
you have that same kind of thing.
Your.
Your movies are very.
Well,
it's.
You're the only one like comedies in
particular,
like that was one of the more
interesting and unique things about red
state because I had no,
you didn't tell me a word about it.
He said,
I don't want you to know nothing.
His coincide here that I meant to me and
me and Marilyn sit there and watched it
and at the end of it we were like,
Holy Shit.
Like Holy Shit.
Like what the fuck was that?
He was crazy.
He wasn't a comedy.
Adam.
It's nice like throw them a curve and be
like,
oh,
he's not.
We thought we saw everything.
Like I always felt.
Most people saw me as like,
oh,
he did clerks and then he's done about
96 variations.
People need to see red state.
If you haven't seen red state,
that is A.
I don't want to say too much because I
want people to go into it the way I went
into it.
Just go see that fucking movie.
But that's another movie where even
though it wasn't like the same,
it was
still a unique voice.
You know?
It's like,
I think,
I don't know what it's like to make a
movie,
but it's got to be.
The lot of people have a lot of say
emerges is bigger.
The budget,
the more you know you have to listen to
a bunch of more people and you can't be
unreasonable about if you get him
tremendous amounts of success like jj
Abrams and you're a nice guy at the same
time,
you know you can get away with being
like,
I'm going to do whatever I want and
people like what you want tends to work,
so here go nuts,
but generally speaking,
the more money you accept,
the more input you also have to accept
lower the budget and if it's coming out
of your pocket,
you don't gotta say Shit to anybody.
Nobody can tell you anything,
but you know,
if you're putting together something
small,
it's still a smaller circle of people.
It's kind of answered.
She's.
You always have to be willing to hear
what they're saying.
If somebody is willing to give you
ungodly matrimony and make pretend mind
you,
this is not like,
I'm going to give you funds and you're
going to give me eggs and I'm going to
sell those eggs and I'm going to make
more money selling those eggs.
They're like,
we're going to give you money and you're
gonna.
Take this goofy fucking idea you have
and try to make it real and turn it into
a movie that may work or may not work.
It's all a crapshoot.
It's like buying a lottery ticket to
much degree.
No guarantees that they'll ever be an
audience for it.
So I learned that midway my career and
realized,
well,
just work for you.
It sounds masturbatory,
but it's like if you are the audience
that you're trying to hit,
then you'll always be satisfied.
You know?
It's like if you want other people to
like it,
it's subjective and you may not find
that people dig what you're doing and
you know,
if you're looking for monetary success,
good luck.
Nobody can guess that.
Like even when marvel releases a new
movie and we know marvel is exceptional
at what they do,
put them in Pixar,
marvel,
pixar,
and care the best of the best.
Even when they release a movie,
they clench a little bit because
anything could happen,
anything could happen at all.
So generally speaking,
they're a little more insulated from
like,
Oh shit,
we lost money because actually those
marvel movies are so expensive now
because dude,
it's like,
same thing with the animated movies.
The animated movies are ungodly
expensive to make,
but they print money and they print
money,
not just the first time they come out at
the box office.
They print money through all the
licenses.
They print money where you know
sometimes you go like they're doing a
sequel to that.
Why,
why don't they do something new?
Because they've already built the world.
It's already there in a computer and
they're like,
oh,
we need a new script and we're good.
We've done our infrastructure.
Like when you think about it,
if you building something,
you built all this massive
infrastructure and spent three years
putting it together and did it once and
they were like,
okay,
everybody,
goodbye forever.
It's kind of a waste of everything you
put together.
That's why they immediately go for a
sequel.
A,
they know they're gonna make money,
but B,
they're gonna make more money because
they don't have to invest as much time
and money as they did the first time.
So that's what makes the studio go like,
oh,
that's easier,
that's low hanging fruit and everyone's
happy,
you know,
it's not like they're making art films
that only a few people,
like generally they tend to make flicks
that a bunch of people want to go see
and that riles up people that want to
see newer films or something like that
because like why is it always the same
movie over and over again?
But you know,
I submit to you,
if you're going to see a superhero
movie,
expect a little fucking sameness.
It's a story of like an exceptional
being with powers that others don't and
hopefully that person will use it for
good.
You know,
you can only cut that cheese so many
fucking times where and say it's
something new.
I think to watch men took it to a new
place and I love the watch,
but at the end of the day it's just like
people in mass doing the right thing and
you they fucked in space,
but other than that there was people in
mass trying to do the right thing.
They were murdered.
The murdered each other.
Does that get caught up in Batman v
Superman?
I heard there were some murders in that
movie,
that movie.
I was like,
did they say somebody fucking died in
prison and over Batman,
you know,
they went in strange directions,
but after a year of a like just taking
it over a movie that nobody saw,
it didn't really come out.
Eventually restored it and stuff like
that.
Yoga is just finally goes to Netflix and
I just want to go back and like,
here,
let me just assure people there's
something you want to do.
Do it.
Like as long as it doesn't hurt
somebody,
especially if it's something like make
something like a movie or fucking comic
book or whatever.
Fuck.
Don't worry about the consequences.
There was a moment throughout this year,
I was like,
fuck,
what was I?
Why would I was stoned?
Why did I make that movie?
Like,
Oh my God,
I'm a fucking idiot and stuff and I
forgot somewhere along the way that like
when I made it and this isn't a cop out
of like I didn't make it for everybody,
but I did kind of targeting audience for
it and I knew going in that it was going
to have this weird life to get to where
it is.
I made it for tween girls specifically.
I was like,
maybe other people could enjoy it,
but this is for tween girl the way.
Like when I was a boy,
I was clicking on cable.
I found strange brew starring Bob and
Doug Mackenzie and I was like,
oh my God,
like I've never heard of this before.
How come nobody ever heard of this?
This is mine.
Like you have a sense of ownership to
it.
It changed my life.
It's one of my favorite movies and
informed what I would become in life.
The conduct kind of comedy that
afterwards by Bob and Doug Mckenzie.
Think about a dude I made Jay and silent
Bob.
You don't get to Jay and silent Bob
Without Bob and Doug.
Mackenzie is not a direct line from
cheech and Chong.
Jay and Bob,
right.
That's like I want to make a movie.
I got a daughter and she's 17 now,
but for years I was always trying to
take her to like flicks where it's not
iron man,
spiderman,
superman,
Batman.
It's like,
hey,
is are fucking lady up in the mix here.
That's not just like and black widow
somebody who's now they're making a
wonderful movie.
But.
So I said,
you consider I don't curse the darkness
or you can make light a candle.
So I was like,
all right,
like let's make this thing that I'm
trying to take the kid to that I could
never find and shit.
And she got an acting.
So she's in it and she's.
The reason I did it,
if wasn't for her,
I wouldn't have tried it and shit.
But she had a small role in Tusk.
I thought she did good.
So I spun off her character and her
friendly rose's character into this
whole movie.
So when I was making it as being good
for like,
you know,
you want to talk about playing a game of
darts,
it's like you're not going after anybody
between girls.
And I knew in that moment I was like,
it's going be a long time before they
get it.
They're not going to find it in
theaters.
A fucking weird hybrid.
Midnight moved to stone or flick.
The villains are one foot tall.
Canadian Nazis made a bratwurst called
razzies,
like a fucked up weird ass movie.
So they'll find it like the way I found
strange brew on cable.
I had this dream like too simple dreams
in regard to this poster I want in
regards to this movie.
I want to post or two girls just
standing next to each other and they're
not like fighting over a fucking boy or
something like that.
But just hanging out the way.
Like Dante and Randall hung out on my
clerks poser and then like that,
it eventually wind up on Netflix or some
streaming service.
That's like a midst hundreds,
thousands of other movies and some tween
girls clicking through one day,
bored as shit and watched everything and
suddenly sees the picture of like two
girls,
10 next to each other,
the hockey stick and little sausage men
and going like,
what's that?
And it becomes their religion,
their strange brew or something.
You know,
you can't always go for the world.
I'm,
it'd be nice if you can satisfy
everybody,
but you're trying to satisfy yourself.
It sounds very massive betrayal,
but the same time it's like,
I hope people go on the journey.
Um,
but I understand if they can't,
like sometimes we go in directions where
the audience,
the entire audience can follow us.
I'm sure you got some people who love
you are like,
yeah,
I don't dig on mma,
but I love everything else you do.
It's like they could go partially.
They can't go all the way with you
sometimes.
And I get that,
especially lately I've been making
movies that are real,
like fucking dare,
like not daring,
but like I dare you to fucking get
through this.
You know,
it's a real like clearly he's given,
doesn't give a shit about the audience
anymore.
He's just making shit to watch their
reaction change and it's not true.
There's something there and stuff,
but I know that it's a used to be a
wider bridge people could cross to get
to me and now the bridge is getting
smaller and smaller because I'm like,
you gotta like this,
you got to be interested in this.
Like Tusk,
the movie I made after redstate is a
movie about a guy tried to tries to turn
another guy into a walrus.
You really got to be in the mood to see
a fucking weird batshit stupid movie
that's intentionally like was this
fucking dumb.
He's serious and like it plays.
It's so straight and shit like we're
argo.
So clearly I'm in a very experimental,
like,
let me fuck around.
I've done enough.
I feel good.
Let me fuck around.
And it finally paid off as the point of
this whole story.
Like after a year get mass kicked online
and people being like,
he fucking lost it and shit.
Now that audience is starting to find
it.
Now that it's on Netflix,
all of a sudden I'm hearing from fucking
tween girls that like the movie and
parents have twin girls.
They're like,
oh my God,
how many of them are like 40 year old
dudes?
Pretend I hope it is.
I hope it's all of them do.
I don't give a shit.
It's I'll take them all if they were all
40 year old dudes that said Nice things
about it.
After a year of people being like,
it blows.
It's nice to have people being like,
oh,
it blows on purpose or oh,
I get it,
or blah blah blah.
I got.
I gotta ask you this.
How much of your thought process when
you make something is worrying about how
it's going to be received or or dealing
with the people that don't like it?
Lately?
Not Anymore.
About about either,
but sooner or later there's a factor of
wanting to see because that has to do
with whether the thing makes money or it
goes at the box office.
How something makes money is completely
different now.
You never counting on like,
oh,
people will come out and see it in a
theater and shit like that.
Um,
you know,
there's a bunch of different revenue
streams at this point and stuff thanks
to the digital age,
but at that point when I'm making it,
you know,
of course you think,
hey,
somebody going to see it.
It's not like you're doing it in a,
in a,
you know,
kind of like an abyss and nobody's there
for you or something like that.
But at the same time,
you know,
you're,
when it's all done,
just stupid questions.
Like,
what do you know?
Uh,
what do you want the poster to look
like?
Dictates a commercial thought,
you know,
I can't say like,
I never think about that shit because
sooner or later somebody is going to ask
me a question that I have to,
you know,
where the like,
hey man,
we get it.
You may get it for you,
but you did take a few million bucks.
Like how do we sell this shit?
I don't get our money back.
You know,
so you know,
then you,
that's when you start going,
okay,
how do we get it to the right audience,
know more like how do we tailor it or
how do we fucking trick him into seeing
and,
or something like that.
Like put it on front street and then
dealing with the fallout.
Yeah.
I used to have to deal with a lot more.
I used to choose to deal with it a lot
more and now it's just like I'm 46.
I don't know what to tell you.
Like there was a person who came to one
of the screenings on the road.
We had the screening at fuck,
I forget where we were,
I want to say New Orleans and of Yoga
hosers I was doing q and a afterwards
and you know,
everyone's getting up and like,
oh,
it's fun,
it's fucking stupid.
And asking questions and then one guy
gets up and he is like tight dude.
He's very serious and he's just like,
uh,
okay.
You told the big long story before that
movie began.
There was a big intro for the movement,
began to like an hour long story of how
we got there.
And he goes,
that story did not match the movie I
just watched.
And I said,
no.
And he goes,
not at all.
why did you make that movie?
He's gone.
I found that unwatchable and everyone in
the audience has gone.
Oh.
And I was like,
no many,
he paid like he overpaid to see this
movie if I'm sitting here talking.
So yeah,
let him say what he wants and I'm a big
boy and fine.
And so he goes,
I just don't think you ever should have
made it.
It's terrible.
And I said,
well,
you understand that subjective,
right?
Like you're surrounded by a bunch of
people that feel like the opposite way.
So you know,
when people were applauding and shit.
And then some guy behind him in line
jumps in front of the mic and goes,
you want me to kick his ass?
And I was like,
Oh fuck no.
I was like,
everyone's entitled to their opinion,
but his opinion is I never should have
done this.
And you know,
my answer to that is like,
that's ridiculous.
Like if I wanted to make it,
like that's the only reason we're here,
I just want to see it.
Like you can choose not to see it.
And in this instance I'm really sorry
that you didn't,
our tastes didn't coincide,
but every time I go to do one of these
things,
I do it the same way,
whether it was clerks have to the most
recent one,
I just make the movie I want to see and
hopefully others like it and sometimes
they do.
And that's amazing.
It feels great and you're like,
Holy Shit,
my fingers on the pulse
and sometimes you're fucking alone,
but at least you're like,
I'm happy with the thing that I made.
I said,
but I feel heartbroken that you came out
here looking for something I didn't give
you.
So I said I'm going to give you your
money back.
And I gave him 40 bucks and I was like,
put it on the,
there's like a riser speaker.
And he goes,
I don't want that.
And I was like,
no man.
Honestly,
it take,
it's not a trick,
it's not like Jason Who's going to come
out and hit you with a hammer,
just take it like I feel bad.
I want you to have a good time and shit
like that.
And he goes,
no,
I don't want that.
And I was like,
dude,
it makes for an excellent story.
Like I told him his movie fucking blue
to his face and I fucking took his money
and walked out and he goes,
no.
And he went and sat down and crossed his
arms and just stayed there for another,
like half hour during the q and a.
So for him it was worth the 40 bucks
just like I'm going to visual verbal,
just sit here and fucking hate on this
and let you know and then sit down
again.
So you know,
you deal with that.
But that's the memorable one because
that never happens.
Generally speaking,
like when we toured the movie,
you're touring and you're in a safe
zone.
It's like going out and doing a club
night.
It's like people there are there because
they love you.
They're not going to wonder if this
fucking tween sausage movie is for me,
like they're already dialed in on some
part of the journey,
like,
oh,
I've loved task,
or have been with him since clerks or so
forth and so on.
I feel like I'm rambling.
Let's talk about.
No,
no,
you're not rambling at all.
It's interesting because the
relationship that you have to the people
that buy your stuff is very direct.
You know,
I mean,
you also have a podcast,
so you talk about things in a pretty
open and honest way like this and you
know,
you expressed vulnerability,
which,
uh,
makes people super uncomfortable that
your experience,
not,
it doesn't make me uncomfortable,
but in the world and just tell people
like,
oh,
I fucked up and I'm stupid,
or fat or my small.
They're like,
hey man,
hey,
that's too much.
But I think there's,
there's two factions.
There's one faction that that enjoys it.
And they go,
Hey,
Kevin Smith is just like me.
He's kind of fucked up just like I am.
Nobody ever gets it together.
And then there's like,
there's the facts.
And like God,
I wish she was like,
will Smith Will Smith just seems to have
his shit together.
Always like will smith just keeps
knocking it out of the only reasons
because we share that last name.
That's why there's an expectation
connecting with a guy who never failed.
Anyone I've talked to says you should be
more like will smith had never failed
guy like name and time.
Wilson?
Yes.
Look,
I'm with you.
Generally speaking,
he always gets jiggy with it,
but there have been,
there have been moments where he too,
you know,
we saw him be mortal.
Wild.
Wild West was one of the first ones to
tiny,
but they still got to a point,
but there've been a couple of flicks
recently,
including the one he did with his kid.
He got punished for making a movie with
this kid as well and he's raising those
kids in a real interesting way.
That's where,
that's where he gets most of his flag.
His son,
his
son's all about star dust and shit.
His daughters not that far off.
Really?
Yeah.
They're both.
They're both really creative kids,
but they have been raised in a world
level much different than the world that
most people are raised and nothing wrong
with that,
but it's produced very interesting
results.
Yeah,
and it's when you're.
If you're,
I guess if you had that sheltered,
like your data,
some super movie star type character,
your transition to regular,
ordinary adulthood has probably like
super confusing.
I got,
I got one kid and I'm not fucking will
smith by any stretch of the imagination.
I ain't even fucking Joe Rogan,
which is not saying you ain't will
smith,
but that's a kind of.
It's so.
But I got,
you know,
I've,
I've done some shifts and some people
know me and stuff and I got a kid and I
was talking to her recently and it came
out that she was like,
well it's,
yeah,
it can be hard to be your daughter.
And I was like,
what are you talking about?
I was like,
I put you in things.
I'm Megan and stuff.
And she goes,
no,
it's not the.
You make it hard.
It's that there's this expectation like
you did something and now if I don't do
something,
what the fuck?
And I'm like,
oh,
don't worry about that.
I said,
no,
I did one thing like 22 fucking years
ago and,
and that's,
that's it.
Like all you have to do is find one
tricky can take your whole life if you
need to.
But I said nobody expects you to be me
and this is a common theme.
But like I've had a moment like this
before once with like Scott Mosier,
the guy that I do smart cast with and I
made like all the early flicks with
like,
he would always say,
it's tough to live in your shadow.
And I was like,
what?
Shadow?
We make everything together.
And he goes,
well we make your stuff.
And every time I think about going to
make something,
I got to compare it to the shit that we
made together.
And it makes me go,
well maybe I'm not ready to try it.
And I was like,
well I'm,
that's not my fault.
He's like,
I'm not saying it's your fault,
it's just tough to,
to live in your shadow and you know,
I thought maybe that was his thing years
later,
the same shit from my wife.
She's like,
it's just tough to live in your shadow.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
We don't even do the same things.
And she's like,
but I can't even think about doing
things now without thinking,
well he's kind of done something like
that or is it going to be compared to
something he does and I'm like,
you're already your mind.
Everything I do fails and nobody ever
holds it as a high watermark.
So it's not like they would hold you to
some same high standard that they don't
even hold me too.
So there's a bit of that man now my kid
is echoing in a little bit where through
no fault of my own,
not like I've created this,
you know,
like live up to my standard.
I'm like,
everyone do what you want,
man.
Even with the kid,
I've never talked to her like a kid.
I've always talked to her like an adult,
but now even my kid is just like,
yeah,
it makes it tough to go do something
because of you and it's not like you did
it but you do a lot and,
and there's a high bar and I'm like,
ain't got you.
It makes me feel bad.
It makes me go like,
alright,
do less.
But then like I got one life.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I got to accomplish a lot before my
man died.
60 seven.
Like I don't know how long I'm going to
live,
but I want to accomplish as much as I
can and create and do shit and
experience things and enjoy your time
here.
It's like,
and I don't want to take away from all
these other people's time.
You know what I'm saying?
I want her to enjoy her time and my wife
to enjoy her time and Scott to enjoy his
time.
But the sad fact of the matter is in
order for you to rise,
usually someone in your life falls and
it's not a precipitous like,
oh,
I've fucking broken.
But they can't be rising like you when
they're helping you build your shit.
That's something I had to learn to deal
with way early on in my career.
I used to take advantage of people and
not in the way of like,
well I'm trying to take advantage of
you,
but I was like,
oh,
we're just working on my thing because
what else would we be working on?
And Hey,
isn't this all great that we're working
period and stuff and you forget that not
everybody started wanting to do your
thing.
Like Scott's whole thing was,
you know,
I didn't go to film school to become a
producer of your movies.
I went to film school to write and
direct and I've been having a great time
doing your stuff,
but that meant 10 years of me not even
trying to do the thing that I went to
keystone.
So it's a weird feeling.
Men especially because I never really
feel successful.
I've never like,
well,
I understand what I understand.
I cast a wide shadow,
but I don't think it's a very long
shadow because I'm like,
there is no high bar here.
Kids,
there's a high bar and as much as like,
you know,
a smuggler,
but there's no like,
well he made the Matrix motherfucker
like how you're going to be the kid or
the guy who made the matrix or,
or the ladies that made the matrix now
like,
that would be tough.
I imagined growing up their kids like,
Amen your,
your parents made the matrix like,
yeah.
Hey,
let me ask you this because you probably
wouldn't know the answer to this before
we get back to the subject because the
subject is really important.
Obviously I'm using you like a therapist
and whatever the fucking happened to
that lawsuit.
Remember there was a lady who wrote a
book and she said that she had submitted
that book to those brothers that made
the matrix and that is the exact same
story.
And then it,
uh,
it went to court.
It did go to court.
Yeah,
it did go to court.
It's really interesting how similarities
between remember road in the actual
thing.
I don't remember because it was quite a
few years ago,
but I thought maybe you would,
you would know about this.
Snopes says it's false.
Snopes is a Hillary Clinton.
She'll organization.
They call the white man town.
I'll get political man.
This is the one place people should run.
It's not even real.
It's not real.
It's saw your instagram posts on
election day.
Were you.
What happened?
It was a picture of the results.
Yeah.
I think that might've been the place
where I actually learned about the
results because I enjoy chaos to a
certain extent.
So I'm looking forward to this.
I really am.
I wouldn't be living at times is that I
would not have been interested in
Hillary Clinton doing the same goddamn
thing that she's been doing.
I just,
I don't,
I'm not a big fan of how he behaves as a
human.
What's up?
It's not false that uh,
it's false.
It's false that she won the,
the large judgement in 2005.
There was a case,
there was a court case and she,
I guess she never showed up to court for
her,
were a illuminary hearing.
Maybe because she was in the matrix.
Maybe they paid her,
disconnected her,
and she was fucking trapped and shit.
She saw cat on the way there twice and
she was like,
fuck,
it's entirely possible that she just got
paid.
That's the other option.
Like,
you know,
what was she,
how much was she necessarily what she
like,
I want half or she'll give me 50 grand.
I'll go away and make a good question.
But the Matrix obviously is a pretty God
damn big movie.
Apparently her story was remarkably
close.
I mean I look and I'm not taking
anything away from them or her,
but you know like they're archetypal
story and that movie is brilliant of
course,
but it's like nobody can really go like,
well,
I've never seen anything like that
before.
I mean it is Kinda like go to the Bible.
It's a Jesus story on some level,
right?
Like,
yeah,
messianic in nature,
but if you're talking about boogers or
in big batteries,
that power of fucking machine that we're
all in and plugs in our head,
then it gets very,
very close and that even.
But even that concept,
that of of one day we're going to live
in some sort of a virtual reality that
that's not new concepts.
Concepts and explored like you remember,
have you watched?
Are you watching westworld?
Oh yeah.
That's,
that is discussing that very subject
while being vastly entertaining and
you're like,
oh my God,
this is a great idea.
But also they are going into the idea of
consciousness and there are a few times
as you watched that show,
not where you're like,
are we in someone's fucking game?
But you start sitting there,
gone.
Everything we know about what we
understand to be reality except to be
reality is a social contract in many
ways like ideas and thoughts that we all
agree on and stuff about what is real,
what is important.
Like that's why when you meet people who
are like,
don't want to have kids,
you know,
some people like that's fucking weird.
It's like no,
their reality is kids are not a part of
the reality.
Never were like,
it's just not in them.
And stuff like that.
Um,
I think,
you know,
this year with the election we've seen
literally,
we've seen reality challenged.
The thing that we all understood to be
apparently was not.
And now,
you know,
things are vastly different.
Um,
I don't know where I'm going with that.
Saved me.
It's just,
it's just the,
the unique thing about it is that we
have been living under this illusion
that it either had to be one of these
people,
like a Democrat or one of these people
are Republican and that these people are
politicians and these are the people
that one presidencies I think,
you know,
I don't want us,
there's a faction out there and I don't
want to,
we should really just stay away from
this.
But I will look,
I'm a guy always tries to find the
silver lining to a situation.
So I did not vote for this president,
but I did not campaign against this
president and stuff,
you know,
one another way didn't work out.
So not the first election where I voted
for somebody that did not win that spot.
Being the person I'm out,
you know,
I'm not gonna sit there and be like,
fuck the next four years.
Like,
no,
like,
you know,
I've lived
through presidencies that I didn't agree
with and things work out.
I hope that it's going to work out this
time,
but this is what I'll say.
It's new.
We might see,
and I'm not saying burn it all down and
see what happens,
but we've had how many years of of two
party system essentially where it's
like,
yeah,
there's lip service to a Green Party and
lip service to another party,
but we for all intensive purposes,
I mean I know it was claimed by the
Republican Party,
but we saw a huge upset.
Have a third party candidate could
happens once.
They didn't want him in.
If it happens once,
that means it could happen again.
There's not a new model.
There's a new path.
He was always a Democrat his whole life.
That's what I thought.
Yeah.
He was fine because I grew up in jersey,
so I was very familiar with the man and
his work throughout my life and stuff.
He was a prominent figure in the press,
always,
always.
He always seemed very liberal leaning
and democratic.
Well,
what he did is essentially,
and he played a certain group of people
in this country and he got to this
ultimate position and power and we're
not sure.
I mean look at 70 years old,
you don't think he's a crafty guy.
Like he's probably pretty good at
getting people to like him as a certain
person who he really is like,
I think you probably got to get to know
him to find out who the fuck he really
is,
but also feel like to some degree it's.
And I'm not taking anything away from
him,
but anybody could have just popped up
and been like,
I'm the other person.
I'm not her,
not him.
She carries so much baggage and that's
the thing too.
And they were asking and essentially
Democratic Party was going,
come on America,
let's vote a woman in.
Come on like,
we just had the black president.
That was amazing.
Let's have a woman president.
And I think if they'd gone with almost
any other candidate that didn't have as
much baggage,
it'd be a different story.
But they were asking you to like
somebody who I didn't have an issue
with,
but a lot of people got a big issue.
If she was a man that it would be a
giant problem,
but we gave her or what do you mean?
Well,
if she had all those problems,
if she,
you know,
all the shit.
I mean we saw a guy with a lot of
problems,
but I'm saying if he was,
she was a man and she was up against
trump and she had all those problems
just crushed.
You have no chance.
But because she was a woman,
oh you think she got further because Oh,
100 percent.
And it was a lot of people that will see
as well.
They wanted to make history.
They wanted to make history because
look,
from a social standpoint,
Barack Obama was very important because
here was a super articulate guy who's
really calm and he just,
he has a very,
even a presence about him always.
He never seen riled up.
You never see him crazy.
Even like he gets heckled.
You can just see that thing with a trump
supporter was heckling him.
And he handled it with Grace Hill,
said graceful God.
It's like probably the best way to
describe them,
you know,
like that was important for the country
because that represented like,
wow,
hey,
here's this black guy who's super
articulate and so calm.
And so like the way he expresses himself
is so perfect for a president.
So presidential.
Like there's a what a what a perfect
example for our country.
This is us.
And then I think a lot of people felt
like Hillary Clinton would be another
one of those things.
Like,
look,
we can have a woman running.
Things were not sexist.
Like,
look we look,
we are a really articulate,
incredibly well experienced woman who's
been in business for a long time with
the government.
She's deep inside the public service and
she was a teenager.
Yes,
but it was just too much.
It was just too much shit for people.
But I think if that was a man and she
had all those same problems,
it was a man and tied to some foundation
that was getting all these people that
eventually got arms deals and they
donated and the.
They're all part of this weird sort of
incestuous political world.
A man would be skewered with that same
record because trump was running as an
outsider,
you know,
what he had going against him as he's
borish and he says ridiculous shit and
you know,
they could,
they could point to that,
that recording of him talking about
grabbing pussies and they'll like,
look,
look who we have here like that.
That was the big thing against him,
but at least to these people that hate
the system,
he was an outsider.
If she was a man,
she would've represented even more of an
insider,
you know,
I think to a lot of people,
I think her,
her actions and what she's done in the
past versus her as a woman.
That was like sort of a situation there
because like you ever seen the video
where she was talking about a Kadafi
being killed.
No crazy video man,
because she's joking around.
It's before they interview her and she
goes,
was like before the official interview
starts.
Like she.
Yeah,
she had just found out that Kadafi had
been killed and she was like laughing
about it.
She goes,
we came,
we saw he died and she throws her head
back and she's laughing.
She was kind of hawkish.
She was hawkish.
If that was a guy,
if a guy did that,
he would have been thought to be a
fucking serial killer.
A sociopath.
Right?
If a guy did that,
like say if Joe Biden,
like we came,
we saw he died.
People would be like,
do you want that guy in charge of the
fucking news?
But we let her go.
We'll give her a pass.
There's a lot of stuff that she's done
where people give her a pass.
They put a more interesting cat and
charge of the duke's.
Oh,
there should be no president.
This is what I say.
Everybody's like,
well,
who would you think should be the
president if you have a problem with
trump or if your problem,
no human being should be in control of
$350,
million human beings.
It's a postural job.
Explain this this way.
Too many of us.
It's in the hospital.
Would it be done?
Can we don't have to do it this way?
The world is the idea.
I don't have one,
but we can't have an Alpha channel
figured out right here were smart.
The Internet.
What about,
what about education?
The Internet mind reading.
Well,
essentially it as it come down to a.
What was the.
Was that movie with the girl?
Shoots,
bows and arrows and shit.
Oh,
a hunger games or games.
Can we district the country and then
there are heads of district or.
Same thing.
We'll go to war with each other.
Your App can't do that.
All right,
so that's gone.
This is the think tech is eating every
idea to get there.
That was one.
States are problematic.
So then once people like,
Fuck Utah,
this is Texas Sun.
That's true.
Yes.
I grew up in New Jersey and New York
hated us and fucking everybody hates
everybody.
Hated bonds.
The Banya Oh yeah,
you hated Pennsylvania.
New York hated Boston.
Connecticut got a pass.
Okay.
So it was like some little kid with a
limp,
like Ah,
don't pick on.
Say Connecticut doesn't get mentioned in
the tri state area.
Whenever the graph shows,
that would be like New York,
New Jersey,
Pennsylvania.
Exactly.
I didn't know.
I thought Connecticut was New Hampshire,
Ohio and years and years like
Connecticut is a highway to highway
between Boston and New York,
but we can like a poet.
Connecticut's I will everyone connect.
It's like,
fuck you.
They are like,
fuck you,
but you know what I'm talking about this
bitch.
You know I'm right.
All right.
Wait no states because we war with each
other.
Yeah.
Can you something?
Somebody has to govern?
No.
They have to be policed and shit like
that.
I think the best way to probably handle
it is let every human being have a say
every human being that's of adult age
and I think registering to vote should
be just as fucking easy as getting an
email.
It should be just as easy as doing
everything else that you do online.
You had a twitter handle,
you should be able to vote.
You should be able to use your id,
like whatever,
whoever you are,
whatever your name is,
you know,
call yourself.
Who are the fuck you want.
That is one individual vote.
That's what I think and I think as long
as we could figure out how to make that
system pure or people can't hack it,
do it.
He can't log in from 15 different
computers.
If you have a fucking birth certificate
and your birth certificate aligns with
this number and that's this and this is
you,
as long as they could figure out how to
make it so people don't hack into it.
Everybody who was an adult should be
allowed to vote for the we've gone to
jail.
I think people that have gone to jail,
the idea that someone goes to jail for
four years and now they can't vote for
the rest of their life.
I think that's fucking crazy too.
That's ridiculous.
You pay your debt to society back and
you should be able to reenter society.
Exactly.
You telling me you can't be a 20 year
old and do something stupid and rob
somebody or something and then I'm
supposed to think of you a certain way
for the rest of your life.
You're 80 now.
You Rob Somebody when you were 20.
That's still you.
Dangerous men talk about tear down
institutions,
but institutions are a problem no matter
what.
There are always a problem.
I think the real issue is government,
right?
Governing us,
so the real issue is what everybody
wants is safety,
security,
protection,
and unity.
That's what everybody wants.
All the other stuff.
In terms of restrictions on your
behavior,
we have to just figure it out.
Cut it down.
The middle between hurts other people
and hurts yourself and hurt yourself.
You're on your own just like you're on
your own with rock climbing,
just like you're on your own with bungee
jumping.
So wait,
give me an example.
Bmx Riding,
you're your role as a hobby.
Drone in high school they'd call them
elective.
Yeah.
How come you could just go to the roof
and jump off,
but you can't do heroin like no one will
stop you.
You can go to your roof and practice
backflip.
Megan.
So much fun.
I'm ready to boot,
dude.
I'm ready to fucking jacket needle in my
12.
Gauge it right now.
You have people tickets telling other
people what to do.
You've got a tyranny.
You got a fucking problem,
even if even if they sort of can get
away with it because it's written down
on paper.
Did you agree to it?
No.
You weren't.
Nobody asked you about like child labor
laws.
You've,
uh,
you've never.
No one's,
no one's pulled you aside and saying
that for years,
since I was a child,
no one pulled you aside and decided,
well,
you know,
you and you,
you have decided with them how old you
should be when you drink.
No,
it's already been done.
It's all.
Most people don't have a say.
It's all written down somewhere and the
amount of people that vote versus the
amount of people that are affected by
that vote completely disproportionate.
It's fairly weird,
man.
It's really weird.
We have a ton of systems that are set up
completely to do two things.
One,
to control people and to,
to ensure the survival of these systems.
And that's what bureaucracy is.
That's a giant problem with government.
Like the Dea.
The dea wants so badly to keep arresting
people for marijuana because if they
don't,
they don't have to shut up.
I'm like,
I better not light is perfect timing
again.
You and I are in sync.
Um,
what do you mean?
Why?
Because they have jobs.
They're jobs are going to go away.
There's no,
there's plenty of other drugs and it was
a small little 46 percent of all
arrests.
They said what was the number of more
people or arrested today or have been
arrested today for marijuana than all
other arrests combined?
You see we smoking man.
You want me to watching the door for the
next hour when I'm like,
what is that?
I heard a noise.
What are you doing?
But we live in the correct state right
yet,
right in telling me I'm right.
Well we're,
we live in.
If you're going to scare me then throw
me of a dick.
Tickle a little bit.
Like tell me everything's going to be
okay.
We're here.
Uh,
Washington state,
Oregon with the west coast since DC.
Large Smoking section,
Washington DC and Boston.
Now Massachusetts and state Florida is
as medical medical,
legal bunch of medical step though for
Florida.
What are the other legal state?
Alaska.
Alaska is legal.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Alaska,
so are gangsters to the north.
Do you believe the love Alaska Dj?
Do you believe the theory that as goes
California,
so goes the union,
like for years they said if California
goes legal,
there you go.
Go.
Ah,
that's interesting.
I think there's going to be states that
resisted still.
There's guys like that Jeff,
Jeff sessions guy who's coming into the
office with trump who's,
who could be an issue,
but I don't think it will be because I
think trump as a businessperson,
he's a businessperson.
He's not just a business person.
He's a populist,
right?
He's gonna.
He's gonna want people to like them and
you know,
and it doesn't make sense.
It's not a logical move.
You know,
it's weird as he is,
he's not illogical.
Like Hillary Clinton was illogical and
this is why I say that,
and people like [inaudible],
I got a lot of shit from people that are
like super pro Hashtag.
I'm with her and I'm like,
look man,
she didn't support gay marriage until
2013.
Do you know how crazy that is?
Until 2013,
Hillary Clinton was saying that she
believed that marriage was between a man
and a woman.
It was a sacred union and it should be
protected and so it's one of two things.
Either she actually believed that or she
was in bed with people who were forcing
her to behave that way or say that,
or she thought that she had to say that
in order to get elected or.
Well,
you're not getting to know.
No,
you can't.
You can't.
You can't be a part of that.
I attended
my first gay wedding in 1994 right
before clerks came out.
My brother married his husband,
Jerry.
There's still married to this day,
so they'd been married for 22 years,
which is like 108 years and straight
people years.
Yeah man,
because it's the part of the going
outside the box is like,
I don't have to live like the normies
man.
I could just.
Yeah.
I can't even get you pregnant,
bitch Goggins I can.
I can roam this earth like fucking cane
and come down.
But they've been committed to each other
and been in a marriage for like a long,
long time.
And the best thing about that wedding,
like it was great,
number one,
seeing my brother happy and,
and,
and get married and stuff,
but like a part of the wedding when the
shit gets slow and you're like,
Oh man,
let's get outta here.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's just middle midway.
Once everyone's toasts,
everybody that dances beginning,
that's not for everybody.
A drag show started like all of a sudden
donna summer and Diana Ross came down
staircase and it wasn't a real thing,
but boy they fucking looked at and put
on a huge town and my father was still
alive and he just had a heart attack at
that point or a couple heart attacks.
Stroke as well to architects in a couple
of strokes.
So he walked with a cane and one of his
hands is like a Bob Dole,
like just kind of hanging there and
stuff like that.
So him and my mom are at this Gig at my
brother's wedding and there we are like
on the dance floor watching the,
uh,
the drag show and you know,
the performers or lip sinking like
famous songs.
And my mom was,
she had a lot of drinks,
dinner.
My mom is like fucking bug in and she's
got like,
you know,
extra fucking weight like every Smith
and so,
you know,
she's,
she jiggling here and there and stuff
like that.
And her sleeveless dress.
My old man was dressed in a suit that
didn't fucking match is put it together
and shit like that,
but he had his hand on my mom's back and
with his weekend was kind of leaning on
the camera using her more for stability.
So his hands on her back while she's
dancing and stuff.
And I watched,
you know,
I'm standing right behind him.
I watched through the course of the
fucking Song Mall Man's hands slide down
my mom's back then spin in a pretty
fluid motion for God,
a couple of strokes and go right for the
last cup and not
dive deep
spelunking for gold.
He went right inside a cup.
It like this shit's minds,
Christ and,
and I will never forget that.
I told my brother,
I was like,
my God,
like you don't realize that it's never
going to happen in any other wedding,
but yours man.
Like my father was just like,
I'm free motherfucker.
And he started grabbing my owl,
his wife,
my mother now they were married,
so that's okay.
She wanted it.
She invite him.
She was just like,
she was a,
she was.
I've had discussions with my mother
since about that next.
Now I'm a grown adult and talk to her
about getting scooped tough course do.
Of course I wouldn't want to leave this
earth not knowing.
It's like,
you know,
I don't want to have a relationship with
my mother.
I've had her on the podcast.
We're talking about shit,
but I asked.
I was like,
Dad,
you guys looked randy that night.
Did you guys have sex?
She said,
Oh yes.
And that was like
randy.
Randy is a weird word.
What if your name was randy?
Be All bummed out that people expect my
dad.
She's like,
I feel randy all the time.
Nah,
film in certain places,
others hold on bump.
Uh,
where,
where are we grabbing pussies?
President,
president hops grabbing pussies.
Oh,
uh,
people that aren't truthful,
and this is like a,
another thing I want to say to people
that think that I hate Hillary Clinton
will not leave the person alone.
It's your show because this is what I,
that's not even a politics thing.
It's a human thing.
I think we owe ourselves like as,
as human beings to not accept like
blatant lies.
And I don't think it's good for her
either.
I don't think it's good for everybody.
I mean the,
the,
the rob is supposed to be the ones who
are in your sixties or something like
that,
that you're done.
You're done developing.
You're done growing that.
True.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I think you're alive if you're alive,
you're a person,
but we have categories of people,
right?
We have people that were 20.
Oh,
he's young,
he's stupid.
He made a mistake.
And then we have categories like in your
60.
Oh,
you're never gonna.
Learn anything.
You're,
you're,
you're done developing.
They're stubborn,
they're stuck in their ways,
like let's just accept the fact that she
lies all the time.
Right.
Like there's this video of when they
were talking about the emails and
there's video of the director of the FBI
talking versus her talking,
like she would say what the director
said and then he would say what he
really said.
It was ridiculous and it's just,
it's just like you see that she's being
dishonest.
That's not good for anybody.
Mad.
It's so good for her.
It's not good for us.
And I think for a person like her,
this is probably just a system that
she's been competing in forever and
that's how this system operates.
Makes sure she's really good at it and
she was a lawyer and she knows what you
can say and what you can't say and how
you can kind of distort things to make
them seem like they were better than
they were still talking about her at
this point.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
because that sounds like him as well.
All of them doing that.
When you do that,
when you do that and we see that that's
not good for us.
If we say yes to that,
it's bad for us.
It's bad for us as a culture.
No,
it does not exist as a nation.
Just as a group of human beings.
We're one person at a very high level is
supposed to be expressing for us.
Like if you're going to be the person
who's expressing things,
that's impossible like exactly as you
said at the beginning.
Oh yeah.
But I mean it's.
So then what's the.
Do you have a binary presidency?
One President is who speaks for the.
For one half,
one president speaks with the other
hand.
I don't think we should have resident
marrying factions.
I don't think we should have a unique
individual or even a small group that
runs this thing.
I think it's done before we got here.
Native apart from is it was done in
small groups because everybody was a
small group.
There were tribes and at the end,
even if you came over on a boat,
you came out in our boat with all those
other psychopaths that we're willing to
hop across the ocean with you.
How many could get on the boat?
A thousand.
I mean,
what's the most amount of people they
had on like one of those boats.
Once you google that,
like you got to really have a sense of
adventure to get over here to be a crazy
person.
Right?
So it's all really hated small towns,
small groups,
little villages.
I mean that's essentially what we had
representative government.
The first place was because these guys
in Utah couldn't really talk to the guys
in DC,
like somebody had to talk for you.
You're over there.
We'll take you months to get there.
So they have to decide how the fucking
thing runs.
So you have to vote in your little spot
and this guy sends his vote.
One hundred and two passengers.
Jesus Christ,
which watch one,
the mayflower hundred and two
passengers.
That's it.
Half died.
The first we got 151 shit.
Half died the first winter.
They fucking froze to death.
Just think about that when you're like,
how come I can't fucking get Wifi and
the subway train God.
One hundred,
two people sailed the ocean blue.
Oh my God.
That it probably was back then.
And then came here with an idea to fuck
it up.
Let's start America.
Yeah,
imagine what the ocean was like back
then.
Probably amazing.
None of those little plastic bead
islands out in the middle of the year.
So I have to not only beautiful but very
disturbing and birds choke on it and
shit.
I read an article that said that
seagulls are birds in general are
attracted to the smell of plastic will
be.
Well,
I've read it something they're saying
because a lot of plastic has food on it,
like even if it's like a in a
microscopic,
that would make sense to me.
Yeah.
Well a lot of our plastic comes in
contact with food for sure.
But I,
I read another thing about a certain
type of bird that lives on this one
island.
It's a real epidemic that these mama
birds are bringing back plastic and
feeding it to their babies.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
This is super villain plot.
It's awful.
There's these bodies of these birds and
their stomachs are filled with plastic
and you know,
they're rotting.
Their bodies are decomposing and the
plastic is just sitting there exposed.
Yeah,
it's super dark.
Can we talk about some of your hardship?
I was in Hawaii recently married and I
was with this dude when he was on a very
positive thing either.
Unfortunately,
he's been a commercial fisherman for a
long time.
His name's Steve.
Shout out to Steve.
Uh,
Steve and scooter took me out fishing.
Um,
but he,
uh,
when we were fishing he was telling me
that he's been doing this forever and he
lived in Costa Rica and you know,
ran a,
uh,
like a fishing camp out there and now
he's doing it out of Hawaii.
And I was like,
well,
how much of a difference have you seen
like over the last,
you know,
few goes,
oh,
it's huge.
It's a huge difference.
He's like a tree now,
like 10,
20 years ago.
Like 30 years ago,
the amount of fish he's like,
it's just totally different.
He's like way less fish.
He's.
And then he sort of explained to me all
the different methods that these
commercial fishing corporations use like
that,
how they go like hundreds of miles off.
See they have these massive nets.
They capture these tuna and they can
them on the boat.
Like they have this system where there
are just thousands and thousands of
pounds.
Tuna just scooping it up,
killing them.
Canning.
I'm like,
you don't think about it when you go to
the store and you see canned tuna,
you think I'd like some canned tuna.
I remember starkist,
I could go for a tuna salad sandwich
early with whole wheat and some nice uh,
Alfalfa sprouts on them.
They do this.
Then I'm like,
and of this or how about a grilled
cheese sandwich with tuna where you
butter the outside of the bread and you
put some tomato on that bitch and you
put some tuna and you put a bunch of
slices of a sharp Cheddar and you cook
that Shit.
Come on man.
Well,
the problem is you're thinking about
you've surrounded the meal with so many
cool adjectives and made it us that we
forgot to tell them this is a dead fish
killed at sea and candidacy dude with
relatives looking up,
going like,
there's hell hell on a boat.
I don't know what kind of bitch ass shit
you're talking about.
I'm talking about tuna melt.
That's delicious.
American sandwich.
What the fuck?
Truly American fucking this guy was.
He was describing it to me and I was
seeing it in my mind like a horror film
playing I was seeing in my mind like
that obviously the oceans giant.
It's gigantic,
but it's been going on these large scale
efforts for so long that it's just chop,
chop,
chop and away the number of fish and he
was really scared of it.
He was really scared of it.
He was like,
I just don't know how much longer it's
going to last.
So there could be an insufficient or
lifetime the.
Well,
there's a lot of speculation that by
2050 we literally would have killed like
most of the fish in the sea if we
continue escalating the way we have from
1960 to 2016 population now.
Seven billion.
We're,
let's just assume it's going to double,
you know,
by 2050.
I mean I don't know what the number is.
What's the projected population by 2050.
I got to imagine it's was the most
interesting questions,
right?
Is that a weird thing?
I always ask people shit.
Like who is that guy who played that
wizard once to what's the population?
Could it be by the year 20,
50.
It's like you're making big decisions
now.
Almost 10 billion.
So I was 11 billion by 2100.
Oh Jesus.
Nine point $7 billion in 2050.
If there's not enough fish,
there's no way.
Does it go to soylent green?
Were like we got to start consuming the
dead.
Well,
they have a method now apparently where
they can make petri dish,
you know,
like stem cell created meat.
I don't know how the fuck they do it.
I have zero understanding of the
process,
but I know that they did it a long time
ago and it was so expensive that they
did it like one cheeseburger would to
cost like a quarter million dollars,
like so expensive to produce,
but it was more of like sort of a test
subject like okay,
now we know that we can do this,
let's make the process more efficient.
Let's figure out how to large scale
people if they can do that a lot,
but if they can do that,
they can literally grow meat with no
body.
There won't be a body attached to the
meat.
It would just be me.
I don't understand how it works so I
don't understand.
Like what do you fuel that meet with
like how does it grow?
Like what is he eating or while it's
growing it has to take something in
order to get larger,
but it's not just pulling air out and
getting bigger.
So what are you feeding it and how's
that work and is that ethical and what
we watch?
Yeah.
Can we watch made it works?
You can suck my Dick.
How far can you take this warm?
Is it.
There's a lot of questions that we would
want to ask,
but I mean that's some westworld shit.
I mean that they're there.
If you can make a leg of a fucking cow,
you can make a leg of a fucking person.
You can just do it.
It just takes some time.
I know a guy with a metal femur.
He has an artificial femur.
He got bone cancer.
Okay.
Yeah,
and so one of his legs is a is like a,
like a metal rod that goes down to his
knee,
like they replaced his femur with a bone
with a metal bone.
Like they can start doing that to the
whole body,
which means if you can make some sort of
a nervous system,
you're like halfway to a person.
You can make meat and you can make
artificial bones.
You make an artificial scarcity and you
cover it with meat.
You've got a westworld thing going on
here.
True hearts.
They showed you the westworld characters
underneath their skin.
It's all robotic.
You're talking about is an organic form
of.
Yeah.
I think the westworld thing
is a little off on how it's going to go
down.
I think it's probably gonna go down,
but that's going to go look at hbo show.
Got It wrong.
I think they're bullshitting us.
Okay.
I think it's a part of the elite
strategy.
They found they figured out a way to
make a human heart in a petri dish of
fucking beating human heart with stem
cells.
Really?
Yeah.
See if he could find associated at all.
It's insane to the Russian scientist or
the German size,
the one that you just cut off dog heads
and I'm sure.
I'm sure ever see that gun never held us
to a burn victim.
Three P or re heal.
What Day is it?
Says?
I've seen that.
It's insane.
It's sprays.
Stem cells like a little mister and
those stem cells cling to the zones.
The tissue,
especially like when they're recently
injured and it heals up super quick.
Holy Crap.
It's fucking crazy,
dude.
I mean,
that was one of the most devastating
injuries a person could get because it's
a giant Oregon,
like a big burn like that or see
gestating minute.
That's insane.
Permanent results within days as a stem
cells regenerate the skin,
leaving no scars.
Fucking,
hey man,
if you're giving your own stem cells,
nobody can get all shitty about that.
Well,
the stem cells that they're using now,
they can get them from women when they
have secession sections,
they take it out of the placenta.
I've had a shot into my shoulder.
I had a shoulder injury.
I had a shot into my shoulder and to
heal like wolverine.
It's the craziest fucking thing ever.
I was like that close to getting
shoulder surgery.
I had this real issue with my shoulder,
like probably that I had probably
dislocated it at some point in time and
I didn't know and then just years of
doing Jujitsu and lifting weights and
fighting out a arm bars and shit,
it was just always bothering me.
So I go to a doctor,
I get an Mri and he says,
man,
he goes,
you got a tear here?
He got a tear here,
he got a tear in your labor room,
you got a tear in your biceps tendon,
like you know,
you might need surgery,
like see how long you can go now,
just do little rehab and you know,
and if it gets to a point where it's
unmanageable,
then you'd go under the knife.
So I go and it's always annoying me,
like it was always [inaudible] at me and
then I go and get these shots in my
shoulder and like three weeks later I'm
like,
am I imagining this or is this fucking
thing?
Feel Great.
I'll just get you skipped over the big
step.
How do you get to the shots?
And the shoulder was the doctor like Dr
the UFC doctor,
the UFC doctor who had had um,
Dr Davidson had shoulder surgery and
after shoulder surgery he was still in
pain months,
months later.
And he went and got the stem cell shots
and he said within weeks his shoulder
felt amazing.
Like it was crazy.
So who tells him about that?
Like how he's a doctor,
you know,
so he's just up on the late in the
doctor community.
They'll look,
yeah,
these are stem cells aren't good.
You get yelled at.
A lot of pro athletes are doing it and
they're doing it to help their body,
or no,
you can.
There's,
there's a bunch of ways to do it.
You could get it from your own fat.
They suck your fat to do a light bulb on
you.
God,
I'll live forever.
Just keep sucking it out.
And you go intravenous with the stem
cells so I can out intravenous stem
cells.
It's more net boom.
Say it again because that I'm going
home,
getting new right now on American
myself.
A million times.
That's illegal right now in America.
But Damn,
that sells.
to intravenously inject it back into
your body has supposed to have some
magnificent effect.
Intravenous stem cell injections.
Explain to your whole body like
intravenous drug,
like heroin.
They can somehow or another do that with
stem cells and you're like,
I've known to people that have done it
boss route and end bill's area.
And they're both like,
holy shit,
this was amazing.
Boss said that felt like he had energy
coming off his fingers.
He was like,
dude,
he was like,
my whole body was charged.
Like,
ah,
this is closest.
We get to superhuman ability,
but it's with our own.
With your own stem cells,
you can do it with your own stance
house.
They do.
That's one method.
Another method that another friend of
mine did is they drilled into the bone
in his hip and they pulled marrow out
and use that marrow,
use the stem cells from his hip marrow
and inject that into his knee.
And it had a pretty remarkable effect
too.
It's the opinion is divided over which
stem cell therapy is the most effective,
but one of them that seems to be very
effective is one that I did and that's
in section.
They take a woman who's given birth by
section and if they're young,
I think they have to be within a certain
age limit.
Then they take their placenta and they
extract stem cells from the placenta and
then they have some sort of a process
that I'll never understand.
And then they inject the stem cells into
the injury itself and your body starts
regenerating tissue.
So that's the difference between this
and any other sort of form of therapy is
that it actually allows your body to
regenerate tissue.
So things that are torn can actually
heal and thick and strengthen like
you're seeing what those burn victims.
Again,
don't listen to me because I don't know
what the fuck I'm talking about.
I just know how it's been explained to
me.
But uh,
it had a pretty profound effect.
What?
So if you're,
if you've got nothing wrong with you and
you just inject stem cells,
I was like,
Ooh.
Yeah.
Well he had something wrong with them
though.
You who's recovering from a pretty
serious injury.
Bas rutten was at least.
But yeah.
Um,
well one of the things we're finding out
is that,
um,
with mice,
they're taking the blood of young mice
and they're injecting it in older mice.
And these older my start acting like
young mice again,
and they start literally like going back
in age.
And this is some crazy vampire show
really is,
do.
That's very close.
This is totally vampire shit.
Do University off the blood of young
mice isn't an excellent fucking.
It is novel.
I think we got your next movie.
It's a great punk rock band.
Great.
It's a great idea for a movie gone
wrong.
Right?
Well,
you're talking to the guy made test so I
can make that work.
Do you know what the battery is?
No.
Elizabeth batteries like one of the most
infamous serial killers in human
history.
And her gig was she would kill young
women in bathing their blood blood.
Okay.
Then I did her.
She's,
she was a noble woman and uh,
where,
where was she from?
Slovakia.
What?
Hungry.
And uh,
she just killed a ton of pretty girls.
She would go find these peasant girls
and bring it back to a castle,
torture them,
kill them and cut them up.
And all the people that worked with are
just horrified buyer because she just
had like a dungeon of dead women and she
would just slaughtered them and then
bathe in their blood and.
But because of the fact that she was a
noble woman,
she never even got executed.
They just put her in house arrest,
so they locked her in some fucking
chamber up in the top of some castle,
like some monster by herself until she
died.
How old?
She was old when she died.
She,
you know,
she didn't die at 30,
but as she's a real mom question that
will.
Yeah,
it's good question.
She was 54 when she died,
which back then,
which right now,
think about it.
You've loved 16,
10,
whatever you liver love that.
Didn't make it to 54 and just realize
that the blood bather butchered.
All those women made it to 54.
How old was she when they locked her in
the hole?
Did the process work?
No Blood?
No.
It didn't work because she didn't know
what the fuck she was doing.
She had the right idea.
I mean in a way like there's the right
idea.
She was the mice before the mice,
but you don't have to kill people.
You dumb cunt.
They just believe that young kids to
donate blood,
to do what she did wrong was bathed in
the blood.
What he's supposed to do,
what she did wrong.
She's a fucking fucking serial killer.
I'm kidding.
But her idea was somehow or another that
she was going to get the younger
juvenile age and that's been a theme
that people have sort of like repeated
over and over again and it makes you
wonder,
maybe we mean no,
some,
somewhere in the maybe it's just
ridiculous and I'm and bloods of
illiquid and you can contain it and
measure it and we just get our heads
wrapped around this idea that that's
what makes you younger.
Or maybe like we inherently knew that's
the source of aging.
It's the blood and then chased it away
during civilization just because like,
well there's only one way around that or
out of others.
Maybe it's not something that we knew or
didn't know.
But it's inherent knowledge.
Like maybe your system,
sort of like how your body knows when
it's thirsty to drink water without
anybody even telling you like you just
kinda know.
Right?
But it's like certain things that you
know,
you see a snake,
even if you've never seen one,
you're going to back up.
There's things that you just know.
It could be highly possible that we'd
have some sort of a subconscious
understanding of some aspects of our
body,
some needs that our body has that we,
we've never been able to see it written
anywhere because no one's written it
down,
but maybe you kind of know things and
maybe somewhere just,
yeah,
maybe somewhere in the back of the,
the human DNA.
We know that the blood,
when the blood goes bad,
your body starts to get old and starts
to fall apart,
but if you pump that young blood
backhand Doodoodoo Doodoo too.
Like we just kind of has to happen
eventually.
Right?
That's the scary thing,
man,
because that's the number one thing that
people are hoping science can stop
people getting old and dying.
That's the number one thing.
Because you said,
I understand going like a,
hey man.
Um,
wouldn't it be great if we could do all
this without a president?
But it's tough to be like,
hey man,
when did this all be better?
If we couldn't die?
I'm not saying it would be better.
I definitely think it's possible.
Like everything.
There's everything ages in one
direction.
The road goes in one direction,
sewer,
slow it down and you can make the path
comfortable for yourself as comfortable
as you can,
the journey even more so,
but I don't think you could extend the
road forever.
You know that certain jellyfish are
essentially a mortal explain they live
here so don't have a head,
heart and lungs,
but,
but if we really can regenerate all the
tissue in your body and let,
except for trauma,
except for accidents and somebody,
somebody killing you,
there could be only one.
It's there's no physical reason why they
shouldn't be able to figure out how to
stop the aging clock and literally turn
it back.
No physical reason.
What about the brain?
Both that.
I mean that is also an Oregon does it,
Tom,
there's going to be a real question as
to where you know,
where your memories are actually stored
and who are you and once they start
getting to that ray Kurzweil's shit of
storing consciousness and some sort of a
data bank watch black mirror.
Oh No,
I haven't,
but I heard I have to.
You got it.
You would love it.
I watched one episode when they made the
politician,
fuck the pig was amazing.
It's pretty bad ass.
Amazing episode.
What the fuck you watched that you were
good enough?
That brilliance and be like,
oh my God.
And that was their first episode.
Let me see what the next one.
It's not that I'm opposed to it.
I just had to wait to have this one
episode and the second season about,
you know,
they don't telegraph it up front,
the smart tv that make it work for it.
But they,
uh,
essentially the idea is they take people
who are dying and you can download your
consciousness into this digital
playground,
look the way you want.
And it looks like,
like,
you know,
every spring break you've ever seen and
stuff.
And so these two people meet up and
they're both young women and you find
out one is an old woman and the other,
they're both old women.
One's been a vegetable.
So she was like a teenager.
But in this virtual world they can drop
and be free and to be whoever they want.
But it's generally considered like,
uh,
if you could choose to just die,
pass onto whatever you think is out
there if there's a heaven or something
like that,
or you could choose to go to the server
as they call it and stuff.
And so the,
you know,
the two women who fall for one,
another,
one is like,
stay here forever.
Like,
you know,
we can be like this forever.
And the older woman was like,
I had a life with a husband and a kid
and I watched him get old and die and he
chose not to do this.
Now I'm going to choose to live forever.
And her friends like where you're going,
you don't even know where you're going.
But what if he's not there?
That gets you nowhere or alert
somewhere.
Good point.
I don't know where you're going with
kids.
Sorry.
It's deep.
Hilton smoke another joint.
Forget this one of many episodes,
but I got to keep going with this
because it's good.
And we got to talk about the arrival.
Have you seen arrival?
No.
Oh my gosh,
I haven't seen it yet.
I've already preordered it on itunes.
It's genius.
May Tell you what,
I'm not watching anymore as a walking
dead done.
Why don't be that one episode of the
latest season of the new season.
I'm like,
fuck,
what the first one?
Yeah.
Fuck you had to do that.
Everyone's waiting to see what what
Nagan dead man.
I'll be like that as a.
This is our soap operas.
Torture show.
Just torture.
Show the zombies.
All of a sudden they're totally
insignificant.
They charge you.
You can just kick them away.
They tear open horses with the raw
hands,
but they charge you just kind of like
fucking highs.
Minimum.
A group of thousands of them surrounding
a van and he figures out it.
Fuck you.
You Killed Glen.
Like that boiler like that.
But that way,
but they also to live on was expecting
when they did shit.
Fuck that show.
You got a high bar.
Rogan?
No,
I don't.
Yeah,
I do feel like don't.
It's just if you're going to fucking
Zombie tree consistent,
it's torture.
Think the idea was to show as bad as we
think the zombies are.
The humans are always going to be worse.
You can't kill Glenn.
Is that.
Is that your big beef?
I love that guy.
I know,
but this show is that going like,
Hey,
I'm sorry we got to kill someone you
love.
Every once in awhile.
I'm spoiler alert in the fuck out of
that show.
If you're not watching it,
pause this.
I'm done.
I won't do that anymore.
Can't tell you the end of the other
thing.
No,
come on dude.
Jesus Christ on.
It's good.
It's good to talk.
I'll cover my ears and then I'm talking
to nobody.
I'm the.
Let's talk arrival.
I want to keep saying the arrival
arrival just arrived.
Did you ever see the other one with
Charlie Sheen?
The arrival.
That's why I keep wanting to say the
Bible.
Yeah.
That's an old video store flick from
when I was renting sling and videos back
in the day.
I remember him that quite often people
come in and be like,
you got the arrival,
Chuck Sheen Son.
I was like,
super high.
God,
I feel embarrassed to have liked that
and then Dave Foley released me.
Of My father was like,
that was a really good science fiction
movie.
Yes.
Yeah.
One smart guy.
Do you know Dave?
No,
I met him once on a game show,
but you know,
big news radio fan.
But even going back pre news radio,
probably the reason I get to news
radio's because that was a massive kids
in the hall fan,
so I met Dave twice.
He only remembers probably the one time
on the game show recently that the
Hollywood game night,
but I met him back in like 95.
I went to a kids in the hall show in
Kitchener Ontario and then went back
backstage after the show and I've never
done that before,
but I was a big fan of.
My friend was like,
oh,
they'll fucking love it.
My friend Malcolm,
he's wonderful.
God very much a blowhard.
He has bug guest called blower,
but he's the guy that's just like,
fuck a Batman v Superman.
It's a certain amount of abortion,
you know?
He's just got opinions and shit.
Some a man took me to see the kids in
the hall and he's like,
we'll go backstage.
They'll fucking love it.
You made clerks,
this will be amazing and they just
finished an amazing show and we go
backstage and,
you know,
I don't know how you are after show,
but I now know how I am after show and
generally speaking the show was there
and now I just like,
it was fun.
Grab some milk and drive home or grab or
something like that.
Um,
and,
and instead,
you know,
you're not like,
hey.
So I met them and they were all like,
hey,
you know,
and not,
they didn't fucking see clerks to know
who I was as early,
early on in my career,
but,
you know,
they just give it all up on the stage
and they're like,
oh shit,
we gotta fucking do another mini show
and stuff.
So,
you know,
I don't,
I'm not like,
what a let down.
It was.
The show was amazing,
you know,
it's just not like a doubt he'd even
remember meeting me,
but I did meet him on that Hollywood
game night show and talked to them for a
long time.
But I'm a deep fan going way back.
That's awesome.
The long answer to your question,
sorry,
I don't remember what the question was
you like.
Do you meet that guy?
He's literally one of the smartest
people I've ever met in my life arrival.
Let's talk about the new arrival.
You gotta see it.
You would love it,
but Dave Foley,
I wanted to talk about data.
Let's go deep on.
He's a secret producer of Newsradio.
What do you mean?
Explain?
Is this deep cuts newsradio?
Yeah.
Here we go.
I'm I'm listening mode.
This is not a knock against the writers
as writers are brilliant.
Paul Sams go created it.
Another one,
the smartest people I've ever met and
just completely unique,
like there's a lot of guys that pretend
to be that eccentric Weirdo writer Guy
Paul Sams is that motherfucker.
He's such an eccentric guy.
Like they didn't start writing until
like 3:00
in the morning.
They would hang out,
play video games and foreign each
other's faces and they literally didn't
start writing until the middle of the
night because Paul like had a strategy
of getting like everybody,
like really tired and silly and then
they would write all night and then a
lot of times we would get like the first
draft,
the day of the table read,
we would get the first draft.
They would just be like,
Josh Lieb would come down barefoot and
he,
these guys would be up all night and Lou
Martin and all these writers and I was
like,
you guys fucking crazy.
Like you didn't even sleep like this.
He goes like,
no,
we've been writing all night.
This is how we do it.
And they were just silly because they
were.
They were almost without doing drugs.
They were getting high by keeping
[inaudible] for inhibition
there up.
The more they're like anything goes and
as you're sitting there,
if your welfare or your,
you know,
in the middle the day,
perhaps you're less a apt or less,
less likely to be like,
Hey,
I got a fucking stupid.
I don't want someone to be like,
you asshole.
That's a fucking funny.
Nobody wants to get judged.
So for me,
I smoke weed.
Not because it gives you a better ideas,
but because it's,
you know,
it lowers your inhibitions where you're
like,
I'm,
I don't give a fuck.
If people think it's stupid,
I'm going to try it.
And if that don't work,
I'll try something.
I'll say another way.
You can express yourself more.
Honestly.
You feel freer to express yourself more.
I must be the same idea that people
fucking up and then just getting them
tired and they'd be like now.
Right.
It's a strategy.
It really is very,
very specific.
It's very,
it was very silly.
It was a silly show and that's one of
the reasons why I think there's a lot of
silliness going on,
but which is a strong suit when you
can't,
when you don't have the card to play of
like let's say cock or fuck shit.
Like you can't even do the basic cards.
So you like,
what do you replace those cards in the
deck width and that show replaced it
with like,
oh,
we're going to have the,
we're going to up the silly question in
a way that doesn't look like other
sitcoms.
Silly.
Like they're silly.
Was bill getting a cane where it's like,
that's a real fucking silly episode.
They built a whole episode around him
walking to everybody loves a cane.
Like that's not,
it's not the same bill.
No,
it was very,
very top shit.
Like your last name's girly,
like just repeating that for,
for,
for five fucking years.
That was like every time it happens.
Like your last name's grilling.
That's genius.
That show was,
it was.
It was a very weird show.
And a lot of ways I'm like,
Paul was a,
he's such a unique guy that he would
essentially let anybody come up with
another line if like they were doing a
table read or a,
not a table read rather.
But uh,
um,
a run through.
If you would get a hold of the script,
Dave would come up with an alternative,
an alternative line.
And like right away the show was in
trouble like,
because like the first year that we are
filming,
like it wasn't really doing very well in
the ratings and they couldn't figure out
how the show.
I bet you that number would be.
Well,
it was weird.
We moved nine times in f five,
five years.
But um,
there was this um,
or four years,
whatever we did and it was this moment
when they were,
they were just trying to figure it out
constantly.
It was a lot of work and they would all
get together and try to rewrite scenes.
But Dave Foley would rewrite scenes like
on the floor.
And as the show kept going,
it became more and more of a thing like
we were,
he was like a secret producer.
Like,
but not that it was a secret because the
writers were so open minded that they
just wanted to see the best job.
He's
the best kind of actor though.
He's the actor that you love because
he's a writer as well.
So it comes to set and he's not just
doing your script.
He can give you five other scripts just
as funny if you want them,
and if he's like the good ones,
he's not jamming my shit's better than
yours and your throat.
He's like,
if there's an opening gracefully,
it goes in.
But that in the beginning of my career
is
to reject people that were like that
because I'm like,
no,
if it's not my writing,
then what is it?
And then the older you get,
the more comfortable getting you
realized,
dude,
you're going to get credit regardless.
Like go ahead.
Like I remember for me it was Chris
Rock.
There was a moment in dogma,
a Chris Rock.
There was a line in the script,
a line in the movie where,
uh,
you know,
he falls out of heaven.
He's Brewfest the 13th apostle.
And then having this conversation though
the road,
him and Linda Fiorentino playing
Bethany,
Jane Santa Barbara there.
And he references knowing Jesus and
she's like,
Christ,
you knew Christ.
And he goes,
no,
I'm shit.
And he used the n word.
He goes,
oh no,
it's been 12 bucks,
Nigga,
12 bucks now.
I didn't write that line.
I wrote dogma,
every piece of it,
but I didn't write that line.
I would never put that light in front of
Chris Rock and be like,
look what I did.
My line was Nomi owes me 12 bucks.
Chris was able to dress it up in such a
way and I told them,
I was like,
Oh God.
Because I was crying when he did.
I was like,
that's hysterical.
But I was bittersweet about it because I
was like,
I can't include it.
And I said to him,
I was like,
dude,
that's the funniest thing I think I've
ever put on film and I can't use in the
movie because why?
That was like,
because I didn't write it.
How am I supposed to do the credits now?
Written by Kevin Smith and one line by
Chris Rock.
He goes,
I don't give a shit.
Don't you know how this works?
He's going,
you'll get credit for it.
He's going to fit with funny.
Take it.
I don't need credit for that.
I say a lot of shit.
And I was like,
Oh,
oh really?
And then the next guy I worked with was
like,
that was a will ferrell on Jay and
silent Bob Strike almost an alien idea
that you would not accept a really funny
addition to had to do the job dude,
because I was.
So I came through indie film and so I
didn't come up through the world of
comedy.
I backdoored into the world of comedy.
But I came up through any film and indie
film was like,
Hey man.
Oh tour,
right.
And direct your stuff.
It's your statement and stuff.
And I've,
since nobody taught you,
there's nobody to teach you.
This shit is no book.
You have your own process where you're
like,
well,
you know,
I guess to be pure it should all be my
stuff.
That way when I see it say written by
Kevin Smith,
it's not a lie.
Just like I was raised Catholic.
So for the longest time,
like I,
you know,
I thought I was a virgin until I was
about 17.
Really?
I lost my virginity at 13.
Like I was inside a girl at age 13.
She was also the same age.
So it's not creepy.
It's creepy to talk about now,
but never.
I never came.
And in Catholic school there's no class
where they're like,
you know,
sex is penetration.
They don't tell you shit,
so you know,
I was like,
well we make rules for yourself and you
just buy them as those are the rules.
So for years I was like,
well,
I,
you know,
I never came inside a girl so I've not
had sex yet.
And then when I finally had sex I was
like,
oh,
I guess penetration counts.
And hence I had sex a long time ago.
It was a problem for a minute with my
current girlfriend.
And she's like,
you said you were a virgin.
I was like,
I thought it was a virgin,
but she was like,
you better inside
somebody else's again,
but I didn't come.
Isn't that the like if you don't come
and don't count.
And she's like,
where'd you get that?
Super impressive.
Anytime a 13 year old doesn't come,
should be super impressive.
You know,
I kind of put out to fear you've got the
Catholic fear of not like,
oh,
she'll have a baby.
But the very catholic fear of,
I can't believe I'm sending,
not even that,
like,
Oh really?
You,
she may have to get an abortion than
your Catholics.
I don't think.
I think any faith,
you know,
you could send,
especially with Catholicism,
they had a built in get out of jail free
card.
Like you can do what you need to,
but you come into church,
you'd tell the strange man your dirty
little secrets in a booth with no lights
and you leave and everything's going to
be fine with Jesus.
It made sense all throughout my
childhood.
I was a catholic.
So,
um.
All right.
So wait,
where were we before we got into the.
I don't know,
I don't have to be anywhere man.
I know,
but I like,
we were on a good thread man.
Like we were talking about you.
It is what you think it is.
Like you build the rules for yourself.
So I said to myself,
if,
if I include Chris,
Chris Rock's amazing Ad Lib in my movie,
then I've taken from another writer and
hence it can't say written,
but absolutely in my head.
I understand why you would think that he
got that out of me.
It didn't make sense to me just because
I was really lucky in the,
the only real comedy that I did that
lasted any,
you know,
uh,
was,
was news radio and it was a crazy
environment like that.
Where this based on you though,
right?
Like Joe Garelli,
the character was very loosely based on
me.
Your stand up and said fucking do that
on the show.
Paul was just like really good at
picking out the goofy shit that you do
and like exaggerating it because I was
always into stupid ufo stories.
So it would always be some conspiracy
theory or some gadget because I've
always been a dork when it comes to like
technology.
I'm fascinated by all sorts of gadgets
and shit,
but I don't like flashing in moments
where you're like,
you see this and it's just a card and
you're like,
uh,
from the elevator.
But I don't know which one it was like
during raise period and stuff is all the
girly moments are washing over me as you
say that.
I probably don't even remember him,
but I bet you I no more about that show
than you.
If you and I went head to head Newsradio
Radio Trivia.
I bet you I bet you would to like Andy
Dick was a perfect sample.
Andy Dick is a super exaggerated version
of Andy Dick,
of Andy Dick.
That's what his character was.
Matthew when I think it was just a super
exaggerated version of Eddie Dick,
but like in ways andy almost sometimes
at his craziest was like more of an
exaggeration,
but in a totally different way.
He was partying,
getting crazy,
but that the silliness of that character
was really handy tech and really it
wasn't him.
I could see that because I'm.
Matthew takes off like he's funny,
but he becomes the matthew that he is
for the rest of the show.
About six episodes,
four to six episodes in.
You see him start
to become the matthew that you.
When you,
when you think of news radio.
Oh yeah.
Matthew.
Um,
so it feels like.
Same thing with you.
Well you weren't even the first guy,
right?
Pilot.
They had a different guy.
And then you,
Ray Romano,
was he the guy?
who was the,
you know,
he was the guy before me.
This is what happened.
Ray Romano was casting it originally and
then I guess while they were shooting
the pilot,
they decided to go a different
direction.
I don't know what that means.
So they brought in another guy and that
guy did it and then after the pilot they
said we want to replace that guy.
And so then they had this open casting
call thing and then I got involved in
that.
And what had you been doing at that
point?
Stand up?
I was thinking about moving back to New
York and thinking I should've got,
shouldn't have got a fucking apartment
in la.
Oh my God,
that's what I came out here for a show
called hardball.
It was a show by this guy.
I'm Jeff Martin and Kevin Curran,
these two guys who wrote for married
with children and they also wrote for,
I think they role for the simpsons and
they wrote for a lot of shit.
They were really funny guys.
They came up with a great pilot.
Me and Jim Brewer and a bunch of other
great guys were in it and then Fox got
ahold of it and just sort of fist it and
just came in it's eyeballs and just
twisted it all around,
a really hacky it just a really hacky
version,
what it once was and then eventually got
canceled.
So I thought being a young dumb guy that
I was,
I thought,
ah,
this,
this show is definitely gonna be a hit.
I should get an apartment.
I'm going to live out here.
I might as well got a year lease,
you know,
everything's going great.
And then all the sudden the show gets
canceled.
I'm like,
what am I doing out here?
Like I don't have any friends out here,
I don't know anybody.
My friends were all back home.
And I was like,
Gosh,
she just moved back to New York and then
I got a development deal.
It's like NBC got in touch with my
management and they asked me if I wanted
to do my own show or if I wanted to do
this show that they have already.
Um,
this show called news radio.
So I got to watch the pilot before,
I had no idea what it was before anybody
ever saw it.
I got a vhs tape of the pilot before the
ever aired on TV and so I got to watch
that and then I auditioned for it.
So it was a big advantage and that like
I kind of understood like the style
rhythm of the show that they did,
but it was really interesting was what
he did was the first,
um,
the first audition wasn't funny
necessarily.
It was just a scene and I was like,
this is weird.
Like,
because the pilot was really funny,
but this seems like they did it on
purpose to see if people would ham it
up.
Like they did just didn't want anybody
wasn't playing it real.
And so they weeded people out by making
something that wasn't really that funny.
I'll fucking crazy.
And then the second time I come back and
it's hilarious.
The second time the banter is just
genius.
And I'm like,
oh,
these clever pitches.
Like I see what they did,
they just whittled it down for people
who down to people who could play it
straight.
That's,
that's.
I mean I'm not insidious in
a negative way,
but that's ingenious.
Maybe is the word I'm looking for.
So instead of insidious that's like,
I don't think like that.
Now I'm just like,
we cast clerks.
I still kept the same weight when we
cast clerks.
We had a first avenue playhouse,
was a little theater dinner theater in
Atlantic Highlands,
New Jersey,
and so we put an ad out like I think in
the free paper and I hung up ads any
place where like college kids
congregated and stuff.
Mom with college at the time,
now it's a mum with university.
So we have this open casting call and
you know,
as we were,
as people are coming through,
we're seeing people do things that like
we're blowing us out of the water.
I had no experience.
Maryland Gagliardi the girl that plays
Veronica and the movie she got cast
because she like cried during the
audition and I remember like looking at
my friend's going like,
who could do this?
Who could just like cry like this and
none of them audition with comedy like
Bryan,
Ohio and underplayed Dante audition with
a piece from like,
don't be afraid of the dark at.
No not there'll be afraid of the dark.
Oh fuck yeah.
Maybe don't be one more.
Alan Arkin is like a stocking.
Audrey Hepburn and she's blind and he's
like robbing the place alone in the
dark.
Maybe this will go,
but it's a real like killer monologue.
That's nothing like his character.
So we were like,
this guy's fucking.
We can act.
If he could act like that,
he can fucking say I'm not even supposed
to be here today.
And stuff like that.
So yeah,
I could see that was my process.
Just I'm blown away.
I'm easily impressed.
Like so people come through.
I'm like,
you cried like,
oh my God,
he's the greatest actor,
cyber so in my life,
or you know,
crazy,
crazy person who could pretend that
something is real when it's not,
no doubt,
God dammit.
That's part of the problem.
And the ability.
Men is not a part of the problems and
this is it.
You have to be a little fucking cuckoo.
Genesis Rodriguez,
who was an actress in a couple of
months.
I did,
she,
she came from Telanovela.
So she,
uh,
the Spanish Tele Novella.
So,
uh,
you know,
we were t,
she did a scene and Tusk and she's
crying and I was like,
that was amazing,
man.
It was crazy.
Like,
it's like you orchestrated a tear for
the right line.
It just rolled and hit at the right
time.
And she's going,
yeah,
she's going on Tele.
You've got to know how to cry like
crazy,
like every episode,
somebody crying and stuff.
And she also described the process.
She was like,
you know,
well first she was like,
here,
like,
just give me a sec,
say something funny.
And so Jason Muse was there and Jason
who started telling him it was fucking
funny story and she just starts bawling
and laughing while she's balling but
literally looks like she's crying.
I was like,
that's fucked up and shit.
And she said,
you have to do that on Telanovela while
somebody is on an in an earwig in your
ear reading you the dialogue,
you will,
they get scripts,
this thick,
thick is a dick.
So they can't learn all that dialogue
and they shoot like 20,
30 pages a day.
So they stick in their ears,
a little,
a little a receiver
and essentially the directors and
control room and you know,
they should have like a soap opera.
There's multiple cameras,
but they are giving them the lines and
they are saying it's simultaneously.
And I was like,
how do you fucking do that as your brain
work like that?
And she goes,
say anything to me,
give me a nice long sentence.
And so I went for the sentence in
English language has all the letters in
it,
the quick Brown Fox jumps over the lazy
dog.
And as I got to quick,
she,
it's true.
She,
uh,
she started following me and finished at
the exact same time like it was,
it was pretty fucking impressive.
She doesn't seem crazy by stretching the
imagination.
I asked her,
I said,
how can you fucking do that?
She's like,
I don't know.
It's just a family thing.
She's like,
my dad.
She said her dad,
her dad's a big performer,
singer.
She said,
my dad can make his hair stand up on his
arm and get goose bumps just by looking
at it.
Oh.
And it's like,
wow,
that's.
I mean,
what a,
what a weird super power to have.
But like,
cool,
well there are definitely things,
weird things like that where people
inherit them from their parents,
like ice data girl who couldn't even see
a needle in a movie.
She would faint,
like if she saw someone getting a shot
in the movie,
she was squeamish,
but she was like woof.
And Her dad,
who I believe was a dentist.
So like you would think the guy saw a
lot of needles.
That guy will do the same thing.
Like he,
if,
if he saw something bad he would faint.
So even though he normally saw neil,
he probably stuck needles into guns and
shit like that.
In his job he was a dentist.
Yeah.
So he,
he's doing shit.
And then watching trauma until she was
telling
me that are her,
um,
her brother had like a real severe
sunburn.
The point where you're like,
blisters,
you know,
like,
where it's like,
Whoa,
you really fuck this up.
He saw it and he fainted.
And they were like,
what the hell?
Like he couldn't help it.
It was just,
he was.
So,
you know,
you love your buddy if you don't like,
you react like that.
It's like,
you know,
sunburned.
It's been so weird.
I don't think it's his fault.
So what I'm saying,
I don't think it's selection.
Yeah man.
There's something in the system.
If something bizarre in the system,
like,
act when people tell stories when
they're just like,
you know,
and then fucking tour this,
do that and shit.
The idea of I'm not,
I'm low tolerance for threshold for pain
myself.
And I like hearing people tell stories
about injuries.
I,
you know,
I react.
Yeah,
well everybody does,
right?
Like you watched those videos.
I watched some poor guy,
oh my God,
who let this fucking guy do this.
This guy who was like ridiculously
overweight and they set up a skateboard
up on a ramp.
Like balancing it on this.
They just see that,
oh my God,
it's awful.
It's awful.
But when you watch someone like that
where you know they're going to get hurt
and then when they get it get hurt,
it's really bad.
You know that feeling that you get like
a sharpness,
like almost like a sharpness and
yourselves where your whole body is
like,
fuck
Jesus.
Sometimes at great heights,
I get that.
If I look inside of a building,
I'm like,
Jesus,
that runs right through you,
like move back.
It's almost like the adrenaline becomes
like stalagmites coming off of a fucking
ceiling.
Just they say that that is built and
even babies have that.
They did a test with babies that a long
table like this and then in the middle
here instead of it being would that
plexi glass and it was clear so that the
mother went under the table and the baby
at the other and she was like,
come on and the baby would crawl,
but as soon as the baby got to the clear
part,
which is still a table right,
went back and would not go forward.
Good.
That's built into us for some reason.
Someone posted,
someone posted it shows is that fucking
thought,
but somebody posted a picture today from
a playground in the 19 twenties and I
don't know if it's real because I really
probably shouldn't be talking about it,
but if it is real like Jesus Christ,
these bars were like 50 feet off the
ground.
These kids are just climbing ladders and
shit.
These metal ladders.
I mean the.
The way the setup look like today.
There's not a chance in hell.
You let your kids play on this thing.
He would freak the fuck out.
Like look at this.
Look at this God damn thing.
Look at this.
How many kids got hurt before they were
like,
maybe we should died every day.
We should bring it in and they'll look
at that height.
Dude,
they're dead because even if it's all
sand,
you're still hitting something hard.
They didn't care.
They didn't want you to live.
Look at the all riding bikes back.
There were no cars.
So yours is early 1980 [inaudible]
callback.
Is that a body?
Is that a one falling from the sky?
That's not real.
Is it?
Or the hanging from something as a swing
that swing that swinging off the fucking
ground.
It looks like a body though,
doesn't it?
If you don't look at the lines,
the lines are like those falling marks
at a cartoon because it's hanging,
hanging off a fucking kids are playing
around.
It's a crazy picture though,
isn't it?
Look at that.
Yeah.
Things were a lot more dangerous and art
and that's even before our day.
Yeah,
that's before our different back east,
you know,
Action Park.
No,
I was just going to say I broke my arm
on one of those things.
Did you really?
Yeah.
When I was a little kid,
I fell off the monkey bars,
snapped my arm and posted on it,
snapped it.
And so you got your first cast.
At what age?
I think I was six.
You have people sign it?
Do you have a lot of friends?
I believe I had people sign it many.
Was it like there's no room.
Sorry.
I don't remember.
Or was it a lot of like love you mom?
Probably.
Mostly,
yeah.
Mostly that.
But those things are fucking dangerous
shit on the bottom of it.
In New Jersey there's a theme.
Park is closed now.
I'm all grown up,
man.
We'd go there.
They would do shit like a water slide
that people got fucking hurt on.
They would do these things.
It was before insurance,
I guess where,
you know,
they had a wave pool.
Um,
so a wave pool is big pool and then like
they've got these giant beaters in the
underwater at the end that are huge,
that just constantly make fucking waves
and people would get crushed under them
and get killed.
They had this like slalom,
race a thing,
whereas you kind of sitting on this
cement track,
there you go.
New Jersey's action park offered fun and
injury for the whole family.
Jesus,
that was a waterslide.
Look at that water slide.
You were completely in a bluetube that
went down a mountain.
It did a a loop in the dark where a lot
of people were getting hurt,
like they didn't make the full loop.
They just got jammed and then people
Clyde into you bang,
Bang,
back injuries.
Couple dead.
Oh my God.
A couple times.
But that was.
That was fun.
When we were kids,
you know,
you didn't want to get hurt,
but like nobody told you,
you might get hurt that badly.
Some things were sensible.
Like I was a child.
If I saw monkey bars that,
hi,
I'm number one.
I didn't even go near the fucking monkey
bars,
but if I saw them that high,
it'd be like,
this is ridiculous.
Like this is clearly.
Clearly we're being filmed or something.
Yeah,
right.
It'd be like,
this is.
This was built by somebody who doesn't
know the child,
looks like or hates them,
tricked him into going high so they can
fall and die.
The more blood I get,
young child,
blood to Bay,
then the younger one could look.
They subscribed to the theory of what's
her fuck.
But that was a real concern back then
about mouths to feed.
I mean we're talking about the
depression.
So you think they built the playgrounds
like that.
So out the week real.
No Way.
Well then you have to agree that we live
in a better time because nobody ran on
that platform and the election of like,
hey man,
only the strong survive.
So you know,
if your kid goes to the playground,
falls off the monkey bars.
That's on you.
Well,
um,
we certainly are more protective of our
children today and we'll just understand
child rearing and understand mortality
and we understand like the,
the bad things that you can do to your
kid while you're developing them.
But it's,
it's a weird catch 22 and you'll
probably agree with me as a parent and
my kids,
you got three,
you know more than me.
I got one,
but go ahead.
But I was just gonna say is like there's
a weird catch 22 in that you want to
give them all the love in the world.
You want to support them as much as you
can.
You want to be there 100 percent for
them.
But you also realize that everyone,
you know,
that's interesting,
had to overcome some bizarre childhood,
overcome some crazy for all my favorite
people.
Like all my favorite people tell me
terror stories about like growing up and
what their parents or what their dad did
or like,
Holy Shit.
So many people,
especially the comedians that I know,
it was all just like,
oh fuck.
And then what happened?
Oh fuck dude.
And they're the funniest fucking people.
They're the most interesting kids that
aren't,
uh,
well,
I know I look,
I'm not a helicopter parent and I know
I'm the guy that paves the way for his
kid.
She wants to act.
I'm like,
oh,
let's make a movie.
You don't really,
you know,
that's not
normal,
but you know what,
man,
the only thing that's wrong with that,
this is the only thing that's wrong with
that,
and this is where we have a problem of
human beings is the only thing that's
wrong with that is the idea that she's
not going to have to start making a
living on her own.
She's going to be able to carry forth
under her dad's momentum,
but the only reason why that's a problem
even remotely has because we have this
absurd idea that it should be super
important for you to take care of
yourself.
That it should be super important for
you to financially carry yourself.
You know,
I explain,
explain.
I've been fucking with this idea more
and more lately.
So I fuck with it.
Is this my,
my buddy Eddie Wong who's a chef and a
really fucking interesting,
cool guy was on a podcast and uh,
Eddie was talking about universal basic
income.
And at first I thought,
why you're going to,
you're going to give people free money.
Get the fuck Outta here.
That's so stupid,
dude.
You can't do that.
Then the more I thought about it,
the more I said,
well,
it seems like when you give people
money,
like it kills their motivation for a lot
of folks,
but what if that's just like your needs
are covered?
Okay.
Is that really true that if you give
people something and you give them
security,
that it takes away their creativity?
Or is this just.
I mean the only we don't know because
everybody's always been in need.
They overcame that need and then they
became successful.
Right,
and that's the story that we hear over
and over again,
but what if.
What if all your needs were taken care
of?
Like food,
shelter,
like you have basic stuff,
you know you're not going to get rich,
but you have enough to eat and you
always have a roof over your head,
which is first of all,
wouldn't we all like each other more?
If that was the case,
if we didn't have to worry,
if nobody had to worry about how much
money they had.
Nobody had to worry about not being able
to eat.
Nobody worried about not having a place
to sleep.
That sounds Utopian right,
but that's almost doable financially if
you look at the amount of money we have
versus the amount of people we have
versus how much money people make.
It's like,
Ooh,
it's kind of close.
Like we would have to restructure a lot
of shit,
but it seems like they might be able to
give every person $12,000
a year,
something like that.
And I think if we could figure out some
sort of a way to do things like that,
I think we would have a giant
alleviation of tension and struggle at
its base level survival shit.
Like to elevate us as a,
as a people just above the survival
thing.
So then we can relax more and get better
at all this other shit.
But we got to get past the survival
thing.
And the base of the survival is what bay
basic food,
basic shelter.
Uh,
you know,
having,
having a roof over your head and having
food.
Well,
if you could just guarantee that if we
could all collectively say,
let's figure out,
let's pile all this fucking money
together,
let's figure out how we can make this
better.
What's number one with God?
We gotta figure out a way to make it
easier to figure out what the fuck you
want to do with your life.
You don't.
You shouldn't have to just dive into
some job and be desperate.
I mean,
we were talking today,
Jamie,
about people that we know that you know,
that may be wanting to do something
else,
but they played it safe and now they're
kind of stuck in this weird place where
they can't get out of playing it safe
because they have bills and they get
trapped.
I feel like if we had some sort of like
universal basic income,
it's totally possible that way less
people would do that and then more
people would try to make independent
films or more people would try to become
standup comics or more people would try
to write books or more people would try
to build cars or do whatever the fuck
they're compelled to do.
How did you do it without getting
$12,000?
$3 a year?
I got lucky.
I worked while you wait for it to show
up at your door.
You actually went out into the world and
had to.
You had to move some elements around in
reality to make a new reality.
Yeah,
I guess man,
but I mean I honestly didn't have a lot
of ourselves and exceptional.
I consider yourself an exceptional human
being.
Now.
That's what you consider yourself an
exceptional human being.
Then I knew I was good at taekwondo.
That was about until had a skill.
I was good at one thing.
I knew I was good at one thing.
I was like,
God dammit.
If I can get good at that,
it's totally possible.
I can get good at life.
SMART,
smart way to look at it,
but at the very least you're a hired
hand.
Definitely taking care of people's
problems with your bare fists and Shit.
No.
Well,
I wasn't really taking care of any
competing,
but if you had to society clubs,
they'd have any competitions.
I'd already realized that I could get my
ass kicked too easy by wrestler or by a
a good boxer.
I was having problems already.
So inspiring problems.
But you have,
you built,
you built a world and I'm not saying
like,
I like your idea,
but at the same time it's like not
anybody can do exactly what you did,
but anybody can take the steps that you
did.
Well,
I'm just.
I'm not saying that the same thing that
anybody can take opportunity.
Yeah.
This world we live in offers ample
opportunity.
That's not what I'm saying.
I'm not saying 12 grand more a year.
Maybe.
I really feel like it's possible that
we're doing it wrong.
I just think it collectively,
and I've said this before,
so if you heard me say it before anybody
listening,
I apologize,
but I always say that if we looked at
ourselves as an organism,
if we looked at society as an organism,
what would we.
What would we want to fix other
organism?
Would we want to make the muscle
stronger or would we want to kill the
cancer?
Would we want to figure out what's wrong
with it?
We want to cure the disease.
Well,
the disease has got to be poverty,
like it's the number one problem that we
have as crime and poverty.
Like we've got to focus on that area of
our world and instead of thinking of is,
oh,
they should pull themselves up by their
bootstraps,
or oh,
they need the fucking,
you know,
realize there's opportunity out there.
You just got to go get it.
Everybody's go their own path.
I think collectively as a human species,
we have to look at the world's problems.
Like the world is like real deep poverty
and social problems and look at it
almost like as if we're a living
creature.
If we're living creature and there's
parts of us that are starving to death,
you got to get that part food.
Right.
I mean that's universal.
That's why those commercials with Sally
Fields,
Sally struthers selling brothers were so
compelling.
Right.
Because you would see those babies and
they did
somebody who's hungry and I've got some.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
these are.
I feel like we only have a certain
amount of time,
you know,
just as a,
as an organism that has a finite
lifespan,
you have like 100 years if you're lucky,
you know,
and this thing that we're doing now
where we have a president,
you know,
and you have to fucking go out there and
earn your keep boy and you know,
you get a job in oil,
looks like you're going to have to get
married now you're a dad and then you
just,
you're just like,
all of a sudden I'm dying.
Like I was living.
I worked in a factory,
now I'm dying.
Right.
I don't know if that's the right way to
make the most productive society or the
most enjoyable experience for the people
that are living in.
It's like a little more jewelry,
mom.
Hi.
A little bit.
A little,
a little more joy would,
would,
uh,
the American experience would benefit
from a little more jewelry.
There's so much toil.
And as you said,
there's so much.
You can do anything here,
but you got to do it.
And we spend so much time chasing
something that makes life easier.
I'm not going to argue that money makes
things easier to do,
um,
but chasing,
you know,
the idea of prosperity and one direction
as opposed to spiritual prosperity.
Not saying religion,
saying prosperity of one's soul growing
as a person,
something that doesn't have to stop just
because now you've entered the
workplace,
now you're married and now you're
falling into place with the model for
society.
Like,
you know,
there's still a space in there for
while.
And I think maybe this is where I'm
coming around to your free $12,000
a year.
It's not my idea by any stretch of the
idea of three,
$12,000
a year because maybe it does leave a
little breathing space where suddenly in
that space somebody like,
oh I want to do this and this would make
me happy.
And when I'm happy at this,
it'll trickle down at work.
Like so many people.
Like I go from one job to this job and
you know,
and then I get the weekends,
maybe in my weekends are Tuesday and
Thursday or something like that.
So yeah,
you're right,
I was thinking like I even,
I got privileges and,
and fucking breaks that a lot of people
wouldn't get.
I came from a poor white people,
but it didn't matter.
It was white people and so there are
breaks for me out there somewhere in the
world and I always think through that
prism.
But you're right man,
there's a lot of people out there that
would benefit from like,
here's a cushion.
Here's something to start with.
Where do you go from there?
And,
and what does that $4,000
a month just for being an American?
Yeah,
mean it sounds like thinking,
oh,
you know,
everybody's scamming to try to get
welfare money.
How about just give it to them,
how just give them enough to survive.
Just give everybody enough to survive
and then let's work this shit out.
And then when you make more than x
amount a year,
you can,
you know,
if you're like Kevin Smith or me,
you would say,
look,
I don't want my 12 grand.
Put it back into the system.
Exactly.
Pay All your taxes,
all that stuff.
But this would make us feel like we're
looking out for each other a little bit.
I mean,
it's not.
I'm not.
I'm not fully formed on this idea.
It's just something on battering around
in my head,
but I'm battering it around in my head
the same way I'm batting around this
idea that there shouldn't really be a
president like this.
Just it's only there because we've been
doing it this way for 300 years,
but if it didn't exist,
there's no way that's how you would run
it.
There's no way we would all agree,
but what we should do because once you
get one person who knows the most people
with the most money who have been doing
this the longest and that person will
have a giant advantage over everybody
else and get that person backed up by
these huge corporations that would
benefit by this person being an office
because you'd make laws and make
environmental rules a little bit lax
because we can get away with some shit
and we could make more money.
There's no way we would say,
yeah,
let's do it that way.
There's no fucking way.
We would say,
no,
we want the geniuses of the world.
We want the the professors,
the,
the Elon musks,
we want the,
the Bill Gates,
the people that are very wise and very
intelligent and very rational.
You want to talk to giant groups of them
and we want to form our own opinions and
we should all be voting collectively as
a group.
There shouldn't be some representative
government,
some electoral college.
What are you going to fucking wear a
powdered wig to?
You can't.
You got to ride around on a fucking
horse with some homemade horseshoes with
your powdered wig and your electoral
college.
We're going to read it on a scroll and
the talents square,
standing on an apple box.
Fuck off.
That shit is old,
so you make me feel bad because I get
high and I'm like,
let me write a movie about.
A guy turns to go to a Walrus.
You get high and you want to change the
world.
You're a dreamer.
Dreamer of a day sometimes.
Sometimes not at all.
Sometimes I just want to go watch that
Hawaiian movie.
Rwanda.
It's a good movie.
It was good.
It's good.
Let me ask you,
let me ask you about archery,
which you seem to have fallen in love
with.
Yes.
I love our fucking hard.
Is it to pull back a bone arrow?
It's not easy,
but they make bows for people is like
little kids like field film.
It goes back with the and shit depends
entirely on what you're trying to do.
If you want to shoot a target,
they make bows that a little kid like my
little kids were shooting bows.
Like when my daughter was three,
I got her a bow and Arrow that she could
kind of pull back.
I kind of help her or I would have to
hold onto it and she could pull it back
and then I go,
we're getting ready to go and one,
two,
three and she would let it go.
So you could have a redo that later
before.
That's the way I would need to be
handled.
But then for a compound bow you have to
two possibilities that you're using it
for.
One,
which is target archery,
which is what I do more than anything.
I shoot targets just in my yard and with
friends
and I'll go to some ranges and there's a
place in Vegas I go to that's really
cool.
Um,
and doing that is like you don't need
that much power because it's just about
figuring out where the Arrow's going to
go and be an accurate about it.
But then when you get to,
if you wanted to hunt an animal with it,
then you have a certain obligation to
make sure that your bow is at least a
certain amount,
has a certain amount of power to it.
And most people agree that somewhere
around 45 or 50 pounds it's,
it's,
it's debatable.
But in Texas I know they're like,
I think they fought back a law because
they were trying to keep kids from
bowhunting unless they could pull back,
I think it was 35 pounds or 45 pounds.
I forget what the weight.
So there's a measure of strength in
order to do something.
They don't have to do that for driving.
Well,
the only reason why you gotta be strong
enough to drive
dad,
it's because it's not ethical because
you really almost don't have enough
kinetic energy to actually penetrate an
animal and kill it.
So you wouldn't be,
they'll like harold would stick out of
him,
you know,
and it does happen.
So you have a certain amount of
requirement of the kinetic energy where
it's ethical to bowhunt I remember it.
I'm
trying my father in law,
my wife's a step that buyer and a great
guy.
Um,
he was uh,
a bone Arrow enthusiast.
I wouldn't go into a bowhunter because
then go out and hunt anything.
But he was good at it.
He won medals and shit like,
oh wow.
So um,
I was writing Green Arrow at the time
and I was like,
you know what man,
I should,
if I'm going to write,
he shoot.
He knocks and fires and are,
you should try knocking an arrow.
Just maybe,
maybe there's something there about like
you can describe it rather than make it
up.
And he took me into the backyard with a
bow and Arrow and a target,
big hate target with thing on it and no
compound or anything.
Just a longbow and you know,
I'm like,
God,
this is gonna be easy.
Green Arrow Knox,
like six of these at a time and shit and
knocked one Arrow and went to pull back.
And like the shake began in my arm
pretty fucking quickly.
I didn't get very far back for.
I was like,
Oh shit,
serious Boho.
Pretty serious fucking bow.
But you know,
it.
Number one,
I was like,
I'm not the man I thought I was and I
didn't think I was much of a man to
begin with.
But number two,
I was just like,
um,
I don't think anyone would ever choose
this to fight crime.
Oh my God.
One of those things where you know,
you confront as much as I love this
shit.
I love comic books.
Went to,
that was the moment where I was like,
this shit falls apart.
Like you always find yourself defending
the notion of a Batman.
Many people like,
come on dude,
if you out all the money and you lost
your parents had all the time to commit
to your body,
turning it into a weapon.
You could be Batman or superman.
He got,
he comes from,
but there could be a bad thing and then
all you have to do is try pulling back a
bone Arrow once and you realize like,
well there couldn't be a green Arrow and
he's got it easier than a Batman.
So if he could give that can exist,
then
this probably can't exist.
Although like we were talking about an
episode of podcast the other day.
Could,
could you,
like I saw a video they did on Penn and
teller of Penn and teller were doing it
were somebody shot a bullet at a Samurai
sword and you know,
they had a calibrated so it was hitting
directly into the middle of the blade
and it split the bullet into.
And then the idea was could a butter
knife to the same thing?
And of course the butter knife did the
same thing.
It's split the bullet.
So it didn't matter if it was a hammered
a thousand times razor's Edge Samurai
sword or a butter knife,
that bullet hitting that target split.
And so we were talking about on the
podcast,
I was like,
well that to me,
I said that to me is proof now that you
could fight crime with a Katana sword.
Like you have to be super fucking fast.
I said to Scott Leggett and Scott's
like,
yeah,
making fun of me because he's gone.
Because I said,
I'm not saying you have to be Batman.
He's like,
and then I'm saying you do have to be
better.
But I'm saying like if you were the guy
held a sword and somebody fired a bullet
and it's split with the kickback of the
bullet,
throw the sword into you or you know,
like,
well,
could.
This was a concrete block,
was holding the Samurai Sword.
So you know,
we talked about the pockets and then God
bless the Internet.
Somebody sends us a link of some other
fucking show where they had a guy
holding a sword,
a Samurai swordsman like modern day
swordsman and cuts of baseball and half.
No fucking metal.
Bb Pellets did.
It was fucking nuts.
Now the other thing I watched,
it was like,
you know,
they had the gun calibrated on a hinge
and a laser scope so that it would hit
exactly where they were going for this
guy handwrite it,
man.
This is from the 15 hundreds.
That's a Legit Samurai sword.
Feel how heavy that is.
Like I'm fine.
I didn't live back then I'd be dead.
That's a Legit Samurai sword from the 15
hundreds.
Oh yeah,
that's sharp.
Careful bitch.
Don't do it.
Now.
This guy pulled one agent and he was
like this,
ready?
And then the guy fired the gun and he
went swipes to the air and so you know.
Then they rolled back the footage and
God damn,
if he didn't fucking split that thing
and dude like,
are you sure it's not CGI was,
no,
this was real.
You got to look it up.
No,
I haven't.
I supposed to live in a constant world
of snowpack.
We must.
We must,
because we didn't think about our
childhoods when we were kids.
Some of them would be like the lochness
monster.
You'd be like,
fuck yeah,
it's real.
If you could have snope that shit,
you've got no imagination in your
childhood.
This.
Look at this guy.
Okay.
That was it.
Right now they play.
He just whipped it out and fucking cut.
Now wait until they play a scam.
First of all,
the of Japanese guy looks like a cock
block and this guy and his girl leaning
over the shoulder like,
hey bro,
he's about to earn it.
I fucked this guy.
Watch this
shit.
Yo.
I see CGI.
That's why I ended up there.
See all that red stuff that.
See,
this is CGI,
bro.
We know for sure the CGI is there.
Is there to maybe remove the ranch and
now the Hollywood bowl.
Shit.
That's real.
That's got to be real.
Look,
they talked to Dr Ramani.
She's hot,
right?
And then she got to be smart.
They got her there in the desert.
Check out the one where the guy cuts the
softball and baseball rather.
It's one of those baseball machines.
Pretty big pitches.
I could do it,
but like.
Yeah,
no,
I agree to bb man.
I just don't believe that's real.
You don't think so.
He can be in hoaxed.
C'Mon man.
Believe in big foot.
When you were a kid.
You're kidding me.
I lived for bigfoot.
I went looking for bigfoot for a TV
show.
I spent a week for bigfoot,
so if you can believe in bigfoot bucket
and you believe you can't believe in big
foot because I spent a week later we can
looking for.
I had a bit in my act.
I was doing well.
You know what you don't find when you go
looking for bigfoot.
Black people are more likely to find big
foot.
Then you are black people out looking
for bigfoot.
I go,
well,
you find it's unfuckable white dudes
camping,
trying to work out whatever's in their
heads about big foot.
If you gave everybody $12,000,
a lot more people go look for big.
Maybe they'd find them.
They should at least find something new.
You're like,
you know what,
dude?
You haven't thought this through.
12 k a year could find big foot.
You know?
When I knew that I always had a feeling
that it was probably horseshit,
but what does that cover Yeti and about
adult abominable snowman.
They used to be an animal called a
gigantic pithy gets.
That's what a lot of this is based on.
The gigantic pythius lived as recently
as 100,000
years ago.
Eight or man or a bipedal hominid in the
Orangutang family that was potentially
eight feet tall.
Sky,
ape giant fucking big standing freaky
ape thing.
And the reason why they figured out it
was by people.
Yeah,
well like bigfoot really would be.
It would be big foot.
I mean it was short like us and they
don't know if that's true or not because
we only have some job bones and see what
happened was this guy found a tooth in
an apothecary shop in China.
I don't want to say the 19 twenties and
he was an anthropologist and a.
When he was there,
he looked good.
So like,
uh,
what's this?
Where'd you get this?
And they took him to the place where
they got to eat.
You saw the tooth and he recognized that
as a primate tooth,
but far larger than a gorilla is far
larger than a human being.
She's like,
whoa.
Like this is like a giant tubes.
Like what the fuck's going on?
They took them to this spot and he found
more bones and then it was eventually
recognized as an actual animal and they
call it Jack Canto,
Pythagoras.
Um,
they just don't know that there's been
big foot.
Yeah.
Let me show him the picture of gigantic
[inaudible] next to a Bush area of the
world was,
which I found the baseball gets the same
guy.
Okay.
I can do it just right now before we get
to the baseball guy.
You show the picture of gigantic pithy
gets next to a human being.
I just,
this is what this is,
you know,
scientists believe this.
So this is not like big foot researchers
that are claiming this is a real animal.
This is like actual scientists.
There's a picture of one standing right
next to a dude is like a statue of
gigantic pythagoras covered in hair.
You got it.
It's huge.
So this was a real answer for that right
there.
Again,
that's Harry and the Hendersons.
That is big foot.
I mean if that is what I mean.
And again,
this is not big foot researchers.
They didn't create this.
This is created by actual
anthropologists.
And did this exist as recently as
100,000
years ago with no chance that there's
one still hanging out?
Oh,
there's definitely a chance.
It's just been.
Unless we comb every inch of the earth,
we give an audit on every single living
creature that is in the densest of dense
forests.
We can't really say that that's true
because they find that we find new shit
all the time and the Pacific northwest
where these things.
The reason why it works,
the way it works geologically are
geographically because that animal
existed in Asia.
We know that humans came from Asia,
like literally American Indians,
native Americans there from Siberia.
Like they have the same DNA as people
who came from Asia.
They came across thej or something like
that.
The whole thing has been connected at
separated for as long as humans have
been humans.
Right?
So if we came from that area,
we know that a bunch of other animals
came from that area too,
and they think that it's entirely
possible that that big ass monkey thing
came from that area to somebody brought
it with him.
It just came like all these other things
to make the walk.
That could be where the whole yeti thing
comes from.
The yeti thing is one of those living in
an extremely cold climate during the ice
age.
I mean it's entirely possible when
people either saw a remanence of it or
but never alive.
They would have never crossed paths.
Ip.
I bet they did back in the day for sure.
Are you.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
We will cross paths with all the other
great apes.
We cross paths with Orangutans.
Why would we think we'd cross paths with
a gigantic [inaudible]?
I get some.
You'd see a you'd fucking run.
If it's really smart,
it would have a fucking house in a cell
phone or it's not smart enough to hide
from us.
Like get the fuck out of here.
If we could find a gorilla like,
wait,
this is the problem.
We could find a gorilla,
we could find a champ.
We find the howler monkey should be able
to find it so slick.
It's still a monkey.
It doesn't even have pants.
This stupid fuck he doesn't have shoes
is that doesn't have a.
your barometer for intelligence.
You like pants and you got a man with no
pants.
You're gonna freeze to death.
You're going to figure out fire.
You're walking around on two legs like
you're the shit.
Come on Bro.
Figure it out.
So if he could figure out nothing except
escaping people,
it'd be like,
wow,
what an extraordinarily animal.
Extraordinarily intelligent animal.
It's figured out at least how to get the
fuck away from people to have a house
like,
come on,
I'm not buying it.
I don't think it's a real thing.
I'm with you.
But I think it was a real thing.
I think it was things based on.
I
think it is a real thing.
So do you think the.
Somebody sees one of those frozen in a
cave and then it's passed down or they
could have encountered it if people have
been around for I think,
what did we decide the other day in this
forum?
I think the consensus is like at least
250,000
years we've been in this form.
That means for 150,000
years we lived around those fucking
things and that has got to be in her
head because most likely they're
probably peaceful because they're so big
like a rang of tans,
but if that wanted to it would just
throw water.
Balloons would splatter against the
coconut tree and that'd be the end of
that and you'd imagine the be similar in
our history.
We were like,
and then there was the great April or we
probably killed them.
We probably figured out bows and arrows
and we probably started fucking killing
him from a distance and we're alive and
they're not and nobody remembers nobody
too long ago.
How can we know his chip passed down?
People don't know shit about my
grandmother and grandfather.
We know we killed those hobbit people.
That's a.
that's a really a fairly new revelation
is my favorite part island of Flores.
There's a small being that they found on
the island of Flores that's in the human
species that they're literally calling
the hobbit people.
It's called like Homo floresiensis cysts
or something like that,
and this is.
This is a hundred percent confirmed now.
I mean this is 100 percent accepted by
mainstream science that this was an
actual type of human being are typos.
The third one is type of.
Yeah,
the third one,
and that was a real animal.
It wasn't a human in necessarily like a
homo sapiens,
but it was some human ed or Hominid.
Some human light based on funding school
funding.
A bunch of them they found,
they found quite a bit,
but there was a bunch of resistance.
Now when I say that it definitely lived.
There are people to this day that don't
think it lived,
but the vast consensus amongst these
anthropologists that this is a real
animal,
but there's always gonna be people that
are willing to debate it and they found
a bunch of bones of these little tiny
people like things.
And what they think is that these are
like literally like hobbit people and
that there was always been a legend of,
and uh,
I forget what part of the world is,
but the,
there's a thing called the Orang pendek
think that's how you say it,
or in pen deck.
And that was a little tiny apelike
person and they think that this legend
of these little tiny a black people,
it was the species that this was a real
species.
And they think that this real species
might've even been preyed on human
children.
They might've been competing for
resources.
We might've cannibalize them.
Yeah.
It's entirely possible that we can
belies the of story.
The grimm fairy tales come from like the
troll who comes to steal your baby and
shit like that.
I had this guy Dr Jordan Peterson from
the University of Toronto the other day
on the podcast.
And he was telling me a story about how
when the fall of the Soviet Union or in
Russia in the 19 thirties and doing
during Marxism,
that they had signs.
They had made signs telling people not
to eat their children.
Why?
Because people were so starving to
death,
they were eating their fucking children,
so they had to make billboards saying,
don't eat your children.
Okay,
we just want a different track.
I thought we were talking about the hub.
It's still what we are.
I mean,
I'm talking about cannibalism.
Human beings have been known to you that
he was in the 19 hundreds through the
20th century in our ear in Russia.
They were telling people,
don't eat your children.
I mean,
however many had happened to three
people,
ate their kids for.
I don't know what the numbers were,
but if that was enough to the point
where the government wanted to have a
sign that said,
please don't eat your children.
Like,
Holy Shit.
That's pretty metal dude.
It's,
it's as metal as it gets.
People have been eating people for a
long ass time.
Uh,
and then we stopped.
Why?
Because before you were mad.
Cow Disease comes from.
Did you know that?
Oh my God,
thank God I cleared out a bunch of my
head so I could walk out of here with a
bunch of more knowledge.
Go fire cow disease comes from something
called the brain.
It comes up the other,
the brain tissue of your of other human
beings.
That's one of the ways you get it.
Like at Papa New Guinea,
the cannibals of New Guinea.
They develop,
I think it's called Jacob Corks,
Feld,
which is technically mad cow disease.
It's the exact same thing.
We're getting it because they're feeding
cows cows,
they're feeding cows,
ground up brain matter,
which they're not supposed to fucking
eat.
The cows eat that.
They developed these prions that people
eat that tainted beef in the prize given
by our own brains and does damage and
he's fucking prions can exist in like a
thousand degree temperatures.
They're like these indestructible
organisms and they invade your central
nervous system thing.
You feed a cow and another cow,
but you're saying would have existed
prior to mad cow disease called
something else in human beings.
Well,
it's probably set up to discourage
predation amongst the same species that
you you are a part of because of council
meeting council essentially to not eat
ourselves each other and especially the
brain tissue,
the brain tissues apparently where we
could really differentiate it.
Like if you eat someone else's brain
tissue that's like the new Guinea,
a neurological Jacobs Crutchfield,
which,
which affects cannibals.
Like literally a fucking disease affects
cannibals.
That's a good neurological disease.
When you eat brain matter from your own
species,
that's how they get it and that's.
And so that's maybe that's the reason
why people stopped eating people.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I think it's nature discouraging that,
that this is an aberrant behavior.
This is not.
It's not what we want.
It's not conducive to the survival of
the species.
I said,
well wait,
if I could I,
other than a cow where it gets weird.
Yeah,
champ,
cow brain.
Like a brain.
Let's say there was normal cal.
Brandon didn't have mad cow disease,
no prions.
Could I eat that brand?
Is that okay for me?
Can I eat the normal rate?
And you most certainly can eat,
people eat lamb's brains,
calves,
brains.
It's like very,
very common that people eat brains.
Why?
Because its delicacy.
It's tickets.
Dog Seats in Oregon that some people
even prefer for some meals.
But some people love eating like lambs
brain cows,
brain.
Yeah.
It's trippy.
Do you?
Uhm,
but do you get any.
Is there any disease from it?
Well,
nutrient from.
Do you get something that you don't get
from meeting another meat?
That's a good question.
Um,
I'm not saying make me smarter datalabs
brain.
But I am saying like,
will it make some part of me stronger?
What if it did what it did make you
smarter than smart?
I would be.
It's not like that wouldn't be bad.
What if you.
Sorry.
How dare you,
you if you ate like,
um,
if you wait a really intelligent thing,
I wonder if you'd get more intelligent.
Well,
obviously it would have to be something
outside of your species.
Imagine.
Imagine if there was like magic and
brains and the more brains you ate,
the more power your brain had.
People have believed that it was an
amazing time.
Well,
the zombies,
I used to want brain that's called for
brains in the.
Not In the Romero flick.
Nah.
We'll think about Ramiro's the modern
father of zombies,
right?
Yeah.
I mean there have been a.
The concept of undead human has been
around forever,
but calling it a Zombie,
it comes out of the graveyard.
It wants to eat your brains.
I don't think they ever said brains and
then moving the zombies.
Never say brains.
Who did say brains?
Who Do you think said brains?
First one that might have happened and
you could look it up,
but I think it's a.
is it revenge of the living dead,
which had nothing to do with the living
dead.
Remember the scene in the cemetery where
the girl has sex?
She takes her gear off like.
Yeah,
I remember watching that in early days
of cable.
I'm like,
oh my gosh,
she's going to have sex right here in
the graveyard.
And then there's a Zombie attack.
That movie was great.
Really wonderful.
That was a fun movie and he's like
tongue in cheek.
It did.
It had like a hipness to it.
Something Fun and Shit.
But it was pretty committed to it's Gore
as well.
I've got to write that down.
Revenge of the living dead.
My childhood.
I can't hate on zombies because I'm
bailing on the walking dead.
You go like I got to fulfill my Zombie
logos.
Where is that?
What it's called?
Return of the living dead.
Nineteen 85.
That's right.
And what did say?
Uh Oh.
Oh.
Because it was made by John Russo.
Parted ways and reach the agreement that
Russia would retain the rights to the
living dead suffix while Ramiro use
agreed to use of the dead in any
subsequent out.
Funny Man.
Those are the two dudes came up with
night the living dead.
So he's like,
you take a living dead and I'll take of
the whatever.
That's hilarious.
Split.
Negotiated it.
That's hilarious.
That seems rational though.
Not Bad.
I like to think they did that with a
smile and they shook hands.
And do you think George Romero is like,
man,
I wish I'd put my zombies on TV.
I don't know man.
So that was what I was saying.
The problem is it's not about zombies
anymore.
The zombies like there,
go back to the little people,
little people could they need human
brains.
Yeah.
That was the problem.
One of the things that we're.
We got
to finish that.
One of the things that were human brains
is that those things might have preyed
on people and that we might've prayed on
them and that that might be also what we
did to the neanderthals.
They found the end of towels apparently
that had some scouring marks inside
their heads,
like we might have some one in the past,
might have killed a neanderthal and then
ate him and broke his brain open and a
scoop of Greens cooked it.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Super,
super,
super hard to survive.
Five hundred thousand years ago,
the person that I wanted to win the
prisons who didn't win the presidency.
There was a time,
dude where you'd be eating neanderthals
brains and you're sitting there going,
I never thought I'd be here,
but you'd be doing it,
and by the way,
you would be one of the lucky ones
because most people,
they beat in your brain.
True.
If you were eating the animal brains,
you've survived.
Dude,
you clubbed in with that mastodon bone
over the fucking head while I was trying
to rape your mom or whatever the hell
went wrong with those dark.
Can it just be just be like a first
Thanksgiving story where like me and the
neanderthals like come to a common
ground.
You're eating is bread.
Give me his brain and I give them some
wavy,
like a dude who just fell here.
We have no need for me to his brain and
like once a year we'll only do this once
a year.
Right?
We imagine if that was the deal,
like,
look,
we're not going to kill you.
Please don't kill us,
but if one of your guys dies,
can we eat them?
That's not.
I mean call me crude,
but that's not a bad deal.
Right?
It's not the worst deal.
And think about this.
It's like,
why?
What are you going to do with them?
I know,
I know.
There's the sentimentality and the
histology of like,
oh,
the debt,
but it's like you're just going to put
them in the ground is going to rock.
What?
A waste of energy.
So you give us your dead will give you
are dead and that will keep peace
amongst the living.
Dude.
We're onto a movie writer or a better
version of government in a world where
you were like,
who needs a president?
Maybe this.
This is the civilization civilization
stabilizer.
Have you ever heard of a Tibet and sky
funeral?
No.
Do tell them here to freak the fuck out.
Here we go.
[inaudible] the way they handle it in
Tibet,
the Himalayas,
they take the body out,
a score it,
they chop it up into chunks and then the
vultures come in and they get it down to
the bone and then they smash the bones
up and then the vultures come in and
they consume the bones and they do it.
All the images of it.
You could watch it here.
Pull.
It blew my mind.
As much as I'm less kind of a let down,
not at the end of the day.
This is how they deal with their dead.
They feed them to literally feed them
two vultures and they film it and they
take photos of this.
It's like,
this is like this intense ceremonies.
That's what they do now.
Who Will,
you could see it like,
that's why I'm having Jamie pull it up.
I thought this was like the pictures of
the little.
Oh No,
no.
This is happening right now too.
So I'm not going to put it up.
No cemetery with the images because
there's a bunch of websites.
Skytap,
some Tibetan sky funeral.
I mean we don't want to watch it
necessarily.
It's just like look at some of the
images.
But there's,
they filmed them now.
It's like people can see the watch one,
like if I have to choose between the
two.
Yeah,
you don't want to be,
there might be a little weird.
I'd write it up on youtube either
though,
but just give me the images so that we
could see them.
So um,
that's just a,
a spinal chord in the left corner.
Show the motherfucker,
this is just one of their dead monks.
Just a regular person.
So rather than bury them in the ground
and this guy just getting picked apart
and then after they pick them apart,
like these,
almost down to nothing,
then they have the bones and they'll
take the bones and smash them and the
birds would come in and eat the bones
and the birds know,
like if you,
what you just clicked on Jamie up above
right there.
Like where you see the body right next
to that.
Yeah,
look at that.
So they taken this guy and they just,
they treat them.
Is that a dead human being?
Now?
It's a bunch of debt to human beings.
They take these human beings that die in
wherever part of the world.
This is in,
uh,
in Tibet and they cut their bodies up
for the vultures and they wear gloves.
I mean these are modern people.
If he's got Levi's on and a belt and
he's chopping up this,
this person's body.
And then they leave it out there.
And if you go through those series of
pictures,
Jamie,
there's a whole series of them,
oh my God.
And you see,
oh yeah,
I wasn't ready for that.
It's tendency that shit just throwing
dead bodies out of the ball just become
clean.
Well,
they got harder to.
Yeah,
they help because they want it to be
done within a good amount of time and
the more it's chopped up like that,
the more vultures that will attract and
the quicker the whole process will be.
What is the reaction?
Do you think it's Ooh squeamish or do
you think it's a ego?
Do you think it's just like what?
Like,
no,
I'm far more complex.
Like I've got way more going on in my
head and body.
I can't wind up as bird food,
but at the end of the day,
your fruit for something.
Yeah man,
it's not the worst way to go because
you're gone.
Well,
I mean as long as you don't fucking like
at the mouth of something while you're
still alive.
But if they were like,
look,
when you dead however you pass,
we want to feed you to something else.
I'm going to think I'm okay with that
particular life.
Eat a lot.
Motherfucker.
They'd remember me.
They'd be like,
oh,
he fed the village for like men months.
You'd be amazed how quick they put you
down.
They'd eat you so fast.
Take the elephant like due to go fast.
You'd you'd.
You'd disappear in a second.
Yeah.
I know a dude who was in Africa when
someone is shot an elephant,
he said they just trumped that elephant
up to like a million pieces and handed
them out to all these villages that came
from far and wide to get elephant meat.
I was like,
whoa,
so everyone could eat.
I was like,
Hey,
I'll go have a bunch of people eating
nuts.
Some asshole was just like,
hey man,
just to kill something.
Well,
I don't know.
The Guy,
the guy who killed the actual elephant,
it might've been one of those guys that
will just went there to kill an elephant
and then.
But when they killed the elephant,
so it's such a catch 22,
but when they kill the elephant,
it's very beneficial to the environment
because they have more.
They can pay for more of the park
rangers to protect the elephants against
poachers and then the people all around
the village get the meat.
This is the real thing is someplaces
elephants are endangered,
but some places they decide,
the people decide there's a surplus.
Those elephants,
because they're trampling on people's
crops,
are eating people's stuff.
You know,
automatically you say like,
Hey,
you should never kill off offense for
sure,
but the real problem is with some of
these extremely poor people were
elephants invade their crops.
You can't do a God damn thing,
and those are the people that want help
and then they hire someone to come and
kill an elephant.
Very.
The whole thing is very fucked up.
Way more complex than way more
complaint.
My teenage daughter may painted.
Well,
I mean we would all like to think that
human beings and elephants live so far
away from each other,
that it was a nonissue.
When we just let the elephant survive
out there in the wild and leave them the
fuck alone,
that's what we'd all like,
right?
The problem with that,
as they do live with people and they
live with people that are super poor and
they live with people that have houses
that are made out of fucking hey,
and there are people too in this bill
though.
Yeah.
If it's like a.
it's just like,
you know,
it's not all.
I mean it's not always that there's a
lot of it is trophy hunting.
There's a lot of it is poachers trying
to steal ivory and there's a lot of real
darkness to killing elephants,
no doubt about it and ideally no one
should ever have to kill an elephant,
but if,
if you're.
If you don't want those people to kill
elephants,
he,
someone's got to figure out a way to at
least capture them and make it valuable
to transport them to some other part of
Africa where they're not going to kill
this guy or tramples and eat all of his
crops.
Unless you don't give a fuck about the
guy you know and you don't care and you
say,
well,
that guy's going to have to starve to
death because the elephant is just as
important as a living organism as the
guy is.
Which is another argument,
something to fall in order for you to
rise.
I see how people think that way.
I understand.
I understand where they're coming from.
I,
I disagree.
You know,
I'm,
I'm more into people.
I like people more than any other
animal,
but I love other animals too.
So I get where they're coming from.
I just think that,
uh,
it's complex.
Yeah.
Eight in any animals complex.
Like my buddy Brian just kill a rat in
his house.
He had a rat trap and kill a rat.
And I was like,
Whoa,
you got them.
Well that's good.
And I sent them a text message,
got them.
And then I was thinking,
let's one of the few animals so you
could cheer for it's murder
and people back up.
Everybody backs you up.
You showed a picture of a rat,
you killed with a trap.
Like,
ah.
It must have been satisfying.
Yeah.
Well done man.
Fuck Outta grosses me out.
If you're watching TV and you hear stop
and you're like motherfucker and you go
in the kitchen and you got a fat rat,
you are happy.
I've,
you know,
we live out in the.
We live in the Hollywood hills and
sometimes it gets dry and you know,
rats fucking.
It's crazy.
It's one of those things that like,
I grew up in New Jersey and you would
imagine that,
you know,
according to every joke you've ever
heard,
that's where I would have encountered a
rat.
Never encountered a rat in my life until
I lived in Los Angeles.
And so you're living in the hills and
the desert.
Yeah,
I lived in the suburbs of Jersey.
There weren't a lot of rats and we by
the water too.
Flow.
So the rats,
if there were rats,
they lived in the rocks by the water and
shit.
Um,
there were a lot more efficient in those
days as opposed to lately.
But um,
but yeah,
fuck.
Was I going with the rats?
So until,
until I got to Los Angeles,
they come out of the hills because it's
dry and we got a pool and water tracks
like that cream.
Then you know,
you think like,
oh my God,
if I ever had a rat in my house,
I'd fucking go ape shit.
And then suddenly you know,
you're like,
oh,
we are a house that gets rats in it.
And it's not like the stereotype that
you always think of where it's like we
live like pigs and the filth everywhere.
It's just like they're looking for
fucking food and yeah,
that's the creepy thing.
You'd be sitting in your office and you
hear some things in a wall.
Yeah.
And you realize,
oh my God.
And they got,
once they get in,
they get the inside of your house down
to a system in science,
unless you plug all the holes and we've
had to go through that thing where you
plug all the holes and then the
skittering stops.
You never hear it again.
Motherfuckers,
they will camp out in your house if it's
a safe spot to like,
this is where we live now.
Didn't make it a little nest in there,
especially if you have insulation in
your attic like the nest and that stuff
happens.
But you're right,
man.
People get like,
yeah,
that's an animal that you're allowed to
kill.
So like elephant,
no rat.
Yes.
You know,
like tiger?
No.
You know like mouse.
Yes.
Comes back to we have rules.
It's true.
Yeah.
There's always gonna be a guideline
there.
I found a mouse the other day and I've
got one of those little pills with a mop
for barbecuing a little in the mop thing
was sitting there and I saw this little
motherfucker run up the top and go into
the bucket.
I was like,
God damn it.
I got a mouse in that thing.
Fuck,
like,
that's gross.
He's going to shit all over that little
brush.
So I took them over to the.
I picked up the bucket.
I took them over to the fence and just
emptied them out on the other side and
he fell and he just hit the ground and
just stand there like,
what the fuck this guy?
And he just slowly started walking off
and like,
I don't think he knew what the fuck
happened.
Right.
But immediately I thought,
damn,
I should have fed them to my chickens.
What do you mean a chicken?
Would he have mouse?
Oh dude,
would they eat a mouse?
They go after them,
like raptors,
like raptors in Jurassic Park.
Like what you would imagine should get
us to eat.
Mice are straight up dinosaurs.
If you remember that scene in Jurassic
Park.
What is that?
A chicken with the mouse?
Yeah,
pull it back so we can see it.
They'll fuck a mouse up dude.
And they fight over them.
They all know.
And so they run after each other,
like they stole it from the fucking cat.
Look at that cat.
That's like pitch.
Like,
that was mine.
That was mine.
What the fuck.
And then he's going to eat that.
I've seen chickens eat mice.
My chickens,
I see.
I've seen them meet one that I fed them.
Me.
Oh,
they don't want to stare.
They fight.
They,
they peck at each other.
They fucking,
they bite off each other's skin.
Trying to get at the mouse,
they steal.
Little got a little piece there like
remember that scene?
A
video of a snake?
No,
a bunny mother bunny fighting a snake.
This video starts with the snake over a
little patch of baby bunnies.
A nowhere.
This fucking mother rabbit smokes in
dude.
And you've never seen anything fight
like this and you're laughing.
You abby goes into the UFC ship,
but this or the mother rabbit went after
the snake and wouldn't stop it.
She wasn't like,
I'm going to get the snake away from my
baby.
The snake fucked off.
It's like I get it.
I get it.
And the rabbit wanted revenge.
The rabbit was like,
fuck you.
And kept going like it was something I'd
never seen before.
Generally,
you know,
unless you're a bear,
right?
You defend.
Get the thing away from you and then you
go take care of your fucking young.
This rabbit,
chase it.
See,
here it is,
bitch.
Watch this shit.
This is crazy.
So I'm sitting there,
gone into at eight the bunny already.
I don't know if it did anything,
but it's just right now on top of all.
Is that squeezing the bunny?
Look at it.
Oh Wow.
So it's the babies in there,
uh,
killed the baby.
It looks like it killed one.
Right?
That one's pretty quiet.
It killed a couple of them.
Look.
So watch her go fucking ape shit dude.
It just smothered.
Or fucking babies,
man.
Imagine are coming back and seeing that.
And this is why this is crazy,
but do it.
It goes on for at least a minute and a
half.
Even when the gets away.
Did you know that a rabbit could do this
shit?
No.
Look at that.
Look at how many times have I bank with
those kids,
biting it and kicking it at the same
time.
She's like,
tore up its body.
It's body's got all these holes in it
now.
Wow.
Not done.
Watch.
Wait til it gets to the wall and there's
a fucking three 60.
Watch this shit.
Oh whoa.
It's trying to kill it.
Yes.
Pull.
It's going after it and pulling it down.
Yes.
It doesn't want it to get away at wants
to kill it.
Revenge Dude.
Like that's shit.
You see it flip because it almost
bitter.
Wow.
That's not done.
Poisonous snake rabbits not done.
Wow.
That is amazing man.
Where,
what part of the world I live in?
Uh,
the,
there's a.
where is it?
Because you hear kids talking and it's
definitely got.
They got an accent.
You hear kids talk.
They have an accent or they could hear
the kids going do it.
Bonnie and stuff like that.
Like England or some shit.
Not Quite England,
but like definitely Europe.
But look to even on the rocks.
This motherfucker's not done from hell's
hard.
I stab at the.
She doesn't say it says save babies.
She didn't save him.
That fucking thing.
Killed a couple of them.
She might've saved one.
Maybe click on and see if like somewhere
there's an explanation or something like
that.
Or maybe that's what they told the kids.
She saved the babies,
but I didn't see any movement there.
To me that was the story of a mother
coming home.
Seeing your kids dead and was like,
I'm gonna fucking kill you.
And that's a very human story.
You don't really think about that in the
animal kingdom.
But like that's very human.
I mean there it is,
there is revenge or whether she just
knew that if that thing was alive,
it presented a threat to the other baby
and she had to kill it because if she
let it go,
eventually she would have to leave to
come back to get food and maybe it'd be
gone.
It would find out where it was.
Maybe she knew that
it was in the middle of like the worst
moment of your fucking life.
We've just lost two kids and you're
like,
I still have to fucking kill this thing
to death.
Otherwise it'll come back and take my
other baby may be me in the night.
Oh.
And like so poorly equipped for battle
to the death.
All fluffy and shit with nothing but
like,
but look what happens.
Like almost unleashed.
Just like grabbing and kicking,
scratching like apparently until you're
just going that fucking room.
And that snake was a pretty nasty
customer,
but he was still like,
I'm done.
Fuck it.
I'm fucking done.
Serpents and snakes and lizards and all
those unfeeling cold things.
You know that that existed before time.
Chickens are in that group,
bro.
Really?
Yeah.
They're in that group.
Do you?
Don't.
You don't realize it until you see them.
Tear of mouse,
part primordial.
They're like raptors there.
Jurassic Park.
Raptors,
they're just little.
You see them in the kitchen.
Opened doors and shit with lucky.
They're not that smart,
but they're smart enough to like if I,
if I have rocks around my house,
but pick up a rock,
the chickens will go towards it because
you know the bugs under it.
Oh really?
Figured that out.
Yeah.
But it's not about being smart.
It's about that lizard brain.
Like they mostly are there.
They're omnivores.
They mostly eat grain because most of
them are being kept by people.
That's the best way for you to feed
them,
but when you let them lose feed every
fucking thing that moves everything,
every bug,
dead,
every state,
snails,
dead,
anything,
whatever.
Whatever's on the ground dead.
And apparently they caught a mouse.
The fight to the death over that mouse.
It chase each other,
clawed out of each other's mouths.
They're little eating machine with a
chicken.
Oh yeah.
They need each other for sure.
They pick holes in each other.
But I mean,
is that just picking holes?
A few chicken.
They'd eat the shit out of it.
Really.
He cooked some chicken and let it or
made raw chicken and put it out there.
They get the fuck out of it.
They wouldn't even think it would.
Then they go open a kitchen door.
They're not smart.
I'm 22.
Does it irritate you to watch Jurassic
Park where you're like,
where to fucking feathers,
bro.
We all know these things now.
Now drastic world just recently did have
feathers.
No,
no feathers.
No.
Well,
it's probably too hard like CGI wise
because you can't use just one big
texture that's going to definitely
flowing cash grab.
Like when they reboot the franchise,
that's going to be the best source.
We finally got feathers on.
Now.
It's fucking historically accurate
memory.
When we were kids,
Columbus discovered America and
dinosaurs were green.
Yeah.
The good old days were the days,
the days and now they're off.
There's a museum of Montana dinosaur
thing.
I'll be honest with you,
I understood it and was that in as much
as you find a bunch of bones and then
you extrapolate what it looked like?
Well,
you mean it depends on the extent of
what you're finding on the lake there.
There has to be like some sort of
consensus on what actually is a
dinosaur.
Like how much of this belongs to the
same animal,
especially because you're dealing with
fossilized remains and the problem with
fossilized remains or it's not really
the bone anymore.
Like the bone disappears.
It's replaced by minerals and it makes
us rock.
Right?
So you can't really do DNA tests on it
for the most part.
So you've got to find enough of them
laid out in the same way where you agree
this was this animal,
you know,
and they've changed that over the time
from the beginning of the first
discoveries of dinosaurs to today,
but now they've been doing it for so
long.
They were pretty good idea.
And then every now and then they find a
new one and they go,
we'll check out this motherfucker.
What does he.
But again I got get,
I'll grant you.
Hey Liz,
would his bones would look like if we
put it together?
But how do they get to like it's skin
was like this.
They don't,
they don't.
So it was all bullshit speculation for
us and now at least they're gone.
We think it's got feathers.
I'm pretty sure it's got feathers.
One guy had a really cool idea about t
rex.
The t rex would have like vulture colors
the t rex did it because it was.
They think that T-rex,
like some people think that he was a
Predator and other people think that it
was a scavenger.
And if one of the reasons why they think
that he's a scavengers,
they,
they look at it the way his body's built
that like you couldn't possibly run very
fast.
He couldn't really possibly chase things
down.
He's really super awkward.
But then there's other people that point
to the idea that the atmosphere itself
was very different back then and it
might have been much richer and thicker
and it actually might have been able to
support an animal like that easier in
terms of its size in terms of its size,
in terms of the amount of life on the
planet itself,
that that animal was so large and
consumed so much,
but everything was so large back then
and everything consumed so much back
then.
There were so many examples of these
mega animals,
right?
Like brontosaurus fucking Allosaurus,
t rex and these crazy gigantic fucking
things roaming the earth.
This speculation is that life was.
There was more richness of life.
There was more life and so the animals
that consumed life,
whether it's in the form of plants,
like a brontosaurus or in meet like an
a,
a t rex,
they just got bigger and bigger and
bigger because there was so much to
consume.
There was no need to like hold back
their size.
Whereas like if you're a champ or if
you're a human,
like there's only so much you can eat.
The more you eat,
we've shown the more people eat and the
more prosperous nation,
the larger the people start to get.
Right,
and so I think that it's entirely
possible that that's the case with the
world back then that the whole world was
like.
It just supported bigger things.
It was just more life,
more green life,
more animals for t rex to eat and it was
just this big fucking thick oxygenated
soup of life that nobody was lizard
looking.
We'll more probably bird in lizard
because today we have crocodiles,
we have Komodo dragons and we have
chickens and we have eagles and Eagle is
fucking clearly a lot like a dinosaur,
right?
It's crazy ass thing with swords on its
fingers and death
in its eyes and it swoops down and it's
got the strength to catch a fucking fish
in the water and pull it out and fly
with it.
They can catch goats and pulled them off
the side of cliffs and watch them fall
and smash on the rocks below.
They do it as a strategy in order to get
to eat.
It will knock it down.
I've,
I've heard,
I've never seen videos,
videos of Eagle,
not gonna catch a mountain goat,
they pull them off the side of the cliff
and then they let them go and they smash
on the rocks down below.
Golden Eagles in particular because
there's some of the largest eagles.
Yeah,
giant fucking easy span.
Flying Demons the way they snatch them
and doing it just because that's the.
Yeah,
that's how they get meat.
Watch this shit.
This is crazy.
Look a Golden Eagle eyes and that thing,
that evil,
but it looks very much like a,
like a dinosaur to sweat this.
He swoops down and they know what's
coming to they buggy.
They're like,
fuck this.
He swoops down God's Shitty resolution.
This must drive you nuts.
As a filmmaker,
I'm fine.
A swooped down.
Clerky drops down.
Boom.
He gets one or they takes it.
Watch this snatch up,
up and away.
I am a beautiful,
beautiful balloon.
Oh my God.
This poor thing.
It's like,
oh my God,
look at that.
He literally follows it to the rocks to
make sure it lands on its head and then
boom all the way to the ground.
So this is a strategy.
This is a strategy for eating these
goats.
So he'll go down there and now,
easy pickins.
Easy pickins means he earned it.
Caught a caught.
A goat's leisure is red in tooth and
claw to.
He carries it right to the rocks and
then lets it go.
Watch this right here,
but wow.
Flow so far with that one.
Look how far he flew.
That's incredible.
With a goat.
Maybe if he got a good hold of it,
he doesn't have to throw it.
If you couldn't carry,
I couldn't carry it.
Go that far with them.
What are majestic animal?
Do you think?
The goat.
There's any part of the goats.
It's like,
maybe I'll survive this story.
I'll have to tell some amazing man.
Amazing fucking life form flying
monster.
Predator.
Do you think now that's not an American
Eagle.
That's a what?
That's a Golden Eagle.
I think the largest eagles are these
Venezuelan eagles called Harpy Eagles
and those motherfuckers kill monkeys.
Really?
Yeah.
That was that a mountain goat that was a
mountain goat because it looked bigger
than a mountain goat.
Some mountain go here pretty big.
I'm sure if you killed,
kill killing a chimpanzee that killed
wolves.
So just swooped down here in Mongolia,
the have trained eagles,
Golden Eagles to attack wolves and
killed them,
and then they use their for.
Oh,
there's video of that too.
Can we?
Oh yeah.
For makes you feel lazy.
It makes you feel like it should make
us,
but we should go kill something.
No sweat this.
He swoops in.
Eagle swoops in and the wolf knows
exactly what the fuck is going on.
I look at that guys face.
That guy is a direct descendant of
gangs.
Con.
I mean they have the traditional Mongol
were on and these eagle swooped down.
They see the wolf.
They know exactly what to do.
He's got the little things.
This guy like,
fuck this.
You can't really defend against that.
I would have never thought that eagles
were so fearsome to wolves.
They thought wolves would fucking eagle
up if you would turn around and bite it,
set up at the right time.
I believe a wolf dude wolfs are for
Rochus,
but this wolf is way bigger than the
Eagle too.
Like if you look at the actual body
size,
the Eagle,
I mean it's like the wolf site three or
four times bigger.
How small he is.
Look,
he just grabs the back of his fucking
neck and pierces him with his claws.
It's amazing.
The second bird of the same team,
this poor dog double Jack on,
but the first one is already handled
them.
Look,
he just grabs a hold of his head with
those knives and just sticks those
knives in his neck.
Are they eating?
Start eating the fucking wolf.
You would've never thought I would have
said,
dude,
why didn't they ever show this shit in
Milan?
This looks amazing.
So he gets his eagle friends that dogs
definitely dead ranks boys.
Oh yeah.
The Wolf's dead.
Dead as fuck.
Look,
another one's coming in.
How come the hands right on his arm.
This is amazing.
Why don't they try to eat the man?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
You know what I'm saying?
Like how long before they're like,
you know,
we could keep attacking these walls that
we could turn it.
Hit the dude in the hat.
Well maybe if the dude keeps bringing
them wolves,
they're like,
look guys,
she seems pretty cool.
Yeah.
But if the bird figures out like he
didn't bring me a fucking wolf.
There are wolves out there for the
taking just like they're humans.
I could be picking the spool off.
I can turn around and you just fucking
eyes out to.
Good point.
Damn,
you're making a lot of sense today.
Hi,
I'm well.
What are we going to look up before?
We're going to look up that.
Oh,
the Harpy Eagle that swoops down and
kills monkeys as one of the reasons why
we look up all the time.
Apparently people look up,
they have a consistent like instinct to
look up like you're in the forest or
something like that.
You look up.
One of the main reasons is they think
that there's an ancient instinct that we
have to protect ourselves from flying
raptors because they found,
you know,
old hominids,
like not necessarily humans,
but in the human tree that had predation
marks from eagles and the inside of
their skulls.
So it came from that.
Yeah.
From Eagles,
from Eagle swooping down and you know,
especially in larger equals.
Yeah,
look up a shit.
No,
no,
not look up shit.
Do you look for danger?
Yeah Bro.
I'll use google to like,
come on mother fucker.
I Google everything.
I need references.
No I don't,
but apparently it's an instant.
I'm not mostly in the woods,
like looking around in the forest,
but apparently when you go to the
forest,
right,
there's an instinct to look up that's
connected to cats to potentially,
you know,
most of the time big cats are not hiding
in the trees and they come down and get
fucking cats.
I'm worried about the ticks up because
I'm like,
ticks ticks in my hair,
man.
Somebody you have to use a big later
burned lyme disease.
Man,
that's a dark and silent killer.
And it was something we shit develop in
our lifetime.
I right about that didn't exist when I
was a kid.
And then one day somebody was like,
if you get bit by a deer tick,
it'd be fucked up for a long time.
I was like,
mono times a thousand.
Yeah.
I know a guy who got lyme disease,
misdiagnosed.
Steven Kotler.
I'm a guest on the podcast really
recently misdiagnosed for about a year.
Wound up spending three years in the
hospital because of it,
three years in the hospital because of
lyme disease,
wrecked his immune system because of the
misdiagnosis of over a year and all
these different doctors had told them it
wasn't.
It wasn't that that's what it is.
You're,
you might be going crazy.
One doctor told him he had aids,
are you fucking Dr you have aids?
And he's like,
what?
Like the,
it was,
you know,
during the time where a lot of people
had aids and he was saying like,
this is what it was like.
No,
I think,
I think it's lyme disease.
Like was like,
no,
you have a.
it's like,
Holy Shit,
you know,
because your immune system is devastated
when you have lyme disease and you just
wasting away like to get the fuck out of
everybody.
Jesus,
he didn't tell us the numbers,
but I believe he got so as Damon Wayans
would say.
It had to go through a lot to get there
though.
It was easier ways.
I'm sure he wouldn't have chosen.
He didn't want it,
but I think he learned a lot about
himself,
like overcoming this incredible health
crisis.
But I've had many people that I'm
friends with get lyme disease.
I know at least.
But you go out in the woods alone for
hunting.
Yeah.
So that's.
And that's where they're all contracting
it.
I know several people who have gotten it
from that for sure.
Yeah.
But I know other people that have gotten
it just from a don't say just from state
New York,
you know,
you're just like,
well I don't go fishing or something
like that.
I mean,
he doesn't have to be upstate New York
and be North Carolina.
It could be,
you know,
a lot of doors though,
right?
Almost all outdoors.
Almost all ticks ever happened here in
California.
Yes,
yes.
It's not as prevalent,
but it has happened here in California,
like tick so fucking bad news,
man.
Their carriers and that disease is
insidious and it's.
It's a tricky one too because it's
oftentimes misdiagnosed or especially
when he was talking about Caitlyn was
saying that the doctors in California
weren't really hip to it because it's
not common,
but aids was more common,
so that's one of the reasons why this
guy was also insurance and you know,
like it was a shitty deal with a doctor,
wasn't get paid very much for each
person that came to him,
so it wasn't very motivated.
We kind of went through the full gamut
of explaining how it came to be,
but yeah,
misdiagnosed for a year.
One US bank three years in the hospital.
Yeah,
I,
that's a losing that much time to
something where you're like,
what Pitney of fucking.
Again,
that's where human arrogance or ego
would come in.
We're going to be like a fucking bug put
it's dirty,
spit on me,
and now I'm going to be in a hospital
three fucking years.
This isn't fucking fair,
and then you remember their guys out and
fucking Tibet voltage drops to the
vultures can eat and while you're making
movies and smoking weed,
you relax.
Yeah,
relax file I think seems pretty awesome.
I'm not sweat the ticks anymore and
that's when Shit tastic.
I came back from recently.
I was in Vancouver.
I've been at.
I haven't been in the woods lately
through a directed two episodes of the
flash one last season,
which was fucking fun.
And that one episode,
the second episode.
He's now,
uh,
yeah,
I think so.
The old episodes,
but it's a CW show.
I need to watch that show.
It's,
it's dope if you like DC comics.
Oh my God.
I love movies.
I'm,
I'm much more into them now as I get
older than I was when I was younger.
It's a show.
It's the center is about a boy runs very
fast to solve all those problems,
but at the really it's just soap operas
for boys and girls.
I'm not even gonna limit it to.
It's just,
they're very soap operatic.
It's,
you know,
it's like very episodic and they thrown
an adventure each week,
but it's more about the relationship
between the characters and stuff.
That's kind of what you keep coming back
for.
It's good balance of heart humor and
heroics.
Like,
you know,
the got the family stuff or friendship,
stuff like that.
It's important to be friends.
Then it got some laughs and then the
heroics is like,
Holy Shit,
look at them,
run fast.
Holy Shit.
Look at her fly.
I did an episode of supergirl as well,
so I was in Vancouver like three times
in the span of the last year.
Um,
and we were at one point out in the
woods and I remember being kind of like,
uh,
can I get some protection and like,
so you're going to get laid out here in
the woods.
And I was like,
no for like ticks and stuff like that.
Like last night,
a real big problem here.
I don't know if it is,
I'm from the Pacific north woods you
would imagine,
but I don't think it's a real big
problem in the Pacific northwest.
I think it's more,
it's more of an east coast problem.
Well,
they named it after lyme,
Connecticut.
That's where all the.
Where it originated.
That's where the original diagnosis of
it was.
How long had existed before.
That is anybody's guess.
I don't know,
but I do know it's also connected to
other neurological disorders like I'm
more jealous.
Magellan's is a weird one where people
think they have strands of fibers
growing out of their body and oftentimes
they have these crazy delusions and what
Kotler was saying was that it has a
neurological effect and he didn't have
more gallons disease,
but I'm one of the doctors that I
interviewed about more jealous.
He was telling me that he believes it's
connected to lyme disease because lyme
disease has some sort of neuro toxicity
effect.
It has some sort of an effect where it
distorts reality and Kotler had a real
problem
member he was talking about.
He couldn't figure out whether a
greenlight meant go or he didn't
understand how to drive anymore like
his,
his body out of nowhere,
nowhere out of nowhere.
And he's realizing,
wow,
something's really wrong and this neuro
toxicity effect this,
this whatever it was doing to pollute
his brain's ability to function
correctly,
the more jealous people think.
It's also what makes you claw at your
skin and think there's fibers in there
and you start seeing shit that it's.
And then they get like fibers from their
clothes stuck to their scabs and they
think that's growing out of their body,
but it's more likely just an offshoot of
lyme because apparently when you get
lyme,
you're not getting one bacteria.
It's one of the reasons why the results
that people have when they,
when they get bitten,
vary so widely.
It's like there's a gang of different
ones and there's a bunch of different
also like a neighboring poisons and
toxins that this,
this tick could have in its body.
It might just not be the simple lyme
disease,
Oh,
here's that one.
Bacteria that tick hasn't number tick.
The tick might have a host of different
pathogens that affect you as a lyme
disease.
Like it's not.
This is this guy who has it explaining
it to me and I'm shitting my fucking
pants because I know so many people
gotten this and there's no one like,
Hey,
take this antibiotic and knocks it out.
No,
no,
no.
And it varies widely how your body
reacts to it when you get it.
My friend's son,
my friend,
Steven Rinella,
his son got it.
The doctor misdiagnosed.
The kid wound up getting bell's palsy.
Where face started going numb in child.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
He was in his fifties.
Well,
most likely the young body could
probably bounce back from it better than
the old body,
but for a lot of people,
like my friend cody has it.
He's like 26 I think,
and he says his fucking joints hurt all
the time and that it's from,
from having lyme,
like from that point on,
like his joints,
right?
Always achy.
I've no have not been bit by a tick and
I don't have lyme disease,
but lately I've noticed I'm 46 now so I
have noticed aging in a way that I
haven't before my knee lately doing
nothing and I'm not an active guy at
all.
Has been being fucking weird and
somebody said it's from descending a
hill.
I walk every day,
walk the dogs like a mile and a half a
pill and back down.
That's like my exercise routine and the
down the hill.
They said that's what's doing it to you
that like how do you walk?
And I was like,
I don't know like this and like you
don't do heel toe.
And I was like I don't,
I don't know,
don't know.
Look.
And I apparently I walk ball,
he'll ball heel up is the way to go.
Yes.
Well apparently is what they're saying,
but I don't know anybody like unless
you're,
unless you're thinking about walking
heel toe,
I don't know if you necessarily fall
into a heel toe type pattern.
The real issue is there's a big issue
with shoes like the way we have
constructed shoes,
we've created a gate that's an unnatural
like heel toe forward gate,
like people always used to walk on the
ball of their foot because the ball of
the foot acts as like a shock absorber
and it allows you to slowly lower your
heels down to the ground,
which is why a lot of like those
barefoot runners,
they do so well,
like if you're running barefoot all the
time,
you're developing these incredibly
strong feet and they,
they,
they're springing and they don't need
like these big thick cushions.
But we,
and I guess it was like the 19 seventies
when Nike came out with a running shoe,
they developed that big fat ass.
He'll and then people started running on
the heel.
They started bouncing on the hill
instead of using the natural shock
absorbing motion of lending shoe change
the way we walk as human beings.
It changed our running gait.
Wow.
Yeah.
Which were also,
would it effect your walking gait?
Sure.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
Because prior to the the sneaker who,
what was that guy's name?
Phil Knight or something like that,
or if I don't know who invented Nike Gym
years.
Phil Knight Champion Gym.
He goes,
yeah,
he's.
He's a sneakerhead film.
That literally changed.
Was it?
He buys yeezys with A.
Exactly.
Thank you.
God bless his soul in there.
And I was like,
maybe that's kind of your west.
Yeah,
it's amazing and you don't know that.
Thank you.
I try to keep my head firmly lodged up
the ass of the nineties.
That's where shit was good for me.
He was like,
you don't know what yeezys are like,
you get away from me,
you're not poisoning.
Always keep your finger on the pulse
chairs.
But meanwhile people will look at this
Nigga,
hey yo,
fresh cheese.
And he's like,
yeah,
Jamie gets out and he looks over at me
like how many people have done it?
Like five or six years.
A lot.
No,
look,
I'm not saying it's me.
Your big sneaker head.
Oh,
he's a dork.
We had a pair of sneakers growing up.
We had a smog cast pair of sneakers for
podcasts.
He's a super sneaker Dork,
seekers are awesome and I loved them,
but uh,
only like,
sorry,
I got to tell me man,
those converse two's fell apart on me.
Quick kind of shocked,
like converse ones virtually
indestructible,
you know,
converse,
two's fell apart on me pretty fucking
quick.
You tend to do a lot more active shit
than the average bear though to be fair.
But like these,
these are the shit converse ones.
These are the shit chuck Taylors to the
shit.
They have no soul.
There's like,
just like the rubber soul,
but there's no cushioning.
It was like very little like sponge fans
were like that as well.
Yeah,
sort of.
like those thin,
thin,
soled shoes.
To me it's like that's how you're
supposed to walk.
You're not supposed to walk with this
crazy cushion on the bottom.
You know,
like whenever I do the UFC I wear dress
shoes and dress shoes have like a heel
and if you stand in them with that heel
for like a while,
it kind of makes your feet feel weird.
I don't feel good.
They want to get out of them.
Like if you weren't like converse all
stars,
you get out of them.
It's like,
not like your feet were hurting,
you know,
second skinny slippers.
There's so minimal.
They're like,
they're the best sneaker my mind for
like just wearing,
just walking around where I'm not even
getting paid by converse with though I'm
advocating the same way.
You'd be like,
look,
we should all be nicer to each other.
We should all get $12,000
a year and you can all have a pair of
these.
You can't pretend you too fancy.
She wearing converse all stars.
You can't pretend you like a super
fancy,
easy wearing man.
He's a caring man.
He might sell his.
He's like,
you might sell them as they've been worn
for awhile.
There's a secondhand yeezy market.
So there's.
You can.
Somebody will buy Warren sneakers.
Eyebrows were up looking at music,
cyber.
I've got some Simpson's bands from back
in the day.
The people that buy your offer for,
for,
for those as well.
Who I bet with him,
that dude who didn't want to take the 40
bucks balm with running shoes looked
like 1920.
Wow,
that's crazy.
It's got a heal.
They have cleats on them for their dress
shoes.
That's amazing.
Did they have tracks or were they just
running in the dark circle?
Probably had heels.
The Spencer Shoe.
Possibly the first pair of specialized
running shoes ever made all my God old
timey pictures.
Dude.
Dude,
that's amazing though.
Look at those stupid things.
This is off the topic,
but old timey picked your trigger to me.
Have you ever heard of the cuttings
fairies now?
So I guess maybe turn of the century or
the beginning,
like 1900 or something like that.
There are these little girls in England
that photographed themselves playing
with fairies.
Whoa.
And the world was exposed to it.
Uh,
not this wasn't the only person,
but uh,
what's his name sir?
Arthur Conan doyle.
There's a picture Sir Arthur Conan
doyle.
The writer of Sherlock Holmes was a
spiritualist.
And so he actually wrote an article
defending that picture.
Go.
You'd go through all the pictures.
Those are the [inaudible] ferry picture.
You don't want to take a leak.
Go ahead.
Paid for quite a while ago,
but it needs to be debunked.
Jamie,
tell him about your sneakers.
I was going to say keep talking,
but there was a will that says museum of
hoaxes.
I wonder what they talk about.
Oh,
this is a fucking hoax bedtime
hoax.
The,
uh,
the kids years later admitted that they
had kind of cut the picture.
They admitted something that if you look
at these photos,
you'll be like,
that had to be admitted.
Like to us.
It's very clearly she cut pictures out.
Those are pictures.
There's a two dimensional images of
fairies and pretty traditional fairy
imagery.
Um,
years later they revealed that they
traced the images that have a popular
book and put their own spins on them and
then cut them out and took pictures with
them.
But Arthur Conan doyle,
the guy that wrote Sherlock Holmes,
like really defended this shit.
Go.
No,
there are ferries,
there is another world and it's trying
to break through and these little girls
have been in contact with it.
Um,
you know,
and he was ridiculed by over half the
population because a lot of people
looked at that picture and saw what we
see,
which is kids with little cutouts,
pictures of fairies.
But there was a time where almost half
the world was like,
oh no,
that's real.
Yeah,
that could be real.
The cunningly fairs or pictures of these
kids fucking took Joe and the clearly
just blow one up.
Clearly fake as fuck.
Exactly.
But there was a time because you had
somebody like Arthur Conan doyle going,
no,
this is real and spiritualism is a real
thing and there are other races and
other beings and fairies are real out
there in the world defending it and
stuff.
And then finally late in their lives
when they were like,
nearly passed,
you know,
they said,
yeah,
we cut them out of a book and they
admitted to something that you knew
right away just by looking at the photo,
like,
oh,
that's fake as shit.
But in the twenties or whatever,
or back in the day,
oh yeah man,
oh my God.
You could show somebody a picture.
And they were like,
that's fucking real,
but you can only imagine,
I mean how gullible people were before
photos,
but when you look at it,
I'm like,
that's bullshit,
but I still think of the big foot video
and I'm like,
that Shit's real.
Like when he walks past the camera and
then he suddenly looks at the camera,
a thought on this,
on this topic recently,
like if you,
uh,
at like five years from now,
if like photoshop was erased from the
Internet's,
remember memories,
how could you explain photoshop pictures
to somebody?
It's a good question.
Like if we live to be a few thousand
years from now,
like if society goes down and then they
re build computers a thousand years from
now and they look at these old images
but they don't have the capability then.
Yeah,
totally possible.
There'll be like,
there was somebody standing on top of
one of the twin towers when a plane kid.
I remember seeing that picture and be
like,
holy fucking shit.
How'd they find that camera?
And then I was like,
wait a second,
dude.
Yeah,
we live in the age of Photoshop.
Do you know the guy who created
photoshop created with his brother is
the guy that created the store,
came up with a story for this new star
wars movie,
rogue one special effects wizard,
right.
And so one day,
you know,
they,
they work in the special effects because
him and his brother like,
you know,
this would be helpful like in a,
in a kind of home use setting,
you know,
like being able to take a photograph and
manipulate it.
So in their spare time,
dude,
like because they were working on motion
pictures and shit.
In their spare time they invented
photoshop.
Jesus Christ,
they must be gazillionaires Scott
Walker.
No,
John Carmack is John Carmack is the,
uh,
he's one of the original owners of ID
software.
Okay.
He's the head programmer lead
programmer.
He created quake and doom and,
and a bunch of different awesome video
games.
And now he also works on Oculus rift.
The uh,
yeah,
he's working on that.
A hero to the game community because he
created like arguably the greatest three
d shooter of all time.
A series of them doom,
quake,
quake one,
quake two,
quake three.
He,
uh,
in his spare time made rockets in his
spare time.
He was a rocket scientist.
So he
was,
he was coding the most complicated three
d graphics engines known to man for
video games.
Right.
Then in his spare times he's making
rockets.
He's a fucking rocket scientists for
fun.
Then he would take Ferrari's and turbo
charged them.
So we'd get these Ferrari's because he's
got ungodly sums of money for making all
these fucking crazy video games that
have sold millions of copies.
Right.
He's buying Ferrari's and reengineering
their fucking engines and his spare
time.
What do you mean?
What were you engineering twin turbo
charging for robberies.
So that makes a gigantic.
This was a long time ago,
man,
where a Ferrari would have,
like if it came from the factory,
maybe 400 horsepower,
he would jack them bitches up to like a
thousand his spare time.
Right.
He was making renaissance man of a real
life.
Buckaroo Banzai if you will,
a guy who you and I are barely in the
same speech to.
Yeah,
exactly.
Barely.
That's true.
In a moment like that,
you're like,
well,
I can't do any of those things by being
like,
well,
he probably can't make a real good Dick
joke and then that's not enough.
I'd much rather be him than me.
Better off to not balance yourself out.
How not to go.
Well,
he can't do it.
I better off to just go look at this
crazy motherfucker.
Appreciate someone else's ability.
Yeah.
The less time you compare yourself to
other people,
the better off you'll be.
Just enjoy how amazing people are.
Don't think,
man,
I wish I was at a managing that.
Well,
I think.
Well that's what I was going back to the
$12,000
a year for $12,000
a year for everybody.
I think what gets in the way,
it's human nature because you have some
people who were like,
why is he he don't deserve that 12,000
or he gets a lot.
He's got a nicer house and he's also
getting the $12,000
I'm getting.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I think that would start seeping in.
Yeah,
but he gets a lot because he makes money
on top of the 12,000,
so like his needs are taken care of.
Bucharest,
logical human animal doesn't always see
things logically.
Sometimes they'd just be like,
why?
Then when we get selfish that I was
12,000
years comes into problem when it comes
into.
Oh,
we don't know because I don't think it's
ever been really,
at least on a wide scale.
It's ever been practiced.
I'm with you.
I just don't think our system.
How many people did you say we had an in
this country?
300 something million plus Mexicans.
So do quick math.
What does that,
how much?
I'm sure they've done it out.
There was an argument by an economist
like a really well respected economist
for
universal basic income and I think the
number they were going by was $12,000
a year.
See,
I'm surprisingly supports universal
basic income.
Just Google that.
And because there was some,
um,
pretty prominent economist who actually
understands the system,
uh,
except for you and I,
they're like,
oh,
I got enough money I can do my thing.
Is this like Noam Chomsky,
Noam Chomsky,
he's,
um,
he's a linguist,
right?
So He's not a,
uh,
not going to be talking about.
Are you ever trying to follow Noam
Chomsky stuff on language to,
to like,
it's,
it makes you,
it feels like doing exercise with your
brain.
It feels like you're doing a workout.
Um,
the easiest way to I think take in some
Chomsky is,
is uh,
there was that movie they did.
It was a documentary.
Is the tall man happy,
I think is the name of it is the man who
is tall,
happy.
Um,
and it was directed by,
um,
the guy that,
oh,
this isn't my Michel Gondry the
director.
He made a very interesting documentary
that was partly animated in a
conversation with about Chomsky.
Yeah.
What was it called again?
Is the man who is tall,
happy,
I believe is the title.
And it's wonderful.
It's like beginners.
It's Chomsky for beginners because it's
very colorful and breaks it down.
But I've watched the other morning I got
up and blazed and watch three interviews
with him talking about postelection and
stuff and his take on everything.
And Oh my God,
like even at the,
and he's,
he's advanced in age at this point,
but that mind is,
you know,
sharp as a tack and it's one of those
magic and be like,
Ugh,
it's going to be a loss to lose that
money.
He's thinking about things that a lot of
others aren't in his thing that spooked
me.
Big Deal was a,
uh,
he said right now the whole world should
be focused on the,
on the Russian front on Russia and the
Russian front because that's where your
hotspot of activities like United States
and Russia have come in conflict
recently,
recently in a way that they haven't
since the Cold War.
And he's going in there.
You're talking about Su two super powers
with the ability to destroy the planet
shit that we haven't really thought
about since the fucking eighties.
And all of a sudden you're like,
oh,
is that what they meant by make America
great again?
Like,
let's be scared of the popular possible
nuclear annihilation.
Because I thought about that in years.
I'll be honest with you.
That was another thing that bummed me
out about the Clinton campaign.
They were Russian fearmongering.
One of the big things that she kept
saying during the election was they were
talking about being hacked and she's
saying it was the Russians,
so she was implying to Donald Trump
supports the Russians because he
supports the hacks and there's no
evidence to the Russians did it?
None.
I've looked at it.
People got mad at me and so that I've
looked into a deeply.
He.
There's no one has proven that the
Russians have done it,
but they're saying it is.
If they proven the Russians have done
it.
So one of two things,
either progressions.
They're not that they actually tinkered
with short.
I would admit it too,
but there's no evidence that they did
it.
Okay.
I mean who knows if they did fair point,
but the problem is if you say they did
it,
you got to know for sure they did it.
Otherwise I'm going to listen to you
every time you say you know something
for sure.
And I'm like,
this bitch definitely doesn't know for
sure.
You can't know for sure because you
don't have the information.
If you did he tell us what it was like,
you don't know.
And the FBI and the CIA doesn't say they
know there's a likelihood there's a
possibility,
there's a high probability,
but you don't know.
So until you don't know,
until you know you can't say,
you know,
because as soon as you do,
because you might be full of shit about
other things,
you might,
you know,
you might fill in the blank on a bunch
of other important stuff and pretend you
know,
when you don't know,
because that's what you're,
you're doing.
And I think that's another thing as
like,
as a civilization,
we can't allow that.
We can't allow that.
Like in Donald Trump,
when he keeps talking about these
millions of voters that,
uh,
that the illegally voted and kept him
from winning the popular vote.
You can't say that you can't do that
anymore.
Why?
Because you can't lie when number one
lie.
Number one,
you couldn't do that before.
He kinda seems to have brought it back
and it hasn't killed him.
He is in fact the president.
What you do this thing when you put your
hand on the ancient book,
Dude,
I'm with you,
but we're.
We're in the episode daisy him now.
Like it doesn't matter what used to be
and there is no more.
You can't because of things like that
where you're like,
well you couldn't,
but he did and everything worked out
fine.
I'm totally with you in terms of like
you shouldn't write fucking say that
because that starts breaking the system
down.
But then again we were just talking
about like,
is this a system that you even want to
place in a world where you're like,
do we need a president?
Who Cares?
What's being said?
Then like,
why?
Why does it matter if somebody being
like the really?
There was a people that voted that
didn't vote.
Yeah,
because he's the guy now see like if you
want that position,
you have to be under oath all the time.
That's what it's got to be like.
Totally.
Like if you really want to say that you
are so noble or you're so powerful or
wise or whatever you are,
that you have,
whatever your attributes are,
you're so awesome that you should be the
president.
I know you can't be lying about illegal
voters unless you have some data.
You can't say it until you have some
data.
You can't say it.
And once you say you got to have some
data,
but he got a lot of things with no data
whatsoever.
I know,
but we understand anything to get
elected.
But now we're beyond that.
I know still playing the same kind of
game.
I'm just,
I've just not grown comfortable with.
But I think,
um,
I have to learn to accept the fact that,
you know,
what I used to consider a fact is no
longer fact.
People talk about facts in this real
loose way now where they're just like,
well,
what is the fact?
The fact that you may not be effect to
me?
And it's like,
well that's not the definition of fact
at all.
The fact is a fact,
but people go,
what's factual for you may not be
factual for me.
We're on such a fucking slippery slope
now that a matrix,
that's the least egregious thing at this
point of him being like 2 million people
voted illegally because the dude was
literally saying he won the popular
vote.
Like right.
That's the first big kind of untruth.
Well,
as he said,
a lot of things that like sometimes he
chucks up to like,
I was kidding.
It's the same kind of thing.
It's,
you know,
someone saying that the Russians hacked
the Democratic National Conference or
committee or whatever the fuck it is.
Dnc W are you sure?
You know,
that's the same thing.
Like saying that like these are all like
whether the little tiny lies or whether
they're a leaps of faith or leaps of
judgment or whether they're just full
fabrications,
a,
you can't do any of them.
Shouldn't be able to do any of those.
I agree.
Like if anybody catches you,
like if you're in big government and you
know,
there's a video
of the FBI saying one thing and then you
say another thing when the Fbi told me
this and the FBI saying explicitly what
they told you and those things don't
match.
There should be a trial and she'd be
like,
are you a liar?
Like,
do you,
do you get interviews extended to people
that are like,
you know,
the president was born and should only
be when you have power Muslim countries.
Like if you,
if you're have like,
yeah,
he's a perfect example when he was
saying that,
that he was born in Kenya,
like trump was like a major league
birther.
Like that's a perfect example.
Yeah,
he was some theorize I've read that he
kind of jumped onto the birther movement
because he was like,
well,
if I ingratiate myself with this crowd,
that will be helpful.
If I want to run for president.
He might've like watched a youtube video
and it.
I'd like to think that.
I mean,
I don't like to think,
but I choose to think that he's smarter
than that.
Oh man,
he could have just been him like
recently he tweeted,
anyone who burns the flag should go to
jail and be rested.
And then they found out I read an
article online that they had just run a
piece on Fox News about flag burning.
So he was kind of informed by something
he just watched on TV.
Did you know tell most people tweet,
right?
They see something go like that,
but that's not what you want out of the
chief executive of a country.
At least that's traditionally not what
people want it.
But this time that seems to be what
people want.
Digital.
Hillary Clinton had proposed that very
same thing in 2005.
She proposed that flag burning should
have a stiff fine in a year in jail.
Like she said that and she's not the
president.
I know now that he is.
Yeah,
it's.
Well the whole thing is uber,
Uber Bizarre.
Where do you feel like and an and,
and I don't want to,
you know,
paying it cynically,
like this country has been here for
awhile and probably be here for a lot
longer than,
than our petty issues within,
in the moment if we have issues with it,
but I just,
you know,
just it,
it became a different world in the span
of six months.
Yeah.
I feel like it did to like,
you know,
in a way where,
I thought I had this down.
Like I think about this whenever I was
in school.
You'd read your history books and you'd
be like,
how come they didn't stop this?
Why did they know this was going on?
Like,
what the,
are you serious?
Like I'm sitting here as a child reading
this and I know that this is wrong.
Why didn't someone step in?
Why didn't Blah Blah,
blah.
I remember going to Germany the first
time with clerks and went to the Berlin
film festival and before screening me
and my friend Brian Johnson,
we were like,
well,
let's go see a concentration camp.
We're here.
Which goes,
he concentrated again and they're like,
dude,
you got to introduce a comedy in three
hours.
You really don't want to do that.
Compartmentalize.
I was like,
let me,
I'm here.
I got to see history.
And so,
you know,
we went to a boot,
can walled the one that says at mocked
fry over at work will make you free,
like the worst fucking lie.
And um,
it's,
you know,
obviously fucking sobering and horrible
and you know,
and they,
she seeing the dimensions and spaces
where things happened and whatnot and
you can't help but turn to the guy who
was our cab driver who drove us for
Berlin,
which was like 40 minutes out of Berlin,
maybe an hour out of Berlin and then
drove us back and you know,
he was waiting with us while we're
there.
So he went through the concentration
camp and he was born and raised in
Germany.
So I'm sure he's had to do this a number
of times with school or something like
that.
But you couldn't help but on the ride
back,
he didn't want to be that American Dick.
But it's like,
did anyone in your family?
No.
Did you guys talk about this?
Like how do they handle this sort of
thing over here?
Like how did you guys wake up after it
was all over and go back to what was the
new normal like you realize this is
fucking heinous,
you know,
and the guy was just like,
it's taught to us in school and there
was a moment when,
you know,
every young kid in school learns about
Hitler and the Third Reich and the
Holocaust that they go back to their
parents and start saying like,
how much did you knew how much to
grandma and Grandpa?
No,
blah blah blah.
So I think of moments like that where
I'm just saying I'm not,
I'm certainly not comparing this country
to the fucking Germany by any stretch of
imagination.
I'm just saying.
Not at all.
All I'm saying is like there are moments
in history where,
you know,
I thought we were kind of passed it.
History happens all the time.
You know,
obviously September 11th is a very big
historical moment in our lifetime.
But I really felt like,
well,
you know,
until like world war three,
we're probably done with history for a
little bit,
which is ridiculous fucking statement,
but now I feel like we're living in a
chapter in a history book.
Some kid in the future is going to be
looking at this chapter and being like
really?
Like they didn't know that's what they
did and I'm not saying again like I
expect horrible things from this guy or
anything.
I'm just saying the world is vastly
changed in a way that it's going to be
recognized,
recognized now and it will be recognized
when they write the book on this year
and when they write the book on this
year for years to come.
Suddenly we're kind of in that moment as
well.
But then again we probably were always
in a moment of history and I don't even
mean in a stoner way.
Like this is a moment of history and
this is a moment in history,
but history is not always that loud and
noticeable.
Sometimes it's quiet and they don't
notice it until later on.
But we've gone through it.
I mean,
I'm a couple of years older than you,
but we remember Reagan.
Yeah,
we remember the Iran Contra affair.
Is that what it feels like culturally?
It felt like.
So I was just having this discussion
with somebody else,
but in the seventies,
sixties,
sixties into the seventies,
you had this kind of progressive growing
America where suddenly,
you know,
maybe there wasn't as much segregation
and,
and you know,
people were.
People were kind of developing and
evolving and becoming more like the
world we recognized now and it felt
like,
you know,
like by showing you stuff like all in
the family and whatnot,
you know,
arts and um,
tries to push the edge of the envelope
at all times.
Try to put normalcy into something that,
you
know,
a situation that you maybe don't find
normal.
But if you see it on TV enough,
you're like,
Hey,
I'm over it.
And suddenly it's for real.
And stuff like that.
Felt like,
you know,
the eighties and Reagan.
And again,
I'm not a political creature by any
stretch of the imagination.
I lived through it,
but I was not active during it by any
stretch of the imagination,
but it feels like that time was a
reaction to the culture,
like,
hey,
things have gotten too loosey goosey
around here,
and then things got conservative for
eight years or.
Yeah,
and then it feels like things loosened
up.
I mean,
again,
I'm no political analysts,
but it just seems like if you look over
your history,
it contracts and it expands the
contracts and it expands,
but the contractions don't seem to bring
it back to square one.
You know,
it may be a matter of of two steps
forward,
one step back,
two steps forward,
one step back.
And if you do that enough of the course
of a nation,
there's growth and you'll see the
balance.
But you've got a bunch of people that
don't believe in the same things,
don't even see the world through the
same prism.
So it just feels like,
I don't know.
I mean maybe the idea,
and again,
a couple stoners talking about how to,
how to do the presidency better.
Maybe you just have an agreement where
it's like eight years of this,
eight years of that,
and that's only if it's a two party
system,
like what if you come up with a four
party system and you're like,
okay,
you only get four years and then the
next.
Then it goes to this party right after.
Then this part of this is a
multiple party system.
You can have a multiple independent
parties.
If you look at the ballot,
a lot of other people wanting to run for
president,
right?
Like Gary Johnson and Jill Stein and I'm
sure there were a bunch of other ones
that we don't know.
Yeah,
there was Zoltan Istvan who's the.
He's the trends in dent or transhumanist
party like a lot of people ran,
but that that's the system is just so
old.
It's just so goddamn ancient.
We're trying to patch up this thing that
we would never create today if it
existed today.
There's no way we would ever let one
person have all the fucking power.
I just think that human beings are in a
process of waking up and realizing how
bizarre our position is.
I mean,
and not just our position in America,
but our position on the planet earth as
it hurdles through infinity.
We were on a spinning ball that's
floating in the sky and hurling towards
the cosmos or through the cosmos and we
tend not to focus.
That alone is insane and we're
concentrating on whether or not gay
people should be able to marry or girls
should be able to get abortions or
whether or not black lives matter.
We're fucking hurling through infinity
and I think this slow process of
realization coincides with the
innovation that you're seeing from like
all these different new technology
companies that are coming up with better
and better ways to communicate,
whether it's cellular or a video or
whether they're.
They're using snapchat or virtual
reality rooms where they can all meet in
and it's going to keep going and going
and going and going and going and going.
Until we're in some sort of a matrix
world.
It's inevitable.
It's going to fucking happen.
You think we go digital ventures hundred
percent,
100 percent,
and I think we might not even have a
choice.
I think it's entirely possible.
We're going to create a new form of
life,
some new artificial form of life,
and that thing is going to be what goes
on from now.
We're going to merge with that somehow.
We're going to find out that they can
give you new eyes when your eyes go bad
and these eyes allow you to look at
navigation screens and Google things and
you're going to be able to get to be
able to stare straight at the sun.
There's it's,
it's inevitable that we're going to
improve upon the human body.
They're already replacing people's hips
and shoulders and knees.
They're growing fucking hearts in a
laboratory with stem cells that actually
beat.
They create a woman's bladder at a stem
cells.
She had bladder cancer.
They made her a bladder here.
We've got one for you.
Stitched it back in.
They're like,
whoa.
Like we're doing some crazy shit and
it's going to keep going.
Fifty,
60,
70,
8,100
years from now.
Whatever it takes,
we're going to merge.
We're going to merge with technology.
I heaven sitting here talking for a
little while and normally when you're in
the world,
you've got that fucking device in your
hand.
That's when I've noticed that my wife
says that all the time.
She's like,
you never separated from that phone.
Like I get up from side of the bed,
I pick it up and go to the bathroom
because I'm like,
well,
I might want to play a game or I might
want to look up some information.
Like there seems to be a human need for
data at all times.
Now we've trained ourselves to have debt
or to fingertips.
We no longer sit there and go,
what does that person's name now you're
just like,
oh,
I'll look it up.
Yeah.
So a lot of our thinking has been pushed
off to to technology that we've created,
so we feel comfortable with a gun like,
well,
you know,
we're smarter than that and it keeps
getting better and faster.
Do you think about it like all those
body parts you're talking about them
doing,
that's the last,
what?
Twenty years,
like prior to that there was no like,
hey will grow you a new bladder or hey
we can,
we can put skin on you again.
You know,
it wouldn't look like that and shit like
that.
So yeah.
What's going to happen?
Yeah,
you're right.
And the next 50 years
merge we're going to somehow,
there's this new Google assistant that
comes with the,
uh,
the Google Pixel phone and it's like
their version of Siri but it's superior
because it's contextual.
So I could say like,
uh,
how old is Kevin Smith?
And they'll say,
Kevin Smith is 46 years old.
Once you're working on these days.
Like it knows I'm talking about you.
I'll say,
what's he working on these days?
Kevin Smith just produced a movie.
It's called Yoga hosers.
But will tell you that about like,
yeah.
Great.
Same with my mom.
Like,
no,
I mean you have to be out on the
Internet like all the data and details
on the cruise and Craig's list trying to
get fucking cock.
Okay.
What is Craig's list?
It will tell you Craig's list is this,
is it?
How many of you have people on
craigslist or selling drugs?
Well,
we found a park something 5,000.
It's,
it's,
it gives you like contextual make it
much easier to like,
look,
I'm looking to have the girlfriend
experience.
How many people including digital Djing.
Well,
if you could get like sort of,
you know,
how bitcoin has sort of enabled people
still happening.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Don't you ever say that around and dress
Antonopoulos it's still going.
Curious that you.
Yeah,
we have this guy,
he prefers not to calm self bitcoin
Jesus because he doesn't like how the
story ends.
He likes bitcoin.
Buddha feels like it's better leads to
enlightenment problem.
Like somebody fucking hack their account
or something like that.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's.
Well there's a long conversation if you
want to go with no,
no need,
but that is actually an exchange that
got tapped into is the magic,
the gathering exchange.
All right.
That's what it started out as.
You know that game magic.
The gathering started off as that and
then during that time people started
trading bitcoin on that when it was
nothing.
And then that bitcoin became worth
hundreds of millions of dollars and then
they got robbed so all the bitcoin got
stolen out and this guy got in trouble
because he ran the site that he was
never know.
No one had any idea that I was going to
be worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and that this guy would lose it all.
So it was the whole thing was like a
really crazy and sort of fair,
but the spirit of Bitcoin is that you
and I can exchange money for services.
But with no third party,
just you and I know bank of like,
you want to buy this computer?
I say,
sure,
give me x amount of bitcoin.
And you sent it to my phone.
All right,
cool.
We got a deal and then you're done.
And this,
this idea.
You mean if you could get to the point
where are you're talking to your phone
and you tell your phone to order you a
pizza and pay for it in bit corn and
it's doing everything digitally and it's
winter big corn.
The corn already buying shits,
bitcoin.
What is it when it's a hooker bit Quan?
Ah,
oh,
that sounds great.
We'll have the corn,
but not everyone will have the quad.
What it was the climate meant like love,
respect everything.
MMM.
I don't know.
What does that package?
What does that mean?
Remember Jerry Maguire,
man,
he was always talking about that.
Don't.
He said,
uh,
it was the full package.
It was love,
money,
respect,
endorsement.
Hm.
There was a bigger deal than just like,
okay.
All right.
But go back to bit coin.
So it's still going on,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's some people who love it.
Yeah.
Like the very,
very democratic way to like my money.
Why do I have to go through this,
this,
and I understand those institutions and
FDC is all built to protect your money
but also seems engineered to keep your
money and get your money and take a
percentage of it as well.
I have the weirdest abstract take on
crypto currencies.
Okay.
I think that ultimately all money will
be digital and since digital,
since money,
if it,
if it all becomes digital like that,
money is basically information.
And the one thing that's keeping people
from each other,
like the re,
the one thing that separates us is the
barrier of information.
Like I can't read your emails,
can't read my mind,
you can't see my pictures,
you can't,
you can't know everything that you can
possibly know instantaneously.
There's like this barrier and that
barrier is all information,
right?
It's all trying to get,
trying to get like writing what,
what has someone written,
uh,
what is,
what is all the scholarly work on
astrophysics,
what does all that stuff like,
the barriers between us and those things
are slowly being removed.
Like there's more and more like if you
went on the Internet in 1996 and tried
to get an education,
you'd be retarded.
Like you're not have that education,
you're not going to learn shit.
But now like you can legitimately get
like a full college education online.
Plus you can read a million different
papers on all sorts of different things,
especially if you want to pay for them
on all sorts of different studies.
And actually in a classroom you could
almost never run out of things to
absorb.
Almost never run out of information and
I think that that's the one thing that
technology seems to be embracing is
closing the gap between people and data.
Closing the gap between people and
information will eventually that money
is going to be the only bottleneck to
reading each other's minds.
There's going to be like w,
there's what,
what money is if it's bitcoin or if it's
digital,
it's a one and a zero.
It's just a code.
So what's to stop me from getting into
that code?
What's the.
How come I can't get that code?
Well,
that's somebody else's.
Oh,
okay.
Like what?
What does that mean?
Like what does that mean?
Is it information?
Like what is it?
Can I get it?
Can I copy it?
Now if you copy this.
No.
Good.
Oh,
okay.
So it's a finite resource,
but that's fucking ridiculous because
it's not.
We're not talking about oil or water or
rocks or minerals or metals.
We're talking about some goofy fucking
numbers.
They've got an a goddamn commuter.
It's information.
It allows us access to resources.
Like we should all have access to all
the information and then it's going to
be some weird merging of digital minds,
some sort of a hive mind system created
by something like Google or some company
that figures out a way to allow people
to communicate thought that thought and
it's going to have money attached to it.
All of it.
It's going to be a big fucking soup of
information.
That's going to be the breakdown.
The breakdown is money.
Why?
Because it's information because if
money becomes informed,
this is obviously super stoner talk
good.
But if money just becomes one's and
zero's,
what's coming?
What's happening with Wiki leaks?
Well,
you know,
these,
uh,
these emails getting hacked data,
getting out,
uh,
you know,
so many getting hacked,
all their data,
getting out all these people.
There's the barriers are falling between
people and information.
They said in the government right now,
our government,
the love of.
I say something retarded in someone
nods,
like,
yeah,
that's fucking,
that's dumb to them.
They said that there are,
there's a deep need for hackers in this
country.
There's not enough because everywhere
else like hacking as exponentially over
the course of the last few years by
double the amount that it was and that's
why you're seeing things like they took
down Sony.
They took,
they took down this one,
so yeah.
I lately I've just been like,
do I really want to have all my world
online?
I'm the.
I go the other way where I'm just like,
well how do you protect that stuff?
How do you protect what you think you
will be able to for a while?
But I honestly,
the fact that you can't.
Well the trend is clearly going to the
cloud.
If you look at these goddamn new macs,
they don't even have a slot for a USB,
like a hug or a thumb drive.
You don't have a DVD player.
There's no other way.
You have to do everything wirelessly.
Like wow,
this is weird.
So you have a very minimal high hard
drives.
The hard drives of the new Mac.
Books are smaller than the old hard
drives.
They've made them smaller so it can be
lighter and lighter,
more compact,
but also you're not storing cheat on you
because they want to throw everything up
on the cloud and you're like,
Oh man,
where do you stand in it?
It's fascinating because on one hand I
think it's inevitable.
On the other hand,
digging my heels in the dirt and I'm
getting dragged along.
Sorry,
I got off the apple tip.
I've got a windows 10 laptop,
two terabytes of storage,
two terabytes.
You can't get the movies.
Any Mac whatsoever.
You could.
It cost you a fucking shit ton.
Way More.
Did they choose this upgrade?
Smooth.
It's great.
Windows 10.
So cat
people need them for business there if
they broke down all the time,
but just.
I just assumed they had to be better
now.
So I said I'm gonna.
Give it a try.
I've only been using it for a few
months.
Zero problems.
Super adorable.
Prior to this,
the whole time for like years since I'm
like the nineties,
you were one of those cats that you know
when it all collapses,
you're going to be fucked.
I'm fucked your fucking.
You've unlocked and gone off the grid
before anybody else.
You've thought about things that most
people don't think you have big things.
You don't just smoke and be like,
dammit,
life's good you.
You smoke and go deep on the big thing
on stuff that like,
like you,
like you pointed out,
very few people do.
It's usually stoners that the big issues
are that we all think of.
The big issues are nothing compared to
like you do recall.
We're hurdling through space on a
fucking rock.
Yeah.
Anything can happen and you're worried
about this or this nonsense.
Fucking gender identity,
pronouns,
Netflix or something like that.
Oh my God.
It's even the big things that people
like.
This is everything in life.
Yes,
so you do the Kentucky take on
everything beyond the.
Beyond the obvious,
beyond the temporal or the daily,
you're gone like what's next?
What happens 10 years from now?
What happens to us?
Not just,
Hey,
what happens to me?
Because that's very human nature to be
like,
what happens to me,
but your thing is what happens to us as
a species.
You're a.
you're a thinker and a seeker as well as
like about you,
man.
You're not content to just be like,
I think I know everything.
There is pretty
much to know that I'm interested in.
The rest of them are really not
interested in you.
You refill all the time.
I met a priest once.
We were sweet kid and uh,
he said not when I was a kid,
but I was like a grown ass man.
I was 20 somethings before I wrote
dogma.
So when I went out to film school and 92
in Vancouver and I was in Washington
state,
my uncle lived in federal way and so I
was like,
you know what,
I'm going to go to my uncles and then go
up from there.
You can drive me up,
drop my shit off and stuff.
Um,
and I'd never really left my side of the
world,
let alone fucking New Jersey and,
and stuff.
So,
uh,
at one point I was still struggling.
I was,
is the end of my Catholicism as I knew
it in childhood that I just believe
everything they tell me and stuff.
So I was having some troubles with it
and I went into,
was walking around and I wouldn't call
myself an emo kid,
but like I still was raised in it.
When you believe something from the
moment you're born,
like,
you know,
all the tenants of the Catholic faith,
uh,
I was an altar boy even for heaven's
sakes,
you know,
when that moment comes,
it's almost like the adult version of
when you know,
your parents are like,
there is no Santa Claus,
you know,
surprise where suddenly you're like,
what,
you fuck it up ended my entire
existence.
So I was going through that and I'm age
22 at this point,
should have gone through it in high
school.
But I held onto my own lot longer.
So I walked into this church and uh,
I sat down and a priest came by.
Eventually,
younger priests,
I can help you.
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm just having a crisis of faith and
just sitting here and praying and
meditating on it and stuff.
And he goes,
come,
come to the office,
we'll talk.
I went into his office and he was like,
what's the issue?
And it was like I believed in this shit
so much when I was a kid.
It wasn't even a matter of belief.
This was the truth.
I said,
but now I'm of this mind that like,
you know what?
We follow this Bible and supposed to be
the word of God,
but like thousands of years ago,
the bunch of people that followed a
bunch of other books that said there
were multiple gods and now we read those
books and go,
isn't that fucking quaint?
These fuckers thought there were 12
gods,
one for each thing that ever happened in
the day.
I said,
I'm afraid one day that like they're
going to turn around and say,
same thing about our book is this.
Like,
I just don't believe.
Like I believed when I was a kid and the
priest said something really smart.
I stuck it in.
The movie was so smart.
He said,
well,
he's going.
When you're a little kid,
I think of yourself as a small glass.
You're very easy to fill up.
It's going,
you put liquid in and you're done.
It's easy to top off a small glass.
He's gone.
The older you get the glass,
he gets bigger.
You can't expect the same amount of
liquid that filled that small glass to
fill the big glass.
And I was like do means like
periodically you gotta refill the glass.
Now he was talking about faith and shit,
but that goes for anything even goes for
intellectual intellectual pursuits or
just the person who's the seeker who is
not content to just be like,
I see it all as it is and I think I
understand it now.
You always understand there's more to
understand.
You go looking for the not just like,
hey,
that's kind of fucked up an interesting,
but what's really ultimately important
if you scrape away all the stuff that we
kind of concern ourselves with the shit
you think about.
Like you know,
and again this is just from fucking
listen to some podcasts and mostly
looking at your instagram feed is shit
that's like useful.
If it all went away and it's not just
like,
you know,
I know how to live off the land is so if
you're thinking big,
think about where the mind goes.
You know,
like most people look like you strong
and shit like that.
Don't fucking think nearly as much as
you think.
I know that's a stereotype,
but it's true.
You can't develop one set of muscles and
concentrated on another.
Generally speaking,
you were there.
Concentrate on building your brand,
building your body.
You've found a perfect way to build
both.
I think you'd be surprised.
What do you mean?
No?
Especially when you're smart,
you're smart,
but especially Jujitsu guys.
I know a lot of really,
really smart Jujitsu guys.
Of course,
just this week
stereotype to be like,
all muscle heads must be done.
That's the only thing I got it.
Do you know Josh Waitzkin do nothing.
He's the guy from.
He was the inspiration for the movie.
Searching for Bobby Fischer,
American chess champion.
He became obsessed with Jujitsu now,
Brazilian Jujitsu,
black belt under Marcello Garcia.
Like one of the most respected Brazilian
Jujitsu practitioners have two things.
Chess and Jujitsu.
That's unfair,
bad motherfucker Scott,
and he's a chess master and he's just a
brilliant,
brilliant guy and I mean,
but a killer,
like if you've got a hold of you,
he will choke you to death for sure,
but only if I did something to.
Yeah,
but I'm saying if you had to,
if you want it to.
I mean he's.
He's not just as genius.
He's a genius and a smart and he's
probably never described himself that
way.
He's a martial artist,
but his ability,
what he can do,
his specialty is strangling people.
I mean,
that's what you mean.
This comes from Marcella Garcia.
Marcella Garcia,
as you would know this,
but Marcello is famous for his chokes.
He's like a famous strangulation artists
like he said,
some of the most spectacular highlights
in the history of competitive Brazilian
Jujitsu.
Just choking guys unconscious.
It's an animal.
Never killing them.
Just taking them to the matches to black
belts.
Go at it.
You never.
You've ever seen.
Remember we had this little Garcia vs
Shaolin.
He barely ever seen and so quickly at
UFC match and you don't have to see a
UFC match because this is probably
something more interesting for you to
watch because no one got hurt even
though it looks like the guy was dead.
He actually just check the blood stops
the brain and then he lets it go and the
guy's instantaneously back like it's not
like a knockout,
suffering brain damage.
The scramble.
Marcella takes his back and he holds
onto the choke and Shalon tries to
squirm out of it,
but he lacks in the choke and now
challenge trying to fight gallantly
buddy goes asleep,
he's out cold here and the referee stops
it.
As soon as they realize now he's out
cold,
so marcel gets off of him and walks away
and Shaolin wakes up like just a second
later.
So he's 100 percent fine.
He just like,
well,
what happened?
He starts talking.
He's not like he got knocked out.
It's not like you got brain damage.
He just got choked unconscious like
he'll be instantaneously fine,
but Marcello was just choked up,
never totally out,
but have gotten super close.
I've gotten to like,
the elevator door is like closing in
that literally way it feels entirely
like the walls are closing in,
like the darkness is coming and you're
like barely can get out of it.
I've gotten to the door.
I never went totally asleep.
As you go into the door,
you're also smart enough to be like,
I'm not dying.
I tap.
Yeah,
you tap,
you gotta know when to tap pants.
Like is there a moment of panic where
like.
Yes,
for sure.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you definitely,
we saw like that dude was like,
he was like fucking go picked up by the
Eagle.
He was like before it was over.
But then he gets out Jujitsu.
Those,
those moments happen a lot.
So like if you go to a Jujitsu class,
it's very likely you might get choked
out three,
four times by one person.
Like if you roll with some guys,
a Brazilian jujitsu black belt and
you're like a blue belt,
pretty likely he's going to get you at
least a couple of times while you roll
with them.
Unless you're like really agile and
really good at defending yourself.
What are the chances of losing off your
windpipe carotid artery,
your carotids?
They literally like closing the blood
supply.
How dangerous that not not only if you
keep it on but clamped on like how long
a minute probably kill somebody.
That's I'm saying so like they have to
be.
You have to be a surgeon to be like,
I got them for 30.
I'm like,
well,
I'd like to find out like how long would
you have to hold someone would.
It depends on the person,
how a healthy they were,
how young they were.
I'm sure would have a factor as well,
but find out how long would it take if
you choke someone out before they died,
someone must've.
Someone wants to Google request that's
going to bring the FBI.
They're going to come,
but what if you could do that with a
body part [inaudible] I mean,
and you got to get a certain amount of
leverage on somebody's carotid artists.
Science reflex death is sometimes
considered a mechanism of death and
cases.
Granulation remains highly disputed.
The port of time from application to
unconsciousness varies from seven to 14
seconds.
That's wrong.
If effectively applied to one minute in
other cases with death occurring minutes
after unconsciousness.
So if you held on for a couple minutes
to the next show on,
would you have to choke ticket?
Yeah,
that's.
Is that from a forum MMA forum?
They might not necessarily know,
but it's on the Internet.
It must be true.
Let's read it and believe it.
Yeah.
Forums,
bodybuilding.com.
Ars,
Technica.
That one is um,
you know,
maybe they'll believe.
Think about it is super wrong right
there.
When it says varies from seven to 14
seconds,
it doesn't even take a second.
What do you mean you could put someone
to sleep in a second if you hit the
right,
if you have just hit it right.
If you just hold onto it right.
Especially if they're not resisting.
Like if they're hurt already and they're
relaxed,
you could just put them to sleep.
It's like if you,
if someone gets hit first and then they
get choked and they don't,
they don't defend it quickly enough.
Like if they're out of it and then they
get choked,
they just go to sleep.
Like real quick says anybody.
Nobody's ever been choked to death.
No,
I'm sure people have been choked to
death.
Just not in the UFC.
What I mean in the real world,
like that was the Eric Garner thing.
Well,
he had a breathing issue.
That was the guy who the police killed
in New York.
They took,
he was selling loose cigarettes in front
of them and they get mad at them.
I thought we were still talking.
You were.
They killed them with the choke
Brazilian Jujitsu.
But you're taking real life.
Yes.
Yeah,
but I'm saying you can choke someone to
death,
but I don't think.
I think he,
he died Maura's,
Ellie,
his.
He wasn't physically very well.
About three minutes is about the most.
Your brain can last without air.
Three minutes without air.
Yeah.
Oh man,
that's crazy.
So that would never it how like
basically he get out of you for three
seconds,
you'd be passed out and then they let
you go.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They would just let you go.
And in class sometimes people forget to
tap in class so they don't tap quick
enough when they go to sleep.
See,
I like the things you do,
but I have zero interest in doing the
myself.
Like they don't understand me.
Like every time I look at those
pictures,
I'm like,
fuck man,
he's living a cool life.
I'm like,
I couldn't do that.
Any one of these things.
We could certainly be an interesting
thing to admire an envy.
Someone's like freedom in life and still
not want to do it yourself.
Generally speaking,
when you look at somebody and be like,
I wish I was like that.
You want to do the things they do or be
the person they are,
but instead I can look at you and
appreciate what you do and who you are
and never wants to be like,
yeah,
that's a.
that's what I'm going to do.
I couldn't like.
You're into.
You're far too much of a man.
You're such a dude and not a dude like
you're a bro,
but you are like.
You're like,
it makes sense.
You're somebody's dad.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you are.
When I think of a man,
that's what I think of,
and I don't mean this to sound like
compliments.
I'm going to have a big head when I
leave your problems in life now,
my dad,
but I think you would be a cool dead
like your kids.
That's very nice.
Your kids have a.
have a wonderful lifetime ahead of them.
Have had great experience thus far it
seems like.
But for the rest of their lives they're
being raised by a thinking masculine
man,
man.
Like my kid will never have that in her
life.
Do you?
Would you want to be different than you
are though?
You seem super content with her.
You are.
The way I look at it,
it's just like everyone's dealt the
cards,
right?
Like,
you know,
and you could improve some things in
life,
but like you know,
like when we were young and they'd be
like,
that's your cross to bear.
When I was kid,
you know,
I was always having.
My mom would be like,
well that's your cross to bear.
You know,
as if like,
that's just something you're as if it
was genetic.
Because if she wasn't like she could
have said,
hey,
let's get you working out.
Maybe feed you less or whatever.
She's like,
that's just your cross to bear,
but you know,
the rest of your life is blessed and
stuff like that.
She probably just didn't.
I mean,
a lot of people say things like that
because that's what someone told them
and they never stopped to think about
it.
Oh,
her mother definitely told her that
your cross to bear is something that was
just kind of passed sanction.
My mom was a wonderful woman.
I just spent.
Oh,
you know,
she's getting old and stuff and I,
I,
I took her to see Dolly Parton and Tampa
and a Dolly Parton have seen three times
in two months.
Man,
she smells like she smells like cotton
candy and baby powder and dude,
she's high note here.
Let me try to hit you.
Always hit me to cool shit.
Dolly Parton is seven years old.
She just three hour fucking show.
She didn't sit in one place.
You moved all over the stage.
He played piano,
Guitar,
Banjo,
flute,
and at one point she blew a saxophone,
which now she didn't just blow
saxophone.
Like I had a few notes.
She played yackety sac,
which is like I can grant an,
an,
an in it that requires some fucking lung
power.
She's 70 years old.
I took my 70 year old mother to see her
and like mom's got a cane and we had to
get a people mover and stuff like that.
Like she's,
it's crazy man.
So like I took mom to go see Dolly
Parton and my mother,
you know,
God love her.
She's amazing.
One of my favorite people in the world,
but you know,
she's like tiger.
You finally made it and I was like,
why?
And she's like,
because like we got to meet Dolly
Parton,
I was like,
mom met Dolly Parton and any old title
and that's not a sign of prosperity or
success or something like that.
Like that happened back on clerks or
something.
But those days when Dolly Parton was on
TV,
there was only like three channels.
Yeah.
She pulled,
she fills arenas like it's crazy.
It's massive.
And just watching somebody like,
you know,
I saw her,
I saw her when I went up to Vancouver to
shoot an episode of the flash.
I went and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Then there's a part of me,
of course,
I'm not a big country guy,
but my old man loved country and Western
even though we came from New Jersey and
we weren't even from like Southern
Jersey,
Central Jersey.
He loved country,
west country mustard.
I hated it growing up.
And he's now dead for like 12,
13 years.
And naturally the older one gets,
you hear that music,
it takes you not to the president but
right back to your childhood.
So lately,
even though I've never been a country
person,
I find more country leaking into my life
and it has everything to do with my
father or something like that.
So I went to see the show and it was
like I might as well taking my dad with
me.
He's been dead so long.
But like that was his dream show.
Like he loved Ali parties.
Big Country Music Fan generally love
Dolly Parton.
So I went to see the show the first time
because I was like,
I got nothing to do,
let's go.
And then I was blown away by her
showmanship as storyteller as well.
She doesn't just sit there and play the
music between songs.
She'll sit there and tell you a story
about growing up in the rocky mountains.
She's fucking funny dude.
I know she's got like pattern she's
probably been doing for years,
but she talks about,
she's like,
when I was a little girl we went into
town and they grew up poor and she's one
of 13 children or something like that.
And she's like,
I saw this woman,
beautiful woman,
and she's painted like an angel and she
had pretty clothes and real big pretty
heritage burn heels and makeup.
And I said,
Mama,
who's that?
And her mom is like,
that's the town trial.
That girl is nothing but trash.
And she goes,
I said,
that's what I want to be when I grow up.
So that's why.
That's why she's got the look.
She's got it.
She's like,
it cost a lot of money to look this
cheap.
So she's hilarious.
She's like,
it's a true like even if you're not like
a Dolly Parton Fan,
like what a true night of entertainment
like and you just won't get appreciate.
I saw her like last weekend I took my
mom to see her in Tampa and time I saw
her at the Hollywood bowl and then like
a month ago,
and then I took mom to see her in Tampa
and that was more like,
Hey dad would love this,
you know,
but she had this weird moment where she
met Dolly in like,
you're talking about two,
seven year old woman.
And my mom went in for a fucking kiss.
Not like I want a friendship,
but just like the way you would kiss a
friend.
But,
and then you could see Dolly who's had
to politically maneuver strangers for 50
years or so.
Figure out,
do I say,
Hey,
I don't kiss strangers or do I just have
her lips were going for the lip on the,
what she was going for.
It was awkward too.
There was a moment where they were the
exparel and then finally they hugged and
uh,
you know,
she was like,
my husband loved your music and shit.
It's really fucking beautiful the see.
But mom,
I love mom to death,
but mom is like such A.
Everybody's mother is very singular
individual.
But mom like had this thing.
I was trying to figure out.
It was like,
when did this person die?
I think we were talking about Barbara.
I was like,
when did aunt Barbara di?
And my mom's like,
oh,
hold on.
And she had this thing when we were
kids,
like she'd get a calendar from church
and she wouldn't write on it your
birthday or a relative's birthday.
She'd write the day that they died.
So like this day was the day uncle Andy
die this day and Connie died.
So my mom keeps all that information.
So she goes,
hold on.
She comes out with a box of like funeral
mass cards.
Like when somebody dies,
you go to a funeral,
there's a little trading card that has a
picture of a saint and on the back has a
person's name.
And when they were born,
when they were dead,
my mom has like a collection,
the way you collect baseball cards and
shit.
And we spread them all out on the table
is 12 significant deaths in our family.
She had lots more,
but the ones that would matter to both
me and her in our immediate family and
between 12 deaths I was able to quiz my
mother who died in 1980.
And she was like,
oh,
that was grandpa Smith.
Like she is my mom's obsessed with death
but not in a like death metal.
When she was a child in Catholic school,
they tried to explain hell tour,
you know,
as you do in Catholic school.
And she was fucking far too young to get
the idea.
So death has been her obsession her
whole life.
Staving it off,
stopping it from like taking not just
her but her family,
you know,
she lost her husband to it.
We all.
Death is just a natural part of the
process.
My mom finds it like she's terrified,
but now I as a,
as a creative person.
And I wonder if you feel the same way.
And I fancy myself a creative person.
Some people like you're not very
creative,
but I fancy myself a creative person.
No caveats.
Death to me is not scary as much as like
a repugnant idea where you're like,
what?
Stop all this.
Like I'm just getting the of it.
I'm just learning like I got so many
more jokes to tell and Shit like that.
Like death to people who make stuff like
us and that's why you might be the
exception because you deal with death on
a regular basis.
Like with hunting and shit like that.
Like it's just something that probably
enters your purview farm with the month,
but it is like one of those things,
man,
were you like wow,
I hadn't really thought about that too
often.
But she's thinks about.
Often when I think of death I'm
irritated by it because I'm like,
it's unfair.
Like why?
But I imagine if I was like my
grandmother,
my grandmother lost her sight 12,
14 years before she died and I loved
hanging out with her.
I used to play cards with her and shit
like that.
And then when she lost her site,
like she did,
she was no longer just didn't living,
so she would sit around and be like,
how are you Graham?
You go visit her.
She'd be sitting in the dark and shit,
listen to the radio,
maybe no longer Christian like she used
to.
We used to play cards,
can do any of that shit.
So she just sat there and he'd be like,
how are you?
And she'd be like,
well I asked him to take me.
And he said he didn't answer,
still not today.
And I was like,
Ooh,
Graham.
She's like Jesus everyday I pray that he
finally take me and I'm still here.
And she grew slowly,
grew to be bitter about life and shit.
Now,
from where I sit right now,
I'm the guy that's like,
I never want this party to an oh shit.
But I guess there could be a time in my
life where,
you know,
everyone,
you know and love is past and you just
get to a place where you're like,
you know what?
I'm okay.
Like,
who was it?
Uh,
the singer that that just passed a law
was the guy that sang Hallelujah.
Leonard Cohen has been to have Louis and
Leonard Cohen didn't interview like
before he passed like five months,
five weeks,
maybe 40 past where he was like,
yeah,
I'm ready for death.
He's gone up pretty much done everything
I wanted to do and I'm,
I'm ready for it.
And he went fairly short there shortly
thereafter.
Grandma didn't Ms.
Young on for awhile but wanted to die.
I hope I'm never that person.
But you know,
what,
if something happens to me and I can't
move or something like that movie,
Johnny got his gun and Shit.
You hit that point.
It'd been really taking care of your
health.
Yeah.
You a little bit late in life just
because I was like,
oh shit,
I should.
I come from diabetic people,
Dad,
all his brothers and sisters,
very diabetic and I've played for my
whole life as if that wasn't a factor.
I never eat vegetables and shit.
Say packaged food.
So I saw that movie fed up and that
turned it around for me.
I lost like a bunch of weight because I
stopped eating sugar.
This documentary was fascinating.
It was abused cartoons.
Maybe that's why it worked on me,
but it broke down like,
oh,
this is what you do every time he put
sugar into your body.
And I was one of those documentary fed
up,
I believe it was.
Um,
I was one of those people.
It's like,
well,
sugar's natural.
Comes out of the ground.
So,
you know,
just like wheat and fucking flower and
vegetables,
I guess it's okay for us,
you know,
it's one of those things where it's
taken me a long time to accept the fact
that sugars much as I love it,
for me,
it's,
it's a poison.
It's like,
or it's like booze for an alcoholic,
like I can't stop.
I dropped sugar on my life,
lost 70 fucking pounds.
Then I let sugar creep back in slowly 20
came back.
So now I've gotten rid of 10 of it.
I've got another 10 to get back to where
I fucking was.
And I remember being free of sugar and
being like,
what a fucking asshole.
How'd you get back into it?
It's a slow,
it's a slippery slope.
Candy Bar,
10 piece of chocolate starts with a
piece of chocolate where you like milk
chocolate,
man,
I love milk chocolate.
I can handle this.
And then when I was working on the shows
in Canada donuts,
because they got Tim Horton's
everywhere.
Throw a rock and there's a Tim Horton's.
I got those Tim bits which are like
Dunkin donuts.
Munchkins a little donut holes.
I liked those.
Boston cream jammies.
Dude.
I love when they checked on the top and
the cream and jelly in that shit.
That's my religion.
I like a jelly donut to powdered sugar.
Oh my God.
Don't do this.
Just so soft.
I learned that I had.
I had to cut it out.
I had to put sugar way entirely so I
stopped eating processed or anything.
Processed or added sugar?
No sugar whatsoever.
Natural Sheer.
Like the closest sugar I'd get out of
drinking were beats.
I know I started drinking vegetable
drink though something.
I never did vegetable juice,
so I'm a big fan of cold press juices.
That's what I've been doing.
Stores too.
You can go and stop in and get them
done.
You could find out online like if
there's a store near you and then once
you know,
like for me I've got a bunch of them and
I stopped at.
I like to go and get something to drink
that's like really nutritious and
fucking powers you didn't like before I.
and this is,
I mean it's no secret or anything,
but here's a tip before I got to do
anything,
requires a lot of energy or something.
Like if I was going to go on the talking
dead or I'm going to fucking go to the
movie set or make some do show I get me
a fucking a big vegetable drink.
Basically I get one whole beat eight
fistfuls of spinach,
half a carat,
half,
half.
I stopped doing so much.
Abbott was a lot of sugar in it.
So about quarter apple,
big knob of Ginger Shit just burned to
my insides out kids in 1920.
We're playing on scaffolding and we're
scared of sugar from an apple were such
pussies who become such until now.
Now I'm like,
I can't.
I can't have the extra sugar,
so I make that dude,
I drink that and that gives me like,
like,
like beats fucking natural.
Amazing.
It's like I've never done coke,
but I imagine it's like we're doing a
line of coke.
I really don't think it's anything like
that is like doing dope beats make me
feel like a,
not just beats but like,
oh,
a good robust vegetable juice.
You feel that God,
Ooh,
I could get a little,
you know,
that was one of the things I like about
your instagram feed you,
you put a lot of food in there and you
talk about like what it does for you and
you're like,
look at his shit.
Fucking natural and I'm getting all this
out.
It's food porn because it gets
repetitive.
I get it.
What do you mean it gets repetitive?
Oh,
would you cook it?
Oka Gun.
Fucking fuck it.
You know,
that's what you get.
Do you then stop and be like,
did you realize your hurdling
through space on a fucking rock?
Anything could happen.
I just think that.
I think it don't bother saying it,
but yeah,
I get it.
But people always looking for things but
also criticizing.
Yeah,
but it's fun if you're eating out again,
it's not like it's not a one time
experience where like I've eaten out
when I was 14 and of course when a man
eats can never again,
so got to expect you might redo a meal
if I give you some.
When you cook it.
What kind of meat is it?
Elk.
Yeah.
How do you cook it?
I'll teach you.
I'll show you how to put it on.
I'll give you some real simple.
I'll give you.
You kill this thing.
Yeah.
I'll give you an elk burger.
That's the simplest.
Got Him out of it.
You just got it.
Tastes like it tastes really good.
It's super healthy for you because I
mean no hormones,
no antibiotics,
no nothing.
It's just wild.
Elk Meat was very lean and if you cook
it like as a cheeseburger,
you have to kind of cook it pretty quick
because it doesn't have much fat in it
at all really.
It's really lean protein.
Yeah.
Very high protein content.
So meaning like it's going to burn fat,
don't,
don't cook it.
Maybe as long as you would like a real
fatty beef burger,
just cook it a little less time.
What's A.
I think the last time we talked we
talked about that.
Like the idea of you'll go out hunting
but you eat what you,
what you bring back or whatever.
I eat everything.
It's Mark Zuckerberg.
That one year was like,
I'm only going to that kill.
Yeah.
I mean from the minute we were all like
that savage,
and then afterwards we were like,
oh,
I see.
I'm not doing anything.
We're all doing.
If we we eat beet.
That's my point.
So like if you're,
if you're buying food from a store or
restaurant,
you're,
you're killing it.
You're just killing it with a card,
a credit card or a check book.
Or if you're eating meat,
you're killing things.
Yeah.
You know,
you might not be doing it yourself,
but my whole take is that if an animal
is wild that's in the,
in that wild animal,
you kill it.
Like that thing was wild.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's whether you ever existed or not.
That thing did exactly what it did.
That's the pure life for one of those
animals and you're saying,
well,
why would you want a hunter doing
killer?
Something's going to like,
this is what you don't understand.
These things are not.
They're not going to live forever.
They have a very short and brutal life.
They usually get taken down by coyotes
or mountain lions or.
I mean when.
When a person comes in and shoots a
deer,
that is the best death it's ever going
to die.
If a person doesn't do it,
that just died in my bed at age 80.
Now they free surrounded by my loved
ones.
They freeze to death.
They get hit by cars.
I want to.
Can I make this board clear?
They fucking freeze to death.
They don't live.
They don't live very long.
If a deer lifts to be like seven,
that is an old fucking deer.
Really?
Oh yeah.
So if people are upset with you eating
any kind of animals at all,
they're not going to understand why you
would be upset at hunting.
But my,
my kid is total vegan.
Great kid about though she's not judging
me as I sit there and eat meat and shit,
but she's,
you know,
her thing is like she fucking loves
animals and what does she do to
supplement?
Like our essential fatty invited me a
question because the Diet I've seen for
a Vegan now,
I've been around it quite a bit is
insanely limited.
Like yeah,
like when I pull sugar out of my diet
suddenly you're down to fucking 20
things because everything's gotten milk
and sugar added to it.
When you go vegan and not just
vegetarian,
I mean fucking leg,
straight up Vegan.
There's like,
you know,
everything green and maybe three other
things in the world.
Like you can't even eat a Bagel without
being like,
did you use this or this or this or
something like that.
Kenneth eggs,
which is a really unfortunate because
eggs are never going to be a living
thing.
He,
that's what people don't understand.
I could understand if you're against
factory farming,
but I think that's a different story.
Like I.
my chickens are pretty free range there.
They live in a big cute coop and I know
a lot of people don't have room for
coop.
I'm not saying you need to do it,
but all I'm saying is you can have
chickens that exists in some sort of a
natural environment.
It's not entirely difficult and they
give you eggs.
They don't have to worry at all about
anything bad happening.
This is just a natural product of being
a chicken.
They lay one on their own.
It's not fertilized and no one's going
to eat it,
but not every egg becomes a chicken.
Not.
No,
no,
no.
They have to get fucked.
The rooster has to come along and sling
that Dick.
That's what makes a chance.
So if there's no rooster then.
So essentially,
dude,
I didn't know that until I was like
fucking 39 years old,
man.
Me Too.
I didn't.
I think you told me last time it might
have this,
but the.
I'm a repetitive motherfucker.
I will to do it.
I liked reading that you eat elk more
than once.
Oh wait,
so it's Kinda like a chicken's period.
Yes.
And matter of fact,
Peta developed a whole campaign to try
to get people to stop eating chicken,
egg,
calling it the menstrual cycle and also
showing a fucking frying pan with a
bloody maxi pad sitting in the frying
pan.
I don't know if that's very effective,
dude.
I mean,
that would gross me out,
turn me off.
But I,
I'll like pull it up.
So I never want to.
I'm kidding.
I never want to eat a tampon again.
Foul,
foul that they chose to do this.
My kid doesn't get like shitty or
political about it or like,
you know,
in your face or you got to live my way
and stuff.
But every once in awhile it slips out.
I'm a big milk drinker.
And so,
you know,
she's uh,
her whole thing is not your mom,
not your milk.
And I was like,
what do you mean?
She's like,
well,
that's not your mother.
You if you want milk,
you should get it from your mother.
That's,
you took some of the baby cows.
And I'm like,
oh,
come on,
don't do this to be good.
I was like,
they raised us to believe in milk.
I watched a lot of commercials.
Milk does a body good.
They taught me that on television.
Don't tell me that I'm taking milk from
baby cow.
She's kind of right though,
right?
Yeah.
Were you down on milk [inaudible]?
I saw your.
Every time I talk about milk,
people put up the little picture.
You talk on stage and they put a bit of
your routine we talked about right
before the show.
Oh,
that Vegan?
Yeah.
Were they say Vegan?
Say No,
we're the only species.
Gut do it.
We're the only species that drinks the
milk of other animals.
I'm like,
you know what else?
Only humans do
fly planes.
Make movies.
Call each other and tell each other how
eggs come from chicken ministration.
Look at that.
Oh,
it was a bloody underwear.
I'm sorry.
I thought it was a maxi pad,
but that's a real p to add.
They put a bloody pair of women's
underwear.
Oh my God.
The tagline is donated eggs period and
period is in red.
Wow.
This psych.
Come on.
What's gross is factory farming.
That's what's gross,
but it's gross is having all these
chickens packed and stacked into these
horrific cages and warehouses.
That's what's gross.
What's not gross?
Is it chicken living in a chicken house
that occasionally lays an egg and when
they lay an egg then they just wander
off and they just wander around the yard
and packet grass and do chicken stuff
because that's.
If a chicken is living in a healthy
environment,
they're not even scared of you.
Like I go near my chickens all the time.
I can pick some of them up.
Some of them don't,
don't fuck with it.
They won't let you pick them up,
but if you do,
if you try to pick it up,
you have to chase them.
They don't try to go after you but they
don't want to be picked up,
but some of them will just stay there
and you pick them up and pet them in.
My girls will hold onto them that they
all have their own little personalities.
Are they dirty now?
Surprisingly,
they don't feel dirty.
You know?
They take dust baths though,
but their feathers I think can brush off
a lot of things.
I think they keep themselves fairly
clean just by whatever the composition
of their feathers are there.
Interesting little animals.
You eat the eggs.
Do you eat the chickens as well?
No,
I don't eat the chickens now.
It just feels fucked up.
I agree,
but I mean,
but so do you chicken engine to those
chickens?
I just don't like animal farm.
Some chairs are more equal than others.
Yeah.
These chickens get a pass.
They're there within my control to every
chicken in front of them.
Not in a shitty way,
but hey,
it's chicken tonight.
Did we kill the chickens in front of
them?
We put them on a fire in front of them.
We set the fire up in front of the
children,
which be fucking kidding.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
I was like,
oh my God.
Imagine if I like the shit.
That was with Vlad.
The impaler used to do vlad the impaler
that Mary Shelley based.
Not Shelley.
Marisa was bram stoker.
Bram Stoker's Dracula on that.
Vlad,
the impaler guy would eat people in
front of other people.
He would.
Why?
Just a crazy killer late.
Maybe look up earlier.
That's what once she.
She made one of her victims eat,
cook,
and eat themselves.
Elizabeth herself.
A little girl said,
oh my God,
she was a monster.
How do you.
How do you cook and eat yourself to make
someone cut a piece off of their body?
Oh,
that was what Vlad.
Vlad did that as well.
He also put people on stakes in front of
his house and he would eat lunch while
he's watching them slowly rather than w
when someone has a stake through their
body doesn't kill them like right away.
They can puncture with the stake and the
stake as long as they put it through the
right spot.
Although you have like massive internal
bleeding,
the state kind of keeps it all in their
launches.
Yeah,
it's all stretched out and in your body
is kind of like if they stick it into
the right way,
it takes a while to die.
Like you could take hours.
So they're sticking this literally
through your asshole and out through
your back.
That's it in through your center.
I mean they could do it a bunch of
different way and they never show you
that in any of those dracula movies.
Like put that asshole put the stake
right through his asshole.
Now Standard up.
I mean maybe they go through a long,
maybe they go through one side and go
through a lung,
but either way there's ways they can do
it where they would put you through
stakes where it take a long time for you
to die.
So these people would all be moaning on
steak steaks are probably going in dry
too,
right?
Oh yeah.
They don't lose that shit up at all.
These people were moving.
You're going to die to stake going
through your asshole first then up
through your body.
But the good news,
we have some light cane is pretty
slippery.
We're going to spray the outside for a
stabbing.
This fucking gigantic steak.
Oh,
that's tough to.
Well this.
There's a real human.
I mean that was a real human that really
did live.
Yeah.
Look at this.
This is the ancient pictures that were,
these are from a long fucking time ago.
These images,
some woodcuts yeah.
Yeah.
He's just like right on.
And he's sitting there eating while
these people were on stakes in front of
them.
And of course,
you know,
you have to sort of process like how
much of that was myth?
How much of that was folklore,
how much of it was real,
what was the point at him there too?
What was the choices?
Well,
he was just a,
he just wanted to make sure that
everybody knew was a bad motherfucker
and if you uh,
it wasn't like trying to live forever
while he became so hard.
Whenever you're talking about people and
you like definitively describe like who
they were and what they were and you
know,
how it's history just gets so twisted
and distorted.
Especially back when there was no video
tapes and no,
you know,
writing a drawings going like,
wow,
yeah,
I mean,
how many of those people were even
writing things down?
How many of those people could even read
back then?
How many of those people actually saw
that was probably passed down like I was
in this village.
People on sticks and like,
I'm going to draw that.
Like what year was that,
Vlad?
The impaler 14.
Forty eight to 14.
Seventy six.
Somewhere in there.
Good luck.
1,400.
Good luck saying exactly what that guy
said.
Exactly what that guy did.
Good luck.
We can't even decide how many illegal
voters are.
Darling Donald Trump to calculate.
Yeah.
I think my biggest takeaway from the day
of the little people.
Yeah,
it was weird,
right?
That's.
I had no idea.
I mean,
I know there've been like,
like,
uh,
well I thought there were pygmies and
stuff like that,
but that's like,
that's,
that's a totally different species of.
Yeah.
Smaller brands,
smaller chimps size brands.
So it's not a homeless.
Florian Florian,
I think it's called the some better.
A few better images of them where they
recreated what they think it looked
like.
Some of these pictures literally looks
like an innocent version of what they
would show you as a troll in storybooks.
And look at that one right there.
The one that you just passed,
Jamie,
with the top
row with a spear and the animal and the
shoulder.
Look at that.
Have you?
I think if you go full image as a full
image to see over there,
you can see what it looked like.
Yeah.
See that's what they believe.
These things look like.
Like sort of semi chimp,
like humans that were three feet tall,
but they had tools.
What do you think the discussion was and
like,
do we give him a dick?
Like yeah,
everything's got.
Not Everything but some things.
I didn't put a dick on it.
He's like,
come on.
No.
Was dragged from everything else.
Is Dixon the shadow?
They're like sort of Dick on,
but don't make it look too big.
His Dick is wrapped up in a riddle.
Is a mystery wrapped up in an riddle
inside into the Nigga.
Dude,
I got to end this.
I gotta go.
I got here.
Yeah.
I think we did things with you like a,
a like a springsteen concert.
Let's see who drops.
First thing I think today I have too
many things.
I have three sets tonight.
What do you mean?
What are you doing with resets at the
comedy store?
Oh really?
Shit.
I got.
Yeah,
there's a belly room show,
a main room show and an our show.
Your best one starts in an hour.
Go.
I got shit.
I got to do my friend.
This was really fun.
This is awesome.
Again,
sooner rather than waiting.
Fucking short brother.
Always a pleasure,
man.
You mind?
We have these fun conversations,
but I think we spend so much time
complimenting each other because we like
it because we just need to wait.
We can go deep on other things,
not each other.
Yeah,
because if we compliment each other like
every time people would be like,
these guys are super gay for each other.
Yeah.
It's like every four years it's not
close enough for people to make the
assumption that is our third.
I think so.
I think I did one with you.
I did one with at our house and I think
one of them our house first.
Then with you and then this is the
third.
No,
this is the fourth.
Then was the other thing,
I feel like I've done your house twice
then.
Okay.
Then you did the first time you did with
me and the wife.
Then maybe you can did one solo with me
and then we did one solo.
The last time we did one,
you showed me that cool treadmill type
desk thing you had to standing standing
desk and I was like,
oh,
that's genius.
You have to walk and type at the same
class and they're working.
That's a fucking,
that's a sweet movie.
Like a year and a half.
I think I used that.
Eventually the treads started slipping,
so I'd be walking and uh,
one time I hit my chin up desk and the
desk was down here so I had to go like
this far and I was like,
you know what,
sue those pitches.
Maybe we were meant to stand at a desk
or walk,
but never at the same time.
Don't quit.
Now.
Back on that motherfucker.
I say wrap it up,
put it on an angle.
So you have to hike,
like you're hiking through the extreme.
I'm lucky to walk up school.
The English running shoes on shoes
running and heels and shit,
man.
All I need is a hat with a buckle on.
It looked like a fucking pilgrim.
Thank you,
sir.
Thanks for having me.
Really,
really appreciate it.
So much fun.
We keep saying this,
but let's try to do these regularly.
I try to do these right there.
So much fun.
I agree.
Kevin Smith.
Leave.